foreign
Services social media marketing can have
a great impact on growing your brand
hi guys welcome to this complete social
media marketing tutorial by simply learn
in this video we'll be covering some of
the most important topics related to
social media marketing now let's have a
look at them our instructor Rob will
take you through how you can start with
social media marketing Facebook
advertising some of the tips and
strategies that you can employ how to
rank YouTube videos how to increase
YouTube subscribers how to increase
Twitter followers how to increase
Instagram followers and some popular
social media marketing tools that you
can use imagine it's the year 2004.
this is Phil Phil's looking to release a
book and set up a Blog he's sure that
it'd be successful but he's only worried
about one thing he doesn't know how to
ensure that his book reaches the right
target audience who could enjoy his book
during that period of time however there
were only a few forms of advertisement
available like print ads Billboards
radio Direct Mail direct sales and the
television all of these options were
pretty expensive their effectiveness
couldn't be accurately determined and
they didn't let him advertise his
content to the appropriate audience
Phil's book would never find the
audience it deserved now let's have a
look at the same scenario in the present
day alongside traditional forms of
advertising Phil would have access to
digital marketing the form of marketing
that's a lot more lucrative inexpensive
and configurable marketing that would
enable marketers to advertise Their
audience digitally using channels like
search engines websites social media
platforms emails Etc among these types
social media marketing cotville's eye
social media marketing would give Phil
the opportunity to take advantage of
social media platforms to advertises
content to a highly targeted audience it
would help more people learn about this
book increase the interaction with his
audience It's relatively inexpensive
unless he goes into advertising and will
help him get Marketplace insights that
might help in understanding his audience
preferences better Phil started by
taking up a certification to learn about
social media marketing
since he was already familiar with the
concept of social media marketing his
next step was to learn about the
different types of content he could post
on social media some of the most common
forms of content that Phil could post
would be images text posts polls and
videos
but over time Phil begin to notice that
not a lot of people were being exposed
to his content Phil needed to advertise
his content for that he would need to
use the advertising options provided by
the social media platforms like Facebook
Instagram YouTube LinkedIn and Twitter
most advertising platforms offer users
with a number of different options like
image ads these ads involve the use of
single or multiple images that are
attractive and have the optimal amount
of text they also have a call to action
that encourages user interaction Phil
could use images from his book advertise
websites that sell his book and more
then there are text and post ads these
ads could advertise posts or excerpts
from Phil's blog or his book further
garnering interest from an interesting
audience
you could also use video ads Phil could
use video ads that feature favorable
reviews and customer testimonials to
advertisers books Phil could also use
lead ads through which he could collect
information from users who are
interested in a Weekly Newsletter or
regular updates from his blog but that
wasn't the only thing Phil could do with
social media platforms he could create a
brand for himself and drive audience
interest to it engage with him create an
identity engage with content finding
content that works for him social media
platforms also allowed him the
opportunity to Target audiences based on
demographics like their age location
gender and much more and in time Phil
began to see an increase in the number
of viewers coming to his social media
page and by extension his blog he also
saw an increase in the number of people
who bought his book greatly increasing
his audience here are some things he
learned one to set goals that were
quantitative smart and follow a constant
deadline two to understand his audience
by engaging and connecting with them
three to set up a social media calendar
to plan competitions polls surveys
videos and more
4. using tools like buzzsumo IFTTT
buffer and more for lead generation
creating email lists setting buyer
personas and more
5. to perform visual storytelling with
the help of images and videos but how
did Phil get so good at Social Media
Marketing Phil taken up simply learns
digital marketing course it was thanks
to this course that Phil had the skills
and training to get good at social media
marketing and now you can too by
clicking on the top right corner and
with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of social media marketing the world we
live in now it's highly digital place
but that wasn't always the case until
four years ago so if we rewind letting
people know about your products was a
little harder then so even if you go
back say five or ten years promoting
your products wasn't as easy as it is
today I mean people had to resort to you
know good old-fashioned newspapers
putting in an ad or those big thick
books called The Yellow Pages that
usually sat in your closet and wait a
ton I mean those were the ways to get
your product a message out there a lot
of advertising in those Yellow Pages
then you have billboard words you know
driving down the highway you see that
billboard on the side of the road you
wonder who are those people that are
actually advertising this stuff of
course you have television that's been
around for decades a good source of
advertising but costly and then facts
facts ads uncommonly known way to
advertise by the way who has faxes now
but people did advertise via fax just a
few decades ago so these were all the
ways in which people had to get their
product and service out there it seems
like so archaic looking at it now but
back then that was legitimate that was
the way to do it and then one thing made
our lives a lot easier so if you're a
marketer you're thinking to yourself man
I'm glad I'm a marketer in today's day
and age because it's social media
marketing social media marketing has
made everyone's lives better from the
company that's selling the product or
service to the marketer promoting the
product and service to the end user who
wants to see that product or service and
engage with that product or service so
social media is a good source of getting
your product and service out there and
it just makes everybody's lives a heck
of a lot easier so we're going to answer
that million dollar question and what's
that million dollar question it's how
can you Rise Above the Rest and so
today's session is going to be how to
start with social media marketing so you
can Rise Above the Rest leveraging this
great platform that we all take
advantage of today so let's start by
asking the question what is social media
marketing social media marketing
involves increasing website traffic it
centers around engagement it offers you
the ability to increase your brand
awareness and it has other marketing
goals you know so you can create various
forms of content for different social
media platforms so that's really in a
nutshell social media marketing so again
if we want to increase our traffic or we
want to increase our engagement like
likes or comments then look no further
than social media marketing if we want
to engage with our users our customers
our potential and prospective customers
we can really put a personalized
experience in place using social media
marketing we want to create different
forms of content like videos and blogs
and infographics and other types of
graphics with the potential to actually
go viral what we mean by viral is
spreading like wildfire one user sending
it to another as rapidly as can be and
before you know it you get you know
millions of views and millions of likes
I mean that's the power of social media
marketing so why do we want to do social
media marketing and I think we just
answered some of those questions but
let's dig a little bit deeper we
mentioned in our definition of social
media marketing that we have the
opportunity to to really build our brand
awareness and that is no more truthful
than with social media marketing more so
than any other digital marketing channel
social media marketing allows us to
really put our brand in a good light in
a good position in front of the right
eyeballs so it allows us to really
improve our brand by pushing out the
appropriate content in front of the
appropriate people social media is a
great channel for that we can look to
conversion rates so if we are pushing a
product and service in front of the
right eyeballs and we are building up a
funnel of prospective customers who then
turn into customers who then turn into
loyal customers who then turn into
lifetime customers we could see at every
step in the process that our conversion
rates may increase we can certainly
leverage social media marketing for SEO
for search engine rankings it's about
off pages SEO is about posting content
on social media platforms to build up
some link juice okay so there is some
inherent benefits to working SEO and
social media side by side it's cost
effective well if you're posting content
on Twitter or Facebook it doesn't cost
you anything it just takes a little bit
of time and creativity now if you want
to go ahead and do some advertising on
these platforms yes it's going to cost
you but you'd be surprised not going to
be as costly as say other search
platforms like say Google or Bing where
you're actually paying for keywords and
paying per click for those keywords so
social media marketing can be very cost
effective and then increase top funnel
traffic so it goes all the way back to
Brand experience and brand awareness if
you're putting yourself in position to
get seen by your target audience okay
your target audience goes from seeing
your brand for the first time to getting
to know your brand a little bit more to
maybe buying a product or service from
your brand then returning to buy another
product in service and then continuing
to buy that product or service I mean
that's increasing the top funnel traffic
and not just the traffic but the
conversions so at every step in the
process social media allows you to build
that funnel depending on where somebody
is whether they're seeing your brand for
the first time or actually returning to
purchase the product or service again so
that's the inherent benefit these are
the inherent benefits of social media
marketing now we talk about social media
marketing what are the channels used for
social media marketing how can we use
them it's really social media marketing
is a channel in itself so let's take a
look at the platforms involved with
social media marketing now there are
some really popular platforms so if you
can't tell just buy these logos then you
probably have not used social media
marketing or or social media platforms
before are taken part in social media at
all but you know one would like to think
that the majority of your users out
there today know what Facebook is what
the logo looks like what it does same
with Instagram which is owned by
Facebook LinkedIn B2B platform it's
YouTube great very popular video sharing
platform and then Twitter which is
considered microblogging but still
social media so these are the most
popular popular platforms out there but
there are hundreds of social media
Platforms in fact when we talk about
social media marketing it can be
anything from microblogging to video
sharing like YouTube to B2B networks
like LinkedIn to say bookmarking sites
like stumbled upon content sharing sites
like Reddit q a sites like quora so
there's plenty of different types of
social media platforms out there in fact
if you folks have any popular or you
think valid social media platforms that
these listeners here should really get
to know and understand and use then go
ahead and put that in the comments
section underneath this video I'm always
interested in knowing what social media
platforms are out there and what people
are using how platforms are trending
what's popular what's not and ideally as
a digital marketer where my target
audience is so these are the most common
but there are hundreds out there
hundreds so let's talk about the most
popular social media platform and that's
Facebook so Facebook is an average of
2.27 billion monthly active users now
that number is fluctuating because we're
talking about billions billions billions
of monthly active users and that
number's probably trending up 88 of all
users are on mobile so what does that
tell you that tells you that Facebook
has an app and the app is very popular
in fact I tend to use the app more than
I use the the webpage for Facebook okay
so I don't necessarily log on via the
Internet on my laptop I go right to the
app it's just easier easier to
disseminate information easier to add
friends comment respond Etc so it's no
surprise that 88 of all users use mobile
now 66 percent of mobile monthly users
use Facebook daily so a lot of recurring
users going back on a day-to-day basis
two-thirds so it's an addiction more
than it's anything else because what
Facebook is is really you're getting
information from the people you trust
care about like work with share a group
with share common interest with partake
in the same organization maybe have the
same running group same passions I mean
that's what Facebook is it's a
commonality amongst people and if you
build up a network of that commonality
it's going to be addicting to take part
in them you know the closest Network
work you can ever get to is your family
so if your family's on Facebook then
likely you're going to be on Facebook
communicating with your family via this
platform especially if you don't live
close to your family or especially if
you don't live close to your friends I
know in the United States you know
people move a lot for work or people
travel a lot for work and so Facebook
bridges that gap between distance and
you you know you do feel like you're
part of somebody's life on a daily basis
being on Facebook so that's what makes
it The Addictive part so if you think
about it from an end user's perspective
it makes total sense now if you wear
your digital marketing hat you're
thinking hey two-thirds of monthly users
are using it daily and there's billions
of active users then whoever I'm
targeting has to be on Facebook now if
we look closer at the demographics we
could see that a lot more seniors age 65
plus are using Facebook so 60 plus
percent of seniors are using face
Facebook so Facebook is trending older
however 35 percent of the audience is
below the age of 25 so it's not just
trending up it's also trending down so a
lot of young people are still using
Facebook and then Facebook you know is
pretty evenly matched between males and
females now if I'm either slowly no
feeling older or skewing younger on my
target audience and half female half as
male then I know somewhere in there
whoever I'm targeting is going to be on
Facebook just based on these numbers
here so your demographic is likely going
to be on Facebook again depending on
your industry depending on your product
or service but considering the number of
people and how it's skewing older and
younger and everybody in between
Facebook has something for everyone now
Facebook allows for video content so you
could post videos all day long so if you
have YouTube videos you can and share
those YouTube videos on Facebook in fact
video just like on most platforms tends
to provide better engagement and the
industries that can really capitalize on
Facebook tend to be food and beverage
news and media and e-commerce meaning
you're selling a product Facebook has
you know plugins and that allow you to
really accentuate what you're trying to
sell when I say that accentuate I mean
really incorporate an opportunity for
people to use the Facebook platform to
not only just engage not only to share
but to buy taking that process a step
further so if you're selling a product
you can more or less set up a a Facebook
shop if you will and sell your product
there so that's why it benefits those
that are are in the e-commerce industry
selling a particular product or in the
food and beverage industry now some of
the most like pages on Facebook spans
across many many Brands but let's just
take a look at Coca-Cola for example in
Coca-Cola just pretty much pinpoints
everything great about what you could do
on Facebook I mean you could see here
they have their opening page is a video
and so you can see they're posting
different content about you know this is
about a grant how they're helping the
city of Atlanta you know they're talking
about recycling so to me these are
community-based posts so they're not
necessarily just pushing out their
product per se they're trying to use
Facebook to build up brand awareness so
a huge Fortune 500 company like
Coca-Cola is not necessarily just using
Facebook just to push e-commerce to push
a product they're out there you know
pushing what they're doing for the
community so this is a good example of
you know how you can really leverage
Facebook taking advantage of everything
Facebook has to offer and that means
brand awareness Community Building
you're sharing you know updated
information not only about the company
but in this case Coca-Cola is situated
in Atlanta Georgia in the United States
so you know what are they doing with the
community okay so this is a good example
of course it's a big example because
Coca-Cola is a big company they're
worldwide but the great thing about
Facebook is you can always take a peek
at what other companies are doing
whether you have a million plus people
liking your page or a hundred plus
people liking your page you can always
get ideas as to how they're leveraging
Facebook now if you do have a company
you can create a Facebook page for your
business just like Coca-Cola so you want
to be able to separate out your business
from your personal page and like
everything you do whether that's writing
a blog or creating a video you want to
have original content that's relevant to
your audience you want to use Facebook
for some promotion but every post
doesn't necessarily need to be promoting
your product or server service you saw
what we just witnessed on the Coca-Cola
page it was about what they were doing
to you know benefit the Earth with
recycling or what they're doing in
conjunction with the with the city of
Atlanta so they're more community-based
posts and so to me that's original
content positive content that isn't
necessarily pushing their product per se
now you could argue hey it's Coca-Cola
they have the biggest brand in the world
and that's true but just think about
your product and service think about
your brand if you're trying to build
brand awareness what does your brand
stand for and if your brand stands for
say the the globe the ecosystem the
environment then you probably want to be
pushing out Post in that direction if
that's what you stand for as a brand
then you want people to know that
because like-minded people are on
Facebook and those like-minded people
are going to be the ones who like your
page who engage with your content and
tell other people about it so you always
want to go original you want always want
to be true to yourself and true to your
brand and then you could take advantage
of user generated content like sharing a
user's experience of using your product
so in other words if somebody's engaging
with you or they've posted something
about your brand and product you can
reciprocate and you can certainly post
something that is similar to what
somebody's doing with your product or
brand so that's a good way to create
some original content by taking
advantage of what the users have
generated so these are just some
examples of how to take advantage of
Facebook I mean there's lots of things
you can do on Facebook plenty of things
if we float back to Coca-Cola page you
know you can see they have you know
careers they have different videos they
have reviews they have community so
nowhere in here do I see an e-commerce
platform now if you are selling T-shirts
then hey you can put something in there
to help you sell that t-shirt but
Coca-Cola's strategy is hey what can we
do to help build up our community what
can we do to fundraise so if we click on
fundraise you can see they have you know
an N AIDS campaign here if you look at
simply learn just as another example you
can see what simply learns done as well
you could see they have information
about us they have different events they
have a community link as well and so you
can see what they're posting as well and
there you can see they're posting
visitor photos so there's lots you can
do on Facebook you can post polls you
can put your Instagram feed in there you
can add testimonials so there's a lot
you can do on your page you just gotta
get creative and take advantage of
everything Facebook has to offer be true
to yourself and before you know it I
mean you're gonna have you know a number
of likes on your business page as well
so some other tips about Facebook when
it comes to content you want to schedule
your content okay you don't want to just
continue to post back to back to back to
back you want to space your content out
and the another great advantage to
Facebook as I already mentioned about
social media marketing that's
advertising so Facebook owns Instagram
they have a great tool for communicating
called Facebook messenger and so you can
advertise leveraging Facebook Messenger
you can leverage Instagram and what you
need to do is if you go to Facebook's ad
manager and you create a campaign when
you go to create a campaign you're going
to click on placements and depending on
what you're trying to do let's just say
you're trying to build brand awareness
you can actually hone in on you know
Facebook you can hone in on Instagram
you can do a number of different things
within Facebook you have different ads
available to you from single image ads
to video ads to Carousel so you have a
lot of options and the biggest option on
Facebook when it comes to advertising is
your audience who are you targeting so
remember Facebook has old young and
everybody in between between men and
women and so you can specify
specifically Target interest you can
specifically Target gender and age a
location so Facebook really allows you
to hone in on who your audience is if
you're advertising and so that's the
great thing about Facebook they have a
lot of users and you're you have an
opportunity to hone in on a segment of
that user base now Facebook also has
metrics that you can look at to really
understand how people are interacting
with your ads how are people are
interacting with your post so let's take
a look at that so if we go to Facebook
when you go to your page you can click
on insights and you can actually see
some insights on posts that have been
posted on your page you can get insights
into how many people viewed it how many
people liked it how many people engaged
how many people you reached with your
post okay you have information about
videos followers Facebook provides
recommendations so this is all part uh
Facebook insights so if you're posting
on Facebook Facebook will give you
feedback as to how your posts are
performing now if you're running ads on
Facebook you can simply just view
metrics related to how your ads are
performing so you can see how many
people clicked on an ad how many people
the ad reached how much you've spent
okay you can look at it by demographic
you can even see cost per result so you
can get a lot of good insights into how
your ads are performing as well so if
you're running a campaign targeting a
specific audience on Facebook you can
look at the you know stats and metrics
surrounding that campaign and again for
your Facebook page you have Facebook
insights so if you have any questions
you know feel free we have a video
called Facebook advertising uh tips and
tricks so feel free to you know take a
look at this video on simply learns
YouTube channel for more information
about Facebook okay and if again if you
have any comments to share about
Facebook feel free to put them under the
comments section okay let's turn our
attention to one of the platforms
Facebook actually owns Instagram so
Instagram is a place where you can
actually promote your brand product or
service through the power of imagery or
video and so the average number of
monthly users on Instagram reaches 1
billion and 32 percent of all internet
users are on Instagram so a lot of users
using it it's very easy platform to use
you just the only prerequisite you need
your mobile phone so you open up that
app it's as simple as just uploading
uploading an image that's why Instagram
is so popular because it's just a simple
tool to use to go ahead and just post an
image with some hashtags so 68 of all
Instagram users are women so unlike
Facebook it does tend to slant more on
the females side and 59 of the audience
is a bit younger between age 18 to 29 so
Slants more women and Slims more younger
and so if these particular demographic
and age groups tend to fit your target
audience then Instagram is a place you
probably want to be for social media
marketing so as I mentioned content that
works best are photos or videos I would
always slant towards videos if you have
them available but photos you know the
rule of thumb is photos always tell a
thousand words a thousand stories a
thousand interpretations images are just
always the best way to go as well I mean
if you don't have the videos hey nothing
to be sad about if you fall back on
imagery so you can really put your brand
in a good perspective and a good light
by posting images and as you can imagine
if 18 to 29 year old women are on
Instagram gram you know that's skewing
towards a certain demographic but in
terms of Industry it is open to most
Industries but the ones that tend to be
most successful are Beauty food and
beverage and e-commerce now food and
beverage always tends to work well when
you have video and imagery likewise
Beauty but e-commerce if you're selling
that t-shirt or shoe you know Instagram
allows the platform to work in a way
where people can purchase that product
right within the platform so that's why
it tends to work well with e-commerce
okay there are lots of channels just
like on Facebook lots of channels on
Instagram I mean some of the most
followed brands or Chanel Starbucks Nike
I mean if you have a product or service
that you want to push out there then
Instagram is the way to go just for
brand awareness if you're selling shoes
then why not take images of and photos
of those shoes and get them posted on
Instagram like I said it's very simple
to use all all you need is some hashtags
to go along with that photo of a shoe or
photo of that cup of coffee and
Instagram kind of takes care of itself I
mean photos do accentuate the product if
you have them so leverage Instagram if
you're really trying to build up some
brand awareness for a particular product
some best practices here on Instagram is
you know have a compelling bio a good
profile picture you know add a link to a
landing page and you know leverage
emojis if you have to so set yourself up
nicely on Instagram you know if you're
in a particular industry like food and
beverage follow other food and beverage
Brands like Coca-Cola like Starbucks
depends on what it is you really want to
be related to so just make sure they're
relevant get hashtags can't stress that
enough you know when you post a photo
there's some hashtags in there you could
see what other people are hashtagging on
Instagram and you can ride that wave of
what's trending or you can create your
own unique hashtag I I'd probably have
two to three hashtags per photo and
don't be afraid to use both photos and
videos videos do tend to work well on
pretty much any platform they tend to
work well on websites and blogs so why
not use them on social media where
people can engage okay so videos and
imageries both work well on Instagram
okay you can also get shout outs from
other influencers you have plenty of
influencers on Instagram especially in
Beauty especially in food and beverage
fashion tends to be another industry
that has a lot of influencers so feel
free to reach out to them reciprocate
see how you can work together where they
can actually you know give you a shout
out on your particular product you want
to keep your Instagram account updated
and you can update those with Instagram
stories it's basically you showing off a
particular product you know over a span
of a few seconds or even a minute that's
an Instagram story they're very popular
uh easy to use you can even run contests
to boost engagement so for example if
your particular product is a particular
food like a hamburger you know hey post
a contest about you know allowing your
followers to post the best good looking
tasty you know Hamburger as an example
or it could be something else in terms
of fashion hey what's your best outfit
on a Friday night before you go out for
the evening you know there's always
things you can do to Spur engagement
especially on a platform like Instagram
where people like to post photos and
then I mentioned this earlier with
Facebook ads you can run Instagram ads
to give a particular post a boost so if
we take a little snapshot of what we
have available in Facebook ads manager
you can choose Instagram as the
particular platform so if you just want
to advertise on Instagram when you go to
your placements you could choose just
Instagram either the feed or the stories
okay so you can choose one of these two
options if you want to want to boost
your posts get some more eyeballs on
that it's a cost per click platform so
anytime somebody clicks it's going to
cost you but you know just like Facebook
you know the cost per click tends to
slant a little bit lower it really
depends on what you're trying to post
when you're trying to post it who else
is posting but hey the Instagram feed
and the stories could be a good option
if you're really trying to draw
attention to a particular product okay
let's turn our attention now to the bdb
platform called LinkedIn linkedin's a
very powerful popular business to
business platform okay it has 260
million active users monthly and unlike
Instagram where Instagram Slants more
towards women LinkedIn Slants more
towards men 57 so a majority of the
users are men but still you have a lot
of women involved in on LinkedIn so a
nice you know a nice mix between both
genders 38 of the user base are
millennials you know a lot of young
people older people a nice mix from a
business lots of different business
segments different levels of business
different business Industries and
verticals are on LinkedIn so don't be
you know shying away from uh LinkedIn if
you're demographic or target audience
tends to be older just because 38 are
millennials doesn't mean anything it
means that everybody's using it just
that means that hey you know more than
one-third of the users are millennials
are younger now LinkedIn is a B2B
platform so if you're in the business of
generating business leads then LinkedIn
is the place for you to go there's
opportunities for you to advertise on
LinkedIn okay there's also opportunities
for you to post lots of different
content on LinkedIn so content that
works on LinkedIn could be a Blog it
could be you know particular news
article you know 10 tips and best
practices I've posted videos on LinkedIn
you know it's good for jobs he says a
lot of content on LinkedIn so if we take
a sneak peek at LinkedIn if I just go to
LinkedIn here you know and I just go to
my home uh the start news page you know
I could see the types of content that's
been posted so somebody just posted
something with an image you know then
you got an article down here okay you
got you know an influencer Like Richard
Branson posting so you got a lot of
different types of posts that you'll be
able to see and you know leverage if you
want to meaning when I say leverage if
you see somebody like Richard Branson
posting something hey stay fit and
healthy you know that's an image that's
something about not about business per
se but you know something interesting
and unique so you can see all sorts of
different types of content based on who
you're following on LinkedIn and who
you're connected to some things about
LinkedIn you always want to create an
engaging Pro profile when I say engaging
first things first make sure it's
complete I mean there's lots of
opportunities so if you sneak over to my
profile here you want to be able to post
a lot of information about yourself so
about what you're affiliated with what
jobs you've held what groups you're
associated with what your interests are
what certifications you have so you want
to be able to you know complete your
total profile you can create a company
page for your business so if we go back
to LinkedIn we can just do a search for
say simply learn and let's take a look
at you know their business page so if I
just do a search for simply learn here
so if I select their page you can see
just like your profile page if you have
a business page set up on LinkedIn you
want to make sure it's complete you want
to put information about the company
what jobs are available and you want
your company to associate with that
business page anybody who does you know
follow that particular business page
part of the organization is going to be
listed under people so and you want to
be able to post just like on your
personal profile if you have a business
page you want to be able to post unique
content I mean you can see here simply
learn is posting you know some of the
accolades that they have but they're
taking that a step further they're also
posting you know information about you
know upcoming events and webinars so
they're posting a mix of different
content and that's ideally what you want
to do on any social media platform is
mix it up and just like you can on
Facebook just like you can on Instagram
you can you know boost a post per se
okay so you can get that post in front
of some additional eyeballs now of
course you want to optimize your company
page for searches so it really does come
down to how many people are following
you but when you say when we say
optimize your company page just make
sure it's complete with some compelling
content and then increase the number of
followers you have so the great thing
about LinkedIn I like the most is that
you know you can you know simply look at
other people if I go back to say the
home page you can actually see who's
following what and you know LinkedIn
does give you opportunities to connect
with people okay so if I go to your if
you go to your profile you'll be able to
see other people that have viewed your
particular page and you can connect with
them okay or connect with people who are
like-minded or similar or connected to
people that you know so LinkedIn does a
good job of presenting other people you
can connect with so it makes it easier
for you to increase the number of
followers so having an engaging profile
personal profile you know having an
engaging company page making sure both
your personal and the company page have
all the content necessary have all of it
completed and then increasing followers
posting unique content I mean that's
really the key to LinkedIn now again
with LinkedIn you can use different
media you can use videos SlideShare
presentation images and you can boost
content as I mentioned before you can
boost content on LinkedIn so if you want
to get that content in front of eyeballs
you can do that so let's take a look at
an example of a campaign and what you
could do on LinkedIn in terms of
sponsored content so if you go to
linkedin's campaign manager I mean you
have an opportunity put your ad in front
of a particular audience so it really
depends again on who you're trying to
Target just like Facebook which Slants
more towards personal LinkedIn is going
to slant more towards business so with
LinkedIn you have an opportunity to
Target a particular industry a
particular company a particular job
title okay so you could Target
everything business related on LinkedIn
so you can go ahead and create an ad the
ads have imagery to support the ad and
so basically when you set up your ad you
set up your target you can choose your
placement you're going to be able to see
you know who it is you're actually
targeting and you can go ahead and great
thing about LinkedIn is you have
different ad formats and again you can
get really creative with who you want to
Target and just like Facebook you know
LinkedIn has you know some metrics that
you can measure and figure out how your
particular campaign performs by
Impressions by click click the rate even
conversions cost per conversions and how
many leads so LinkedIn has built-in
platform for measuring campaign success
and so the differentiation between
Facebook and Linkedin is really just the
type of demographics that you have to
choose from you know with LinkedIn you
do have you know different options
available based on business like your
job title or job level or industry or
vertical so you have a lot of examples
available a lot of options available to
you on LinkedIn in terms of advertising
okay let's talk about you YouTube now so
YouTube has 1.9 billion active users if
it was a search engine it'd be the
second most popular search engine the
highest number of monthly active users
in decreasing order starts at the United
States Brazil Russia Japan and India all
big markets all like to use YouTube but
YouTube's popular across the world just
like Facebook where the app is popular
the app on for YouTube is very popular
so 70 of All Views are generated from
mobile so with YouTube being a video
platform you nef definitely need videos
now there's a lot of Industries on
YouTube a lot of Industries and some of
the most successful brands on YouTube
you know range from logo to Coca-Cola
you know pretty much to every brand if
you're a brand you want to be on YouTube
because of the massive reach that
YouTube has to offer coupled with video
and how great video is in terms of
Engagement it's a just a great
combination okay so some best practices
here for YouTube you want to optimize
your video for SEO to get views and so
we have a video that we've created at
simply learn how to rank YouTube videos
so if you watch that video you'll get
some really good tips and strategies
about how to you know optimize your
video for YouTube the very least you
want to make sure that you know using
right the right keywords and the title
description and hashtags so that's a
start when we talk about optimizing your
videos you want to upload regularly and
fix a schedule for your videos because
if you're starting to get followers on
YouTube or subscribers they're going to
expect you to produce more video
especially if you're producing engaging
unique relevant content for that target
audience so we're not saying you have to
have a video once a day or once a week
start small and build up and get on a
regular schedule okay and then you can
organize your videos in the playlist so
you know if we look at simply learn you
know simply learned does a good job of
organizing their videos into a playlist
so all you have to do is go to
simply learns uh YouTube channel and you
can see how it's broken down into
playlists now YouTube also has the
ability because it is global you do have
the ability to provide translations so
if your target audience is from another
country it probably wouldn't be a bad
idea like Facebook and Instagram or like
LinkedIn you can advertise on YouTube
you would just need to do that through
Google ads so with Google ads you're
going to say Google I want to advertise
on YouTube and you have plenty of
available options to available to you
anything from you know pre-roll to
showing up in the middle of a video to
showing up you know before or excuse me
at the end of a video all the way to
Native content marketing where you know
your ad is showing up next to a video so
you've plenty of options for advertising
on YouTube and then just like on
Instagram there are influencers on
YouTube you know feel free to reach out
to these influencers and see if you can
collaborate in some way where maybe you
post their video on your channel they
post your video on their Channel and
vice versa so you want to be able to
maybe collaborate somehow to get some
views on your video okay let's talk
about Twitter now so Twitter is a micro
blogging platform and so when I say
micro blogging I mean Limited in
characters Limited in how much you can
actually post but it's very popular it
has 326 million active users per month
and it does tend to slant a lot towards
Millennials a lot of young people use
Twitter and a lot of people use it to
get their news so no longer are the days
of grabbing that newspaper no longer the
days of going maybe to a media news site
online you can quickly go to Twitter and
get all your news right there in a feed
and easy feed let's take a peek at
Twitter here you know I can get
everything from you know somebody
posting something specific about their
dog you know all the way to a particular
job you know all the way to Industry
news you know all the way to basically
an advertisement all the way to a
specific news article so it's all here
on Twitter in your feed so Twitter does
offer videos so videos do work well so
if I go back here you could see you know
here's a video of Antonio Brown he's
posting a video of his news conference
and another promotional video so
industries that capitalize on Twitter as
you can guess if a lot of people go
there from their news you'll probably
see a lot of news in media and
entertainment on Twitter so that doesn't
necessarily mean that you can't use
Twitter for your brand it really comes
down to target audience some of the most
influential brands are slanting more
towards you know news and media but you
know you got Cosmetics you got gaming
companies you got everybody's on Twitter
okay it just comes down to does this
platform have your target audience and
given the nature Twitter you know how
can you get your particular brand
product or service out there and so many
characters okay some other advantages
and best practices you could use on
Twitter so I would recommend
implementing Twitter cards and really
all Twitter cards does is allow you to
attach Rich photos or videos and
different media experiences to tweets so
when you can attach you know rich media
like videos and images to tweets it can
help Drive traffic and engagement to
your website all it's going to take is
just a few lines of markup to your web
page and then users who tweet links to
your content will have a quote-unquote
card added to the Tweet that's visible
to their followers so that's how it
works I would certainly look to get
Twitter cards implemented if you are
going to use Twitter as your platformer
choice for social media marketing so it
does enhance the experience for the end
user and because allows you as an
Advertiser or as somebody Leverage
social media to really enhance your
Tweet and it just provides a better
experience for the end user who's
looking at your Tweet and so like
LinkedIn you can really take a look at
who's trending what's trending on
Twitter so Twitter makes it easy for you
to you know follow so here they'll list
a who to follow so these who to follow
are similar to what you've been posting
or similar to your industry and then
here you can look at Trends you can look
at what hashtags are trending and so if
you click on a particular hashtag you
can you know follow a particular you
know person who or an organization who
tweeted something so you always are
reminded in Twitter who to follow and so
it makes it easier for you to pick and
choose who to follow and build up your
following fairly quickly because Twitter
actually provides you with opportunities
on who to follow just like LinkedIn just
like YouTube just like Instagram there
are influencers out there people who
have a large number of followers who
tweet on a regular basis who tweet
original content who get high engagement
these are influencers and these are the
people you want to engage with so look
for those people on Twitter follow them
I mean the rule of thumb is if you
follow someone on Twitter you know
generally they're going to follow you
back so if you can engage and follow
influencers you have an opportunity to
see not only what they're tweeting but
the ability to communicate with them and
engage with them as an influencer so
maybe they can retweet one of your
tweets and get that tweet out in front
of their followers so you can advertise
on Twitter and the unique thing about
advertising on Twitter you can you know
promote your Tweet just like you promote
a post on Facebook or Instagram or
LinkedIn but more so I think than any
other platform is the use of hashtags
and so use appropriate relevant hashtags
I always tend to use a unique hashtag
but also depends on what you're tweeting
about if there's something that's
trending and again Twitter will tell you
what's trending in terms of hashtags if
it's something you're tweeting about
then go ahead and use that hashtag as
well you can have multiple hash tags in
a particular tweet and so don't be
afraid to use a unique hashtag along
with a hashtag that's trending because
the whole idea is you want your Tweet to
get noticed and then you can use tweet
chat or some there's some other tools
out there that are available to allow
you to find people to follow and these
people might be interested in your
product or service because you know they
can fit your target audience or you can
connect with like-minded folks who are
in the same industry or have similar
products or interest so tweet chats
available for that reason and you want
to take advantage of these tools because
again with Twitter it's easy to build a
following but you want to build a
following that is going to to engage
with your tweets so let's talk about
what tools are available for social
media marketing so when we talk about
all these platforms available to us okay
we talk about Facebook and Instagram and
we talked about LinkedIn and Twitter and
YouTube I mean those are popular
platforms but at the beginning of the
session I mentioned there's hundreds of
social media platforms out there and if
you're posting content on a number of
them you want to be able to organize
that content you want to be able to
organize it and schedule it you know
where it makes sense and when it makes
sense you want to stay organized and so
there are tools available to help you
stay organized tools like HootSuite
buffer or Sprout social okay some of
these tools are available you know at a
cost of a free trial or at a low cost
per month so regardless of whether using
a free version of one of these tools or
another tool not listed or you're
actually paying for it it's worth the
investment if you're going to partake in
social media marketing and even if
you're on one platform it's still worth
it to have a social media tool available
to help you schedule and not only do
these social media tools help you
schedule they do a lot of other things
too for example they help you measure
the engagement of your post so let's
take an example of one of them like
Sprout social so if I go to sprout
social here I can see for a particular
company I'm able to see you know how my
post and get were engaged okay so I
could see daily engagements on
particular platforms I can also you know
schedule my post so I can go ahead and
pick a time and date to schedule them
and so I can go ahead and post something
and put it in a queue to be published
for example tomorrow or next week or
whatever the case may be so these tools
do a lot for you I mean they help you
discover new followers they give you
in-depth reports they help you stay
organized and so to me it's worth the
investment to look at one of the tools
list it here you know these are some of
the more popular ones to maybe even a
free version but regardless of how much
you pay and what tool you're using it's
still worth the investment just to make
sure you're scouting your post at the
appropriate time so you're not posting
something back to back as an example and
you're able to measure accordingly so
it's nice to be able to go into a tool
like Sprout social go to reports and
measure you know in one place you know
how Twitter is performing or how
Facebook's performing or how linkedin's
performing and so that's what's a lot of
these tools provide is nice reporting
options and nice scheduling options so
you can find more content you can create
by using these tools again you can
schedule efficiently analyze them and
you can use insights to improve your
campaign so a lot of these tools give
you nice insights to how the post was
actually engaged and you want to be able
to leverage that and some of these tools
if not all of them have social lists
listening and social listening is
monitoring what's being posted out there
so what else is posted you can take a
look at and if it's something
interesting or relevant you can go ahead
and follow or take part in that
conversation okay so that's what social
listening allows you to do and a lot of
these platforms have that as a feature
so let's take a look at tips to be a
good social media marketer so some of
the important things you should take
care of are set up a social media
marketing plan when I say set up a
social media marketing plan there's some
questions you want to be able to ask
okay what platforms am I going to use
what's my objective on each platform in
fact and before you choose the platform
you want to figure out what your
objective is in terms of social media so
your objective could be different on
each platform it could be brand
Awareness on Facebook and it could be
promoting a particular product on
Twitter your objective is going to be on
each platform you want to be able to
choose your kpis and align your kpi eyes
with each platform meaning what metrics
are important to your business goals and
you want to be able to figure out okay
what kind of content am I going to post
on these social media platforms so you
want to get organized and put a plan in
place and then you want to create
informative shareable actionable and
relevant content and what I mean by all
that is you want to create unique
content that doesn't mean you can't
Leverage What other people are doing
meaning you know if I'm you know in the
shoe business I can certainly go to Nike
or Adidas or Puma or Reebok and see what
kind of posts they're putting out and
then I could take their cue and do
something similar but I want it to be
unique to me and I wanted to be unique
to my brand and I want to be able to
keep my content visual meaning I want to
be able to use as many photos and videos
as I can that's available to me because
remember videos generate better
engagement I want to be active and
responsive with my customer base meaning
the whole point of social social media
is to engage and people are going to
respond they're going to comment they're
going to take part in What you post and
so whatever they do you want to be able
to respond accordingly whether that's
positive or negative and then you want
to measure metrics like conversion rates
and click the rates so that goes back to
putting a plan in place figure out what
your metrics are and then when you're
posting on a particular platform you
want to be able to lean on those metrics
to make sure you're achieving your goals
so you want to have those metrics in
place beforehand and then you want to be
able to use those metrics moving forward
as you post the whole idea is if you're
measuring what you post you're obviously
going to want to lean more towards
what's working versus what's not working
in a world where a lot of competing
different products satisfy the same
requirement you have a lot of
advertisers who want you to try their
product and then you have other
product try my product try my product
try my product try note try my product
my product's the best no no no no my
product's the best try my product well I
want you to forget all that and try my
product forget about those other
advertisers try my product well there's
only one way you can prove your product
is better than the rest and that's with
powerful advertising and one of the best
ways to advertise on the Internet is via
social media and through the largest
social media platform in the world and
that's Facebook so today we're going to
talk about Facebook ads tutorial and I'm
excited to teach this class my name is
Rob Sanders I'm with simply learn and
today we are going to talk about all the
different ads that Facebook has to offer
so introduced back in 2007 the Facebook
ads platform has grown tremendously over
the last few years almost 4 billion
million dollars of Revenue in one year
so what does that mean that means
there's a lot of advertisers why is
there a lot of advertisers because a lot
of people use Facebook it's a popular
platform so not only is it popular but
it's popular with advertisers because if
you're advertising on Facebook you have
the opportunity to share your product
and your brand with users who you think
are going to buy your product or
associate with your brand and on
Facebook you can do that a number of
different ways specifically in
somebody's news feed and specifically
that person's new feed that again is
interested potentially interested in
your brand your product so there's a lot
of ways to advertise and a lot of
reasons why you want to advertise so I
just mentioned one of the reasons hey
it's an opportunity for you to reach out
to people who are targeted who are
specific to your product and your brand
so not only that but you combine that
target audience with the amount of time
that people spend on Facebook okay
people spend a lot of time on Facebook
in fact not only do people spend a lot
of time on Facebook there's a lot of
people on Facebook in fact 2.27 billion
in the third quarter of 2018. and so
when we say spend a lot of time we mean
going to that Facebook profile at least
once a day okay so a lot of eyeballs
throughout the day checking their news
feed on Facebook Facebook also enables
you the advertiser to find the perfect
audience and so that's the great
combination a lot of people on Facebook
and targeted audience so it's a platform
that allows you to put your product in
front of people based on specific
interest specific demographics special
specific location so you're really
really putting your product out in front
of the right people at the right time
and so the other positive and pro about
Facebook is it's lesser spend greater
reach and what do we mean by that well
traditionally Facebook is a little bit
cheaper than other online advertising
models it is definitely a lot cheaper
than your traditional advertising models
and Facebook has been known to have good
return on investment because it's cost a
little bit less than other advertising
models and other advertising platforms
so that's the other benefit to being on
Facebook so if you're into building a
brand you want to be on Facebook why
because it helps you increase your brand
awareness it's going to help you allow
users to know what your brand is all
about because remember you're putting
your brand in front of like-minded
people or people you think that are
going to associate shape with your brand
that are going to associate with your
product so you put your brand out there
you incorporate your your advertisement
in somebody's news feed it's going to
add value it's going to establish trust
and credibility especially if that
person's friend is associated with that
brand so instant credibility if friends
and family members of a person on
Facebook are associated with your brand
so it has the opportunity to really lend
a lot of credence to somebody who is on
Facebook active on Facebook and is your
targeted demographic and the great thing
about Facebook is it also has other
features other advertising features such
as retargeting so you could Target
people who've already expressed an
interest in your service or product but
if they didn't go through the conversion
process meaning they didn't go all the
way through and and buy your product you
can certainly reach out to them again
just like your traditional retargeting
options on say Google or some other
advertising platform Facebook works the
same way we want to be able to reach out
to people who aren't fully committed at
a point in time but we can reach out to
them at another point in time and so
Facebook's advertising platform allows
us to do that so it's a great feature
that we could take advantage of that
will talk about more throughout this
session and then it helps increase
Revenue sales and leads and and that's
primarily what most advertisers are
after you know more Revenue more sales
more leads so Facebook allows us to
educate our audience again a targeted
audience about a specific product we
have to offer so the more our audience
knows about our product especially for
their friends and family members and
colleagues are using the product then
the more likely they're going to
purchase so if you go back to the other
feature higher Revenue less spend this
is the primary reason because you have a
chance to influence somebody who's very
targeted who's very active on the
platform and who may have like-minded
people in in their life associating with
your brand and product so it's a perfect
combination for advertising perfect
combination and so today we're going to
talk about all the different types of
Facebook ads and we're going to start
out with the single image ad in the
single image ad or just single image
advertisements that have an optional
text on top and a link description that
links to the website so single image ads
are probably the most popular you can
see them on probably your own Facebook
feed if you look so in fact I'll just
jump over to my Facebook feed right now
and if I go there what do I see I see a
single image ad here and it's from
Shopify Partners so become a Shopify
partner at eCommerce to your list of
qualifications so Shopify must be you
know a brand that is trying to woo my
business okay so they know that somebody
that I'm associated with or maybe I fit
their demographic so they're targeting
my newsfeed with a single image ad so
that's what a single image ad looks like
it's simply just one single image with
some description and the great thing
about this single image if you haven't
noticed is the pixels are pretty large
it's 1200 by 628 so it kind of stands
out a little bit it's not your
traditional thumbnail it really pops
when you look at the news feed so again
if I go back to my news feed here you
can see it just really stands out within
the news feed so I can't miss it if I'm
a targeted part of their targeted
audience it's hard for me to you know
not see this ad interact in some way
especially again if I know somebody in
my network on Facebook either that be a
friend or family members associated with
that product okay in addition to the
single image ads Facebook also has
multi-product ads or also known as
Carousel ads and so what the carousel
ads do is allow you and carousel form
allow you to rotate different ads with
different messaging and different call
to action and so here you can see simply
learn has a example of a carousel ad
where they're showcasing their different
courses so this allows users to view a
range of all your different products and
services if you have multiple products
and services to offer then the carousel
ads would be a good option for you so in
addition to the Carousel ads and single
image ads it gets a little bit more
sophisticated in terms of Technology
where Facebook allows us to offer up
video ads and so video ads are
interactive it's a good way to really
showcase your product your brand your
service and the great thing about the
video ads is they can go from just a few
seconds all the way up to you know two
minutes or excuse me all the way up to
120 minutes and so you can really really
put lot of time and effort into the
video ads to really put your brand out
there and so the one thing about video
is it is interactive most people engage
with video and they tend to get about 10
to 30 percent more views than other
forms of ads so the video ads are really
a popular way for you as an Advertiser
to put your brand or product out there
so you can put your brand and product
out there and not just a few seconds but
you know really tell a nice complete
story to get the engagement to get the
person to take the action you want them
to do so that's why video ads have
become very popular because they tend to
get more engagement more interaction
than your traditional single image ad or
say your Carousel ad so Facebook also
allows us to advertise something called
lead ads and what lead ads allow us to
do is obtain user details okay so we can
acquire or get an email address or phone
number from somebody whose interest in
our product or service and that person
doesn't even have to leave Facebook so
if you look here on the example here we
have the ad somebody clicks on sign up
and they get this form submission and
the great thing about the lead ad is
that it can sync up with any CRM or most
of your popular crms I should say for
example Salesforce as a good example of
a CRM where somebody fills that out the
information goes directly to Salesforce
and so lead ads are really good if
you're trying to generate you know leads
for your business and the form itself
the interaction stays right in Facebook
and so that's the great thing about it
they don't really have to leave the
platform another form of advertising on
Facebook are slideshows okay so unlike
the carousel ads which rotate and the
carousel ads remember rotate and
showcase different products or Services
these ads are interactive but they're
rotating different imagery so it allows
you to really put your best images out
there with a really strong call to
action just like you see here with the
simply learn example okay so they're
showcasing you know they're different
classes and then they have the get
started today called to action a really
punctuate the slideshow ad so what's
interesting is you can really gauge a
person's interest by throwing different
products or images out there you know
you can really immerse a user's
experience here by showing different
different images and then the last type
of ad on Facebook's called The
Collection ad and so these ads combine
basically your video your slideshow or
your product images taken from your
product catalog okay so if you're an
Advertiser who wants to advertise
several products at once then this could
be a great option option for you the
collection ad so here you can see the
simply learned example here they're
showing you know not only you know some
some good slide shows and imagery with
some good messaging below that so before
we get into the steps for creating an ad
on Facebook let's talk about some of the
important changes that have happened on
Facebook recently in light of data
sharing so really what Facebook's done
is they've made an important change on
how user data is being used for
advertising and so what Facebook's done
is they remove something called a
partner category and that was an ad
targeting program which the targeting
option was based on data provided by a
third-party partner so if you're an
Advertiser and you had a third party
partner that provided some targeted
options to you that was known as a
partner category in in summary Facebook
has removed that program and so now the
only way you can gain user information
is if they provide that voluntary like
the lead ad for example now you have to
get the data directly from the third
party now so you can't have that third
party give you that targeting option
anymore you could certainly again
capture the data Yourself by relying on
leak capture landing pages as an example
or the lead ads and you can certainly
still Outsource your advertising to lead
gen agencies and media buying companies
okay but the partner category has more
or less gone away
okay so now let's get into
how to create a Facebook app so what are
the steps so the first thing you'll have
to do is set up a campaign so when
you're setting up a campaign you have to
select what kind of spending you want to
do for your advertisement and what you
want to achieve okay so you have to in
other words identify the goal okay so
with Facebook you have two opportunities
at hand here you can jump into an
auction just like Google what you're
going to do is your ads going to enter
and into an auction and so this is where
you can decide how you want to spend
your money to achieve your goals by
choosing an appropriate bid strategy for
the auction so in the auction you're
competing with other advertisers another
option is you could do reach and
frequency and so with reach and
frequency you'll be able to advertise to
your Brand's audience with a fixed cost
so reach a frequency allows you as the
advertiser to better predict the
delivery cost and reach of your branding
campaigns so with auction you have more
choice you have flexibility you have
scalability but not a lot of
predictability okay because again you're
going into an option and your auction is
going to be competing against other
advertisers so it's this option is
available to all advertisers and you can
have pricing that you can change during
the auction price process so that's the
unpredictability part is the pricing so
pricing can fluctuate during the auction
because you have different advertisers
who are trying to achieve the most
prominence for their ad with reach and
frequency you'll be able to plan and set
up your campaigns and actually set it up
so it's more predictable on how the
delivery is going to be done with reach
and frequency so more predictability
when reaching frequency because you
could set everything up in your campaign
okay so again with the reach and
frequency you'll be able to advertise
with a fixed cost auction you're not
necessarily going with a fixed cost
you're going with more scalability
flexibility on cost uh that can change
okay so once you choose your objective
for your advertisement then you need to
choose the type of advertisement you
want to do and it's based on your
objectives so what's your objective is
its awareness to drive awareness is it
to drive consideration or is it to drive
a conversion so these are the three
objectives uh available to you for your
advertising you want to choose one of
those objectives so let's take a look at
each of these objectives available to
you okay so let's start out with
awareness so awareness can help with
creating an interest for your product or
or your service so when we say where is
where they can maybe brand awareness or
product awareness to get out there in
front of people okay so with
consideration it's a little bit
different than awareness but not so
different in that we're really aiming to
get people to think more about our
product and service and have them take
the next step so with awareness you're
introducing your product and service
with consideration you're getting people
to take the next step and start looking
for information about the product or
service you're advertising and then
conversion is kind of that final step if
you're really after a conversion you
really want that person to make the
decision okay so they're either going to
buy or use your product or service okay
and so that's the conversion objective
so you have to choose one of these three
objectives here is it going to be
awareness is it going to be
consideration or is it going to be
conversion and so let's go back to
awareness okay so if we we look at
awareness under awareness we have brand
awareness and we have reach okay so we
look at Brand awareness really what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
increase awareness about our brand or
the product in our brand so these types
of objectives I mean meaning awareness
don't really emphasize interaction okay
you're not really trying to get somebody
to purchase or or buy something or opt
into a newsletter really your goal as an
Advertiser with brand awareness is to
get your product out there so people are
aware that it exists okay let alone
forget about buying it or opting into a
newsletter you really your goal with
awareness and brand awareness is to get
people to see that you're existing your
product exists your service exists it's
available and really the aim is to
create high brand recall amongst users
rather than focusing on generating
Revenue so when we say you know High
brand recall what we mean is hey if your
brand is out there and you are really
pushing it out there amongst a large
targeted demographic audience then the
next time that audience sees your brand
they're going to be able to associate
with it okay it's not going to be
foreign to them or the first time
they've ever seen it you really want
them to recall hey I know that brand
I've seen that brand before okay that's
kind of the reaction you want to get
from a brand awareness hey that's a cool
looking logo or man that product looked
interesting now I'm going to take the
next step so that's what brand awareness
really needs to do it needs to create
that recall for that for your audience
okay so let's take a look now at reach
so with reach reach ensures that our
advertisement is seen by the maximum
number of people within our target
audience and budget so with reach we're
really trying to reach or get our ad out
there to as many people as possible
given who we're trying to Target and
given the amount of money we have to
spend so it helps to Target a smaller
audience to visit your website watch
your video or even convert on your
website okay so that's with reach we're
just really trying to get it out there
okay so let's move on to consideration
so we talked about awareness we talked
about brand awareness and reach with
consideration we have you know people
who are willing to take that next step
okay so if we're targeting a specific
demographic and we're looking at
consideration we really want them to do
something with our ad we don't want them
just recall it or see it for the first
time we want them to take that next step
and so with consideration we have
traffic so if we have an ad you know the
least we want somebody to do who's seen
our brand before is at least click on
our ad okay so we want people to you
know click on our ad and go to our
website really that's a goal of
consideration is hey I know that brand
I've seen that brand before let me click
on this and see what they have to offer
so this might involve them listening to
a podcast or reading an article or being
introduced to an app so really you're
setting the stage for further down the
funnel by further introducing them to
something that's on your website so you
really want them to take that next baby
step the next baby step is clicking on
the ad going to your site and further
educating themselves about your
particular product or service so
Facebook shows these advertisements to
people within your target audience based
on their past Behavior okay so that's a
great thing about Facebook it's you can
really really get targeted here with
your audience okay so engagement so we
talk about traffic we're going to talk
about engagement so these types of ads
are useful when we want users to engage
more with our ad for example we can you
know really have an advertisement or
post that will allow people to like it
they can respond or even take advantage
of an offer so that's what we mean by
engagement we really want people to
react positively within Facebook about
our ad or our post okay so it can help
with building engagement meant an
engagement audience for your Facebook
page that can be used for future
advertising campaigns so we're really
getting people to take that next step
and what's that next step if they don't
go to our website they can like what we
have to say and then we can have app
installs so that's another option to us
for consideration so app installs are
great if we want to send users to an app
store for example so they can download
our app so if we're really really
pushing an app that we just developed
then an app install could be a good
opportunity under consideration to allow
that user to take the next step and
download your app so that that at a
later stage they can go and interact
with the app we have video views so
video views are are good advertisements
when you're promoting your product or
service and you really want a high
number of views so remember early on we
were talking about the types of ads
available on Facebook we talked about
video views how they get 10 to 30
percent more engagement well that's
really what we want videos to do under
consideration we really want people to
understand what we're trying to do and
really engage with our product and so
they could turn around and like it they
could turn around and um push it out to
their friends so video we know is high
engaging with an audience and so having
a video allows you to really allow that
video to potentially go viral okay so
video views help users engage and
enables the creation of an audience
which can be used for future
advertisements okay so highly engageable
you know interactive allows people to
you know really really take that next
step with your product or service by
really getting to know what you're all
about okay then we have lead generation
so lead generation is interesting
because remember those leads ads we
mentioned in the when we're talking
about the type of ads that Facebook has
to offer well Lee need ads or you know
if you have a lead generation type ad
really what you could do is you can just
collect the information so really
somebody's interested in your product or
service right away then you can generate
a lead ad and allow them to say hey you
know what I'm interested I'm going to
sign up for your newsletter or yes I'm
interested in your product or your
future any future giveaway or promotion
you have to offer here here's my email
address here's my name here's my phone
number so lead ads are great for
consideration because somebody knows
your ad they've likely engaged with you
they like what you have to say and
they're willing to take that next step
and you can integrate your lead ads with
third-party apps that's tied to your CRM
so for example Salesforce lead ads can
sync up right with Salesforce and then
you can then follow up with that user at
a later point so that's consideration so
we have a lot of good options available
to us under consider duration you know
we could drive traffic video views app
installs just regular engagement you
know and then we got Legion so we got a
lot of opportunities for consideration
if you're really trying to Target people
who are already familiar with your brand
or product or service and then last but
certainly not least we have messaging so
with messages you know these ads aim to
convert a user's interest in a product
to a successful sale or conversion so it
targets people who are more likely to
respond through Messenger so Facebook
Messenger is a service that is
integrated nicely in with Facebook and
so with Facebook Messenger you know you
can communicate with that person
directly just through Messenger okay so
it could be a chat bot or it can be a
rep who can act as customer support or
provide more information about the
product or service so you can use
Messenger to your advantage you can talk
right away to somebody who is really
interested in considering your product
or service so this is kind of the
Capstone of consideration because it
takes into account one of Facebook's
most popular features which is Messenger
it allows you as an Advertiser to use
that feature to engage with your
targeted audience directly let's turn
our attention to the last objective
which is conversion so under conversions
we have conversions product catalog
sales and store visits so for
conversions really this is the end of
the funnel this is really the part of
the funnel where we want people to take
action so ads related to the objective
of conversions really aims to increase
you know whatever the goal is of your
website so if it means sign ups or
registrations for your services or sales
or downloads or any desired action on
your website then that's the conversion
okay so that's what we're aiming to
achieve when we are tying our ads to
conversions okay so you have conversions
and you have you know pure product
product catalog sales so for product
catalog sales these could be ads to help
promote your e-commerce store or other
products in your store portfolio you
know so think of Amazon think about all
the products they have on their website
you know they are probably likely going
to choose you know product catalog sales
because it really will help really push
traffic to the store and really get
somebody to convert either in a for a
particular product or get them to look
at other product categories and buy
something there so it really really
product catalog sales are really great
for future campaigns when you're really
looking for sales and then we have store
visits and so store visits really help
direct traffic to your location and
really helps deliver ads based on your
user's current location okay so if we
really want to get somebody to the store
if you have a brick and mortar store for
example then you can use store visits as
your objective under conversions to
really Drive traffic to that location so
that's what store visits are we really
want people to you know take that next
step get to your store and check out
your store and purchase so that's what
store visits are under the conversion
subjective So within each of these
advertisement objectives we can create
split tests also known as a b testing
and the reason why we call it a b
testing because what you're doing is
you're testing one variable from the
other so really you have two
advertisements that really are the same
except the only difference is there's
one thing that's altered from the other
so in this example we have a with one
promotion and then we have B which is
the same audience same everything except
different promotion so you're really
changing one variable when you do a
split test and so that's available to
Facebook just like any other type of
advertising let's say you do you know
search advertising on Google split
testing is available let's say you do
email marketing split testing is
available with subject clients
Facebook's no different it allows split
testing or allows you to use two
versions of the same ad and able to
change one of those parameters so you
can see really what ads performs best
that's the whole idea behind a split
test okay so if it's the original sales
sale of 25 off then hey so be it you
know it works because you tested it
against another variation and then the
great thing about testing it never ends
so if 25 off works over say two thousand
dollars off then you try something else
to see if that will increase sales
that's the whole idea behind testing is
you only want you always want to see
what works okay so really what it comes
down to is it can be really it can be a
promotional offer or it could be
something as simple as changing the call
to action you know a different color on
the call to action it could be anything
you want to test as long as you're able
to you know figure out what works and
then apply what works so you can
continue to improve your advertising
that's really the whole idea behind a b
testing okay so it really is identifying
an element you want to test and then
really once you identify that element
and you test it and you know what wins
then you can move on to other things to
figure out what else works so if you
tested the promotion then go on to the
CTA so you could test things like colors
and call to actions and imaging and
messaging and positioning and you could
play around with your target audience
and test a segment of a Target on ends
against another so there's lots of
things you could test when you a B test
the most important thing to note though
when you a B test is you always want to
keep in mind what metric you want to
measure the test up against so some of
the metrics you could use are
click-through rate which is CTR cost per
click CPC you can use conversion rate
also known as CR or just clicks the
whole idea is when you do a test and
you're testing a promotional offer
you're testing even the call to action
you need to measure that up against a
metric so that metric is what's going to
determine the winner and so it doesn't
have to be overly complicated it could
be as simple as testing you know one
call to action against another and
determining which one gets more clicks
and if one gets more clicks than the
other then hey you know you have a
winner okay let's go through the steps
of creating a new campaign on Facebook
using Facebook's ads manager so you're
going to log into facebook.com ads
manager and you're just going to click
on the create new campaign button and
when you do that you're going to see a
screen that looks just like this and
you're going to go through a series of
steps so as we presented earlier the
first step is always choosing your
objective so we have awareness
consideration and conversion so recall
that awareness was getting your brand
out there to people who never seen your
brand or product or service before so
it's a matter of trying to reach as many
people as you can to get your brand out
there and so you have brand awareness or
you have reach remember one is
controlled one is uncontrolled okay so
reach is a little bit more control
because you can set your budget okay and
you can control your budget a little bit
better so brand awareness is just
getting it out there having Facebook
plop it in front of the Adam front of as
many people as possible with reach you
are trying to maximize how many people
you show your ad to but it is a little
bit more controlled against the budget
okay either way choosing awareness is
going to set the objective of trying to
maximize your exposure for your brand
your product or your service okay if
somebody has already seen your brand or
somebody's already familiar with your
product or your services then you may
want to choose the objective of
consideration and so these are people
who again are already familiar who you
want to take that next step remember
Facebook is an environment where you're
targeting a specific audience so you're
targeting people you know have likely
seen your brand product or service so
you want to take that next step that's
what you want them to do okay so here
under consideration we have traffic
engagement app installs video views lead
gen or messages all all of these choices
are getting somebody to do something for
you for example app installs you want
them to install your app or engagement
you want them to like or share your post
video views watching your video or
messaging you want them to interact with
you via Facebook's messenger feature so
all of these are interactions of some
sort where somebody's taking that next
step they've seen your brand they're
interested but you they're not ready
quite ready to purchase yet okay so
that's what consideration is then you
have conversion this is people in the
funnel who you know or think you know
want to convert and when I say think you
know meaning you know you're really
targeting people who you've targeted
before who maybe has purchased from you
before or is exactly the type of
audience you're looking to purchase okay
so you have conversions you have catalog
dog sales and you have store traffic
meaning driving foot traffic to a store
okay so these are people further down
the funnel who you don't necessarily
want to take a smaller action like just
share your Facebook post or provide
their email address and name okay so you
want them to purchase so these are the
three marketing objectives you're going
to choose from okay so we're just going
to choose conversions for the sake of
this example and then when we go to
choose conversions remember we can
create a a b split test okay so that's a
choice you should always choose because
you always want to be testing something
okay in this case we might want to test
the ad we might want to test say the
call to action because we're looking for
conversions so it could be as simple as
having one ad with a buy more and the
other AD that says hey check out our
website so you have that option to a b
split test and then you have budget
optimism station which basically allows
you to set your budget evenly across
your different ads okay and so what
Facebook's gonna do is basically make
sure that the best performing ad is
going to be seen more often so that's
budget optimization you're maximizing
your budget towards an ad or ads that
you want to be able to have more control
over in terms of what's working and
what's not working versus not selecting
this option your ads are just going to
randomly show and there's not going to
be any necessary control over how much
spend each ad gets so that's the first
step in creating your campaign it's
always choosing your objective with a
few options built in
so the next step in the process is AD
set okay and as you can see here before
you even get to ad set what uh Facebook
is prompting us to do is look at
basically how the A B test is going to
work so here they're explaining how an A
B split test works okay so basically
what an A B split test does is serve up
50 50. the original versus A variation
of the original okay so that's more or
less how an A B split test works and so
Facebook is doing us some good by
showing us this messaging okay because
that's what we chose now notice we chose
conversions that are objective okay so
what we're going to be required to do is
put a conversion pixel on our website so
that Facebook can actually track
conversions and so what we want people
to do is purchase
and so what we need to do then is add a
Facebook pixel to our website so that
Facebook can actually track how many
people purchase from your campaign so
this is very important and so if you're
driving traffic to your website and you
want them to convert then you need to
make sure all the tracking is in place
so the next step in setting up your ads
is setting up an offer so if you have an
offer that you want to provide go ahead
and select on because the default is set
to off okay what you could do is you can
associate it with your particular
company page
on Facebook and then you're going to
create your offer so I'm going to put my
offer title I'm going to put a little
bit more details in there I can put an
end date when the offer expires in a
specific time so based on what you put
this is what people are going to see
with the ad and here you have the
Redemption section where you can have
people redeem the offer online or online
and in store so if it's online you need
to provide Facebook with a URL where
people can go and redeem that that
promotion that offer and then you have a
chance an opportunity to add a
particular code so you don't necessarily
have to have a code with your offer it
could be a one-time code or it can be a
unique code okay or unique codes okay
and then you have an advanced option
here and this Advanced option is pretty
important because if you're setting up
an offer and you only want a specific
number of people to see that offer then
and you don't want them to to share that
offer then what you could do is hide the
share option so that way people won't be
able to share the promotion with friends
or family or whatnot now they could
still copy and paste the link of the
offer but they won't be able to easily
do it with the share option and here you
could put some terms and conditions so
that's the offer okay and it's pretty
intuitive in the Wizard
my recommendation is you should always
put out an offer to get people to you
know again your objective is to get
people to convert so an offer always
helps incentivize conversions
okay here we have our variable because
we're testing we're split testing okay
so here we're we're choosing what we
want to split test so if we choose
creative basically what we're doing is
we're telling Facebook we want to test
our creative or at and so now what we're
going to do is we're going to select the
audience and so we could choose a custom
audience a look-alike or all so here you
can see we have a look-alike and a
look-alike basically is basically what
Facebook does is they're trying to find
people who are very similar to your
customers okay so that's who you want to
Target people who look like your
customers on Facebook okay so you can
choose the look-alike audience or you
could choose a custom audience if you
already have one
so we're going to create a new custom
audience here
and basically what we want them to do is
website traffic
and we're just going to call it website
traffic and basically it's going to be
all website visitors
okay so we're going to create this
audience here
so we've done that and basically now
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to tell Facebook okay if our audience is
all website visitors where those
visitors going to come from so we want
to choose a location so it could be
everyone in a particular location
everyone who lives in a particular
location or recently in the location or
traveling in a location okay so here you
can see we have it set to United States
but we can always change that so you can
really pick and choose areas or cities
and even exclude areas
you can even upload locations in bulk so
if you have a specific set of locations
you can upload that
after you choose your location you're
then going to choose your age so here
you have if you look all the way down to
13 years of age and then your range goes
all the way up to 65 years of age then
we have our gender we can choose both
men and women or just men and just women
and then we can Target a specific
language if we want to Target Spanish
people or people who speak Spanish then
we can choose Spanish notice we can add
multiple languages
okay so if we want to do some specific
targeting for example we can do interest
or specific behavior so if I click
suggestions then for example Facebook's
going to offer us up some suggestions so
if we want to Target people who have an
interest in foreign language your
charity and causes or mindfulness or it
could be specific job titles okay so we
can get really detailed with our
targeting we also have connections so
who do we want to Target so are these
people who like our page who are friends
of people who like our page we can also
exclude people who like our pitch okay
so remember your advertising is tied to
a Facebook page however you could still
drive that traffic to your website but
what Facebook does is once you connect
your ad or your campaign to a Facebook
page then they have an idea of the
profile then they have an idea of what
type of community do you have on
Facebook okay so that really helps them
offer you more detailed targeting in the
form of connections okay so when we're
done we could save the audience
so I'm just going to name it uh English
and Spanish click save okay now I have
my audience saved and the important
thing here is that this audience is
saved we can use it at a later date or
if we're setting up a new campaign we
can pull from the same audience under
use a saved audience
so if I just type in English in Spanish
you'll see my audience here okay and we
can always edit it if we need to
okay so next is the placements section
so here placements is where we want to
show our ads okay so we want to be able
to place our ads in the proper placement
and so what Facebook does is they
actually recommend you do an auto
placement and so Facebook Will based on
your audience show your ad in different
spots or different placements throughout
Facebook based on the people you're
trying to Target the audience okay so in
this case we're targeting both Spanish
and English okay and we're targeting 13
to 65 year olds who live in the United
States and so what Facebook's going to
do then because we have automatic
placement set up is they're going to be
able to place our ads based on our
target audience so this is an option I
always recommend you do and Facebook
recommends as well if you're specific
about where you want your ad to be
placed then you can just select edit
placements and notice when you select
edit placements here you have different
options not only on Facebook but on
Instagram as well okay and Facebook's
Network and in Facebook Messenger so you
have all these different options
available to you if you really want your
your ad placed in a specific position so
here if I just scroll over here I can
see what it looks like in a feed and
stream video I can scroll down to
Instagram that's what it looks like in a
feed on Instagram okay uh you have
Instagram stories if I want to go and
advertise on Facebook Messenger then I
have some options here in messenger
inbox or sponsored messages okay so you
have a lot of options available under
edit placements meaning picking your
placement specifically but again I
recommend as does Facebook just go with
the recommended placements for now
unless you're really clear and you
really under understand how Facebook
works and where these placements are
actually going to be but remember if you
choose edit placements and place it in a
specific position let's just say on
messenger inbox remember your audience
may not be there so go in with the
automatic placements you know is a way
for Facebook to help you get your ad in
front of the Right audience here the
next section delivery optimization okay
how much of our ads are optimized and
delivered so remember we chose
conversions here so we're going to
optimize our ads for conversions so what
Facebook's going to do is take into
account each conversion that e-chat is
getting and they're going to show that
ad that's getting more conversions more
often than the ads that aren't getting
as many conversions okay so they're
optimizing the ad delivery based on how
many conversions each ad gets and
there's an option in here as well so you
can put a cost control in place so you
have an average cost per purchase okay
so Facebook will aim to get the most
purchases and spend your entire budget
okay if you put in an average cost per
purchase so for example if I'm selling
T-shirts I may not want my average cost
per purchase to be 20. dollars because
I'm not going to make any money so I'm
probably going to choose maybe two three
four even as high as five dollars on a
cost per purchase because I want to make
sure I'm not spending a lot of money
just to get a purchase so you have that
option available to you to put in as a
cost control
and here we have a conversion window and
so with this conversion window is going
to do is you know help Facebook optimize
your ads a little bit better based on
the number of conversions that happen in
this window
okay so you have some other options in
here you want to do standard delivery ad
scheduling you can run your ads on a
schedule or you can run them all the
time okay and then moving down to the
next option in our ad set is we have
split test and split test budget and
schedule so we have the opportunity to
put a budget in place for our ads okay
and we can schedule the the A B test to
start running immediately if we want to
or we can have the A B test run at a
specific date and we can have it run for
a specific period of time so this goes
all the way back to the first option
where we chose a b split test on step
one so we have a series of options
available to us for the split test okay
once we have all our options in place
okay we're going to click continue and
then the final step is actually setting
up up our ads Okay so
what we're going to do is we're going to
name our ad in this case add a okay it's
going to be tied to a Facebook page it's
going to be tied to an Instagram account
and then we can choose the format of our
ad so remember we have a lot of
different options available to us on
Facebook we have the carousel which
allows us to have multiple images
scrolling horizontally we can have that
single image ad we can have a video we
can have a collection of images
so we have a lot of options available to
us
and then what we could do is we can link
up our ad to a specific page okay now
before we do that we want to be able to
upload our images okay so we're going to
manually choose images videos and links
okay
and then we're going to add some text to
support that image okay and so when we
add text and for our ad we have the
option of setting up a headline actually
it's not an option it's actually
mandatory the description is actually
optional okay but my recommendation is
you want to add a headline that's going
to grab attention and you want to add a
description to support that headline so
I always recommend putting in a
description and then once you do that
you're going to add your destination URL
and then you're going to be able to
preview your ad okay so if we have an
image here okay we can just say hey this
come check out our new product and so as
I add
this information I'll be able to view it
on the right side okay so it looks like
Facebook at this point is not able to
view the image but normally you're able
to see a preview in this case it's on
the mobile news feed so if we drop down
we can see desktop right column okay so
we need to really choose our images so
we're going to change an image here
let's see if I can choose another image
okay I'm going to choose an image here
and so now I can see the image now I
could see the headline
um and and then I could see what it
looks like just by changing the
placement okay so if I want to choose
Facebook Stories whoops that's not
available if I go to for example instant
articles okay here I can see what my ad
looks like on instant articles
so it wasn't available on certain
placements because of the type of AD we
chose but the point being when you set
up your ad you choose your image and you
write your headline and put your
destination URL in then you'll be able
to preview it on certain placements
depending on what type of ads you chose
okay once you're set once you're set up
and remember we're setting up a b
testing so that was add one now we want
to test the second ad or the variation
and so basically what we want to do is
choose the same type of format then what
we want to do is pick a variation what
is that variation going to be it could
be maybe just a different headline okay
or it could be a different URL you need
to decide what it is you're going to
test once you decide what you test
you're going to add that to variation B
once you add that the variation B then
you have both ads set up
once you confirm Facebook is going to
confirm for you whether the ads meet
their criteria okay and if it doesn't in
this case you could see we have some
errors then we need to go back and fix
them so I'm going to go back and choose
single image ad okay so now
I could just choose my one image
so I can browse a library of images I
already have
now here's my single image ad I'm going
to add some text in there a website URL
a headline
remember you want it to be catchy okay
you can change the call to action here
okay you can add multiple languages so
you have a lot of options depending on
the type of format you choose
so remember we chose a B test so we're
going to set up both ads add a and add B
okay and when we do that again we can
have Facebook review it once they review
it we they can confirm this you can see
we still have some errors on add a so
let's go ahead and fix that I'm going to
choose single image because that's what
add B is I'm going to browse my library
maybe I'll just test a different image
I'm going to click continue
and so basically keep everything the
same what I'll test is maybe the image
so you have to go into an A B test
knowing what it is you want to test
ahead of time okay once you do that
you're going to go ahead and continue to
add B and then once you do that
um here let's go ahead and fix this
error here
um the link field so let's just go ahead
and put a link in there
continue to add B
once I confirm then I have two ads ready
to go on specific placements or excuse
me automatic placements and this option
is that's the option we chose and
basically the ads are set to
optimization against conversions we have
a set budget and we're going to be able
to then once our ads go live is look at
some reports to see how they're
performing so that's the steps in
setting up a campaign on Facebook you're
choosing your objective okay then you're
setting up your ad set okay and then
once you set up your ad set with your
target audience then you're actually
going through the motions in this case
we set up two ads because we chose a b
testing okay and if you didn't choose a
b testing then you would just choose to
set up the first ad and once you do that
you confirm and voila your campaign is
set up based on these three steps choose
from over 300 in-demand skills and get
access us to 1 000 Plus hours of video
content for free visit skillup by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more okay so let's
uh review with some do's and don'ts of
Facebook so we mentioned the types of ad
that Facebook has we mentioned how to
set up a Facebook ad itself and choosing
the right objectives and so some of the
dues involved are what just what I
mentioned we always want to do a b
testing on our ads whether that's again
just changing out the color or changing
out an image you always want to do a b
testing because Facebook has you know
Carousel ads and because they have you
know ads that can rotate and you can use
even video with your ads you always want
to take advantage of what's given to you
and so Facebook allows you to do it do
it so if you have the opportunity to
have video ad then use the video ad
highly recommend it remember video ads
have higher engagement so definite do is
use engaging videos and imagery so you
don't necessarily have to use a static
ad or image ad you can use the carousel
for example with a presentation mode
where you could show multiple images to
really showcase your product and service
so with all the advertising that you do
you always want to align your messaging
so use a message that will stay with the
audience okay so use something that's
going to be able to trigger remember
depends on the funnel and where you're
at so if your awareness or consideration
or conversion that has to align with
your messaging so if you're you know
targeting ads you know when you want
people to convert then your message is
going to be as such you're going to talk
to people as if you want them to convert
as if they're ready to convert and you
want to keep your message consistent and
simple so remember the ads are available
to you and you have so many different
features available to you within the
Those ads but that doesn't mean you
gotta convolute it with messaging so
keep your message just consistent and
simple if it's brand awareness you know
definitely keep your message simple so
that people can understand exactly what
it is your product or service is all
about then you want to alter your reach
so that the ads are shown to the
appropriate audience okay so you always
want to keep in mind who you're trying
to Target okay so you don't want to
Target somebody who's not in your
demographic so alter your reach so that
the ads are shown to the appropriate
audience remember you have you know
reach available to you and reach allows
you to really pick and choose exactly
who you're targeting to and how often
remember you want to reach as many
people as possible but you don't want to
reach the wrong people okay some of the
don'ts to stay some things you want to
stay away from is you don't want to put
all your money on one campaign so you
want to separate out your budget
allocate your budget across different
campaigns and I would even take that a
step further and you know put different
types of ads and different campaigns
just to see what works so again it
depends on where you're at in the funnel
if it's just brand awareness okay maybe
create a campaign for that if it's
consideration create a campaign for that
because in consideration you might have
lead ads in them they say with the
awareness campaign you may just have a
single image ad okay just to introduce
your product to somebody with a simple
message so you want to you know
definitely think about how you want to
separate out your campaigns but don't be
afraid to separate your campaigns by the
type of ads don't put too much
information in the ads remember keep it
consistent and keep it simple that's the
best thing I can say and remember a lot
of these ads are image based so images
tell a thousand words they tell a
thousand stories a video will do the job
if you have to say too much so if you're
saying too much think about a video but
if you're using an image let the image
tell the story okay don't forget to
proofread your ads I can't stress that
enough remember if you're an awareness
campaign this is the first time
somebody's seen your product or service
so you definitely want to get the
messaging not only correct meaning
consistent and simple but grammatically
correct you don't want to be so active
on your Facebook page so you know when I
say be don't be so active on your
Facebook page really it depends on where
you're at you're trying to introduce a
product or service so that doesn't mean
that you need to go out and tell
everybody to start buying your product
remember these people may not even know
who you are what product and service you
offer so you want to be able to approach
your audience on your Facebook page in a
manner which is suitable for your
audience and then have an image that
doesn't correspond to the product being
advertised so you you want to be able to
you know have an image that does
correspond so so if you're targeting a
specific audience with a specific
product then make sure the image on your
Facebook page aligns with that okay
don't be inconsistent don't confuse the
audience you know be consistent with
your imagery as well as your messaging
okay so those are some of the don'ts see
things you want to stay away from when
you're advertising today we're going to
cover a number of tips to help you gain
a better advantage on advertising on
Facebook so let's get right to it with
tip number one and with tip number one
not all advertisements need to sell
something so remember you have different
objectives on Facebook you can advertise
an event you can promote a customer
story you can send traffic to your
website or you can get them to download
an app so it all goes back to your
objective so if we go to Facebook and I
want to create an ad remember my first
option is to create an objective so you
have awareness you have consideration
you have conversion so depending on what
you want somebody to do that's the
objective you're going to choose so just
keep that in mind when you're setting up
your campaign on Facebook you need to
align your objective with what you want
people to do so tip number two we want
to use Facebook Messenger for
advertising so Facebook Messenger is a
feature that can be used with
advertising on Facebook and it's a good
tool it's a good practice because it'll
allow you to as the advertiser to
commute with individuals directly so
it's a feature that you should take
advantage of because it allows you to
quickly engage with your target audience
so that's the beauty of leveraging
Facebook Messenger with your advertising
the communication tools available and
for you to engage with your target
audience so it's great for not only
interacting but taking care of any other
objections that they have as an on as an
audience or prospective client so you
can answer any concerns they have right
away so it's a lot more personal and
interactive than other forms of
advertising because you're directly
communicating with your audience tip
three use video advertisements I can't
stress this enough video is very
engaging in fact it's not only engaging
but it's very easy to use so we go to
Facebook really Facebook is telling us
for video all we need to do is have
basically a phone handy and an app and
just to be able to upload it so with
Facebook video you can really Drive
awareness and you can really Drive sales
I mean you can really make some really
splashy videos on Facebook all you need
is a mobile camera so with Facebook
videos it's really very easy to create
you just got to be creative that's
really the key to videos you know
they're going to be engaging to the end
user say something do something that's
going to really grab their attention and
get them to do what you want them to do
so these are just some of the examples
you can see on Facebook and you can see
how creative advertisers are getting you
know clear call to action great video or
great imagery good promotional use so
there's a lot you can do with video and
really make it interactive so I can't
stress video enough as an option for
Facebook it really is one of the better
features of Facebook advertising and
really very limited use of resources all
you need is that web camera an app and
the ability to upload that video that's
really it for video advertisements so
keep in mind and the reason why I'm
harping on those video ads is they tend
to outperform your traditional Facebook
image ads and other formats like the
carousel or the presentation mode so
there's other types of formats on
Facebook video tends to give it that
extra Edge because it's very interactive
and in the form of interactivity comes
engagement so in this example you know
people are going to react they're going
to comment they're going to share the
video and that's what you want as an
Advertiser you want to grab as much
reach as possible towards your target
audience and so video will help you do
that it'll help you not only engage with
the person but allow that video to be
shared and expand your reach towards
your target audience so remember video
can range from a few seconds all the way
up to 120 minutes so you're really gonna
get more views regardless of how long
the video is because it's just going to
be so interactive so just keep that in
mind it doesn't have to be full on 120
Minutes it could be you know anywhere
from one to five minutes you know to me
that's probably a good range but just
know that you have that lead way if you
wanted to so remember video ads always
perform better than single image ads or
other type of image ad formats on
Facebook and they also perform better
when they have subtitle support so just
keep that in mind as well because you
may have you know individuals watching
the video from you know different
countries speaking different languages
so you tip 4 when you're placing your
advertisement where you place your
advertising and play an important role
in deciding how many people come across
it so Facebook offers a number of
different options to choose from so
remember you got the news feed you got
instant articles right column you got
suggested videos so you got a lot of
options at your disposal there's lots of
other options too so you can have
Facebook actually automatically place
your ads or you can specifically tell
Facebook where you want to place your
ads and that's all part of the Facebook
setup so if we go to Facebook and then
we go to create your campaign so if we
close ad sets here is where we're going
to be able to choose our placement if we
click on choose placement we'll be able
to you know be able to allow Facebook to
place it or we can edit the placement
specifically so just keep that in mind
you have a lot of different options here
again feeds and articles in-stream
videos got rycom you even have Instagram
so you have a lot of options available
to you so my recommendation and
Facebook's recommendation is always go
with the auto placement but you could
specifically choose your placement if
you want to when you're setting up your
campaign so start the advertising on the
news feed could be recommended the news
feed is where you're probably going to
get your most eyeballs most users spend
most of their time there and it has the
highest chance of grabbing their
attention so the news feed could be a
good place to start again you can have
it at Auto placement and your ads may be
there as well or you could specifically
choose just the news feed or other
placements so tip four just be careful
where you place your ad it's really
important you want to place your ad
where you're going to get eyeballs so
tip five Facebook ads also offer you the
option to advertise on Instagram so you
have that option available to you as I
mentioned in tip four you have the
option to advertise these stories
Carousel ads photo ads and video ads so
again that's all part of the ads set up
when you go to choose your placements
here you got Instagram feed you get
Instagram stories and again with both of
those placements on Instagram you can
work with several different types of ads
including that Carousel ad including
that video ad so just keep that in mind
that Instagram is an option for you take
advantage of it there's a lot more
eyeballs on Instagram these days and it
plays off nicely with what you're trying
to do with Facebook so go ahead and give
it a try Okay so let's take a quick
break from the first few tips we went
over and let's take a look at an ad so
it's an ad break time so let's take a
look at this ad this is by New Scientist
and so what makes this ad so great well
there's been a lot of shakeup in the
world today about fake news you know
what is fake news so new scientists is
actually playing off of that they're
mentioning hey fake news not in our
world so they're actually playing off of
that that term fake news and so that's
an attention grabber so I think that's
what makes this look so good but this is
a single image ad and you can see here
they're promoting this ad with a
promotion so try 12 weeks for just 36
Euros okay so they have a promotion in
there so and you notice they the image
of the you know the magazine they're
also displaying that hey you can look at
this digitally on a laptop a tablet or a
mobile phone so you have other options
as well so they show you that in the
image which is placed on the right side
of their messaging so for me this is a
good ad because of the placement of the
image the type of image they're using
the play on fake news and the promotion
that they're offering up so this is
really a good ad it's very eye-catching
and hopefully the promotion is good
enough to get you to sign up okay so tip
number six so tip number six we want to
continuously do a b testing you want to
always have this option going for you
want to be able to test variation a
versus variation B because you want to
be able to find out what works and what
doesn't work with your audience and on
top of that it helps you really put your
best foot forward by showing your best
ad so by doing a b testing you're
getting feedback from the audience and
turning that feedback into positive
returns so you're then turning your ad
that does work well in front of an
audience and you're going to continue to
do that so A B testing is always a good
option so remember when you're setting
up your ad in Facebook go ahead and
choose to have your A B test set up and
when you do that you choose that option
you're going to be able to then go in
and choose what it is you want to test
without a and then with ADD B so you're
going to again align your test with a
Facebook page you're going to choose an
ad format once you choose your ad format
then you're going to be able to go ahead
and you know put your ad in there and
then you're going to choose your call to
action so the whole idea behind an A B
test is you want to be able to find what
it is you want to test is that going to
be the call to action is it going to be
the messaging is it going to be the ad
format so there's lots of things you can
test with Facebook on a b testing so
it's all part of the ad setup so things
you can change again are the color of
the elements Imaging text the call to
action the position of the ad there's
lots of things you could test that's all
part of the Facebook setup so the thing
is you want to continuously test that's
the key continuously test certain
elements of an end so testing can be
done initially on broader elements and
then smaller finer details like
statements in your ad copy so my advice
is when you're actually setting this up
on Facebook you know think ahead think
what it is you want to choose to test my
advice is maybe start out with a call to
action so if you're in Facebook itself
you know you have an opportunity to test
different call to actions try that
that's an easy way to test and then you
know when you test the call to action
once you find out what works and doesn't
work then you can move on to something
more sophisticated like maybe the image
type or maybe trying different types of
imagery or ad types like the carousel
versus single image so start small start
easy and then work your way up tip
number seven so we want to choose an
appropriate call to action in your
advertisements that will attract
potential customers so what do we mean
well you have different call to actions
available to you you want to choose one
that aligns with your ad so for example
the simply learn ad about hey learn how
SEO Works search engine optimization so
if you're trying to get somebody to you
know learn or take one of your courses
you're not asking them to actually shop
now you really want them to sign up so
that's the key we want them to sign up
so use a call to action that makes sense
tip number eight choose the Right
audience for your advertisement okay so
what do we mean so for this you can
consider you know website visits
interests it all depends on your
objective okay what is it you want
people to do if it's you know customers
in the buying process then that's our
objectives to get conversions then we
want to move somebody over to a product
page and get them to purchase you know
if it's focusing on just website visits
then maybe it's the objective of
consideration maybe you just want to get
people to your website to learn more
about your product so that's the whole
idea behind you know choosing uh the
right you know objective because you
want to align the objective with your ad
okay so tip number nine create
look-alike audiences and I'd like
look-alike audience because what
Facebook does is they create an audience
that's similar to the audience you
already advertising to or customer base
you already have so in other words
Facebook already has an idea of who your
audience is you can also you know
provide them with additional information
like an email list to give them a better
sense of who your audience is and then
what Facebook does is they take that
information and they'll put your ad in
front of an audience that looks just
like the audience you already have
that's why they call it a look-alike
audience so it's a great feature by
Facebook it really allows you to reach a
target audience an audience is very
similar to the audience you currently
have and one example provide Facebook
with an email list with that email list
they're going to be able to map that
email list and be able to identify an
audience that you could Target so that's
the whole idea behind look-alike
audience it's a great feature by
Facebook definitely recommend taking
advantage of that why because it will
increase the number of people who will
find your advertisement relevant
remember you're targeting people who are
similar to your actual audience to your
the people who are already connected
with your brand or already liking your
page so if they're similar to those
people then the chances of them engaging
with you are going to be greater so look
alike audiences tend to perform well
because you're targeting an audience
that's very similar to your actual
audience tip number 10 so use the golden
Point rule on your ad Creator so what do
we mean by Golden Point rule well let's
take this ad here as an example so what
we want to do is we want to devote the
creative into nine equally sized boxes
so what we want to do is draw two
horizontal lines and two vertical lines
just like a tic-tac-toe box and so
ideally what we want to do is place the
main subject of your ad in the cross
sections of the Drawn Lines and so what
that does is encourages the user to
place their focus on those points the
lines are just simply there as a
guidance to help you position your
messaging so that's the golden Point
rule really is we want to be able to
position our messaging accordingly so
time for another ad break so let's take
a look at another ad here on Facebook
and this one's my blue apron and so of
all the tips we've talked about this
particular ad takes into account a lot
of them okay so this is again they're
using multiple images in this ad here so
again what they're doing promotion
they're offering up a 30 off promotion
here and what they're asking you to do
is sign up to get that thirty dollar off
so you can see the call to action we
already mentioned that on one of our
tips the call to action matches the ads
so they're asking to sign up they're
using really good imagery here and
they're supporting that with you know
some good copy and text so this is what
makes this ad so good I mean who doesn't
like good looking food or tasty food and
healthy food okay so they're definitely
taking advantage of the imagery with a
promotion and with a good call to action
and so remember we want to a B test so
blue apron is likely testing this ad so
what they could do with this is test
different imagery or they could test a
different promotions so there's a lot
they can do here on the a b testing side
so for me if I were to test this yeah I
would probably be testing the imageries
because we want to be able to see what
images get people to sign up
alternatively we can also test the offer
as well what offer is going to get
somebody to click on that sign up button
so ideally there's a lot to do here from
the A B test standpoint and the way
they've structured this ad it makes it
very easy to test so that's what makes
this ad really good is shows good
imagery has a good promotion and aligns
the CTA tip number 11 so we want to
place the product in the right hand of
your creative so the right side should
contain our product imagery so why is
that why because there's been a study
called the perceived product heaviness
and package evaluation and that states
that depending on where a product is
placed users would react differently to
it and so the study found that users
tend to react more positively when the
product is placed on the right side of
the ad creative so here you can see
countdown of Black Friday this is an
Amazon related ad and you can see the
product is basically a litter box which
is placed on the right side so it's a
Black Friday ad they didn't place the
image on the left side they placed on
the right side because people tend to
react positively when the product image
is on the right side so keep that in
mind when you're placing your imagery
try to place it on the right side tip
number 12 don't use images that have
more than 20 percent text okay so you
want to use images that are clean
remember that blue apron image we looked
at and that was a very clean image of
food no text overlaying the image so we
want to try and stay away from images
that have text on the overlay okay so
there's no limit to how much text you
can add to your creative but you know
Facebook and myself recommend hey the
Lesser text you have the more more
likely it is for your ad to have its
desired impact meaning somebody's going
to click on that ad okay so keep that in
mind let the image do the talking for
you you don't necessarily need to
overwhelm the image with words or
messages tip number 13 so we want to use
an ad creative that's a tension grabbing
and is relevant for your business so
again going back to that blue apron ad
hey who doesn't like good looking food
good looking healthy food green food
well Switching gears we're looking at a
Nike ad who doesn't like a good looking
shoe here this is a good running shoe
and Nike is definitely taking advantage
of the opportunity to place the shoe
against a nice looking background so
here the image on the left you got a
nice mauve looking color the shoe on the
right on a nice red background to kind
of really play into the color of the
shoe and so that's attention grabbing so
the colors kind of match and go with one
another and it tends to grab your
attention so Nike's doing a good job
here of just not showing an image of a
shoe really what they're doing is put
the shoe is a central focal point and
supporting that with additional color
and they're really putting the messaging
kind of as the background behind the
shoe so they're making it as a tension
grabbing as possible here the Nike's
done a good job with this ad you know me
personally I'm not the biggest Nike fan
when it comes to shoes but hey this ad
definitely grabbed my attention because
now I could see you know this shoe is
really popping to me we don't want to
use clip art in your ad creative okay
and don't use low resolution pixelated
images as well we want to use high
quality imagery so and use images that
are well lit you know natural lighting
always tends to work well as as well so
when you're doing a placement for
product whether that be food or shoe you
can see here in this plated example
they're putting it on the Right image
they're putting it in a National
environment on a table on a plate with
some paper next to it you know and then
you could see from the one on the left
it's of a person holding a box with the
image of plated on it and so to me
that's not stock imagery or clip art you
know that's an actual person holding the
product so it's real life you want to
make it as real life as possible and as
clear and quality as possible so when
you create attention grabbing ads you
know show images of people benefiting
from your product instead of just having
the product itself so that's always a
good idea in the case of Coca-Cola you
know these people are enjoying their
bottle of Coca-Cola well going back to
the Nike ad you know they could have had
a person wearing that shoe or you know
running with that shoe that could have
been an alternative for them as well so
the whole idea is just make sure your
ads are attention getting and they grab
your attention and if you're going to
use people make sure the person's
enjoying it just like on the previous
this image it's a person Hole In The Box
we could see she's got a smile on her
face and she is enjoying holding that
box so to me you want to use people with
the images to the best of your ability
and that means use that person who's
enjoying it so that's really going to
put the product in the Forefront okay
tip 14 don't hesitate to experiment with
your advertisements creative or its copy
okay so what do we mean by that really
we want to be refreshing our text we
want to be refreshing our images okay so
if you're going to place an ad on
Facebook don't let that be the only ad
okay if you're using a single image ad
you know feel free to change out that
single image from time to time
especially if a lot of people have seen
that ad so if you're using reach as your
objective and you're trying to reach as
many people as possible just keep in
mind that if that ad is reaching the
same people over and over again it's
going to get stale and you want to be
able to update that ad so feel free to
change out the imagery changing out the
text is just as easy okay so feel free
to play around with the text even if
you're not doing a b testing you can
always change out the text just to see
hey if changing out the text actually
gets you better engagement or meet your
goals tip 15 plan your campaigns for the
holiday season okay so Kent State this
enough you know towards you know October
November December there tends to be a
lot of holidays you know across multiple
religions okay so it's really the time
of year where people are in full ad mode
and audiences are in full watch mode so
advertisers are really pushing ads that
time of year especially Christmas you
know and people are accepting of that
because they're used to it so you want
to be able to plan accordingly so if
you're doing your ads you can easily
engage with your audience if you're
aligning your ad with that time of year
so during Christmas most people are in
the mood for shopping so it's a time of
year where you can really really take
advantage of increasing your sales and
increasing your conversions so you want
to plan accordingly and so if you're
planning you know months in advance you
don't have to do a full year but you
know for me if I'm thinking I'm going to
do a lot of advertising during the
holiday season I'm probably going to go
out maybe once summer ends probably
August beginning of September beginning
of September seasons change a little I
might start thinking about the holiday
season and when you could plan
appropriately you can come out with
really good ads you can think about what
you want to say and so in this case you
know Target this particular ad is really
promoting Black Friday so Black Friday
is the day after Thanksgiving in the
United States and so here they're
letting you know Black Friday is here
there's deals to be had so planning in
advance gives you an opportunity to
really really tweak your messaging and
come up with some good creative ideas so
let's take another break and let's look
at another good looking ad this example
we're going to look at Dell okay so Dell
I've seen their ads all over Facebook
they do a lot of different advertising
types between videos carousels again
this is a single image ad what they're
really trying to do is get you over to
the storefront so you can buy one of
these good-looking you know Dell
computers okay so you know here again
they're promoting their latest computer
the Dell Inspirion 3000 Series All in
One desktop so so them anytime they
create a new product they're going to go
ahead and pull out a new ad for that
product and here they're putting a
little bit of a Different Twist on it if
you notice the ad itself it's just the
image of the product there's really no
promotion here they're letting the
product image speak for itself they're
really showing you hey look how good
this can computer looks you know this is
our new model and you know we got a shop
now ctas if you're interested go ahead
and click on that shop now so they're
really putting the effort into the image
itself you know they're not offering any
promotion you know no discounts you know
what you see is what you get with the
image and you click on it you're going
to go right to their storefront so Dell
does a good job of really you know
cranking out their new products whenever
they go to market so tip 16. shorten the
amount of time between retargeting your
audience so Target people have visited
your website within the span of a month
or two weeks so retargeting is reaching
out to people who you've already engaged
with so if somebody has seen your ad or
somebody's went to your website
somebody's even purchased from you
before you have the opportunity to reach
back out to that person so how often you
reach out to that person or how long
between their initial engagement and
when you retarget them really does
depend on what it is you're selling so
if you're selling a pair of shoes if
you're Nike then chances are somebody's
looking for a pair of shoes it's not
going to be a long purchase window
meaning they're not going to wait two
three months so if I'm Nike and
somebody's seen my ad I'm probably gonna
Target that person in a short period of
time for retargeting so it really
depends on your product but you don't
want to wait too long between the time
they've been initially engaged and the
time you retarget so it really depends
on your product you know again if you're
selling merchandise you know retail it's
probably going to be a smaller time
frame if your Dell computers you know
that's a bigger purchase somebody's
going to take their time so you know you
want to Target people you know for the
Dell computer probably you know over a
longer period of time okay so just keep
the product in mind you don't want to
wait too long you don't want to keep it
too short so you want to find that nice
balance of when you could retarget
someone okay tip number 17 keep keep
altering the hook of your ad copy what
do we mean by altering the hook so here
you can see a couple of different
options option one you know we're
talking about hey if you're interested
in getting some dmca certification you
know this is what you need to do option
two a little bit different of a hook hey
start your journey to get your DMC CA
certification so you know just altering
the way you're trying to talk to
somebody is really what we're after here
on tip number 17. you have an ad
especially the text remember we always
want to refresh that copy but if you're
testing it try different hooks try
different ways to talk to people okay it
always works well when you can have
different types of messaging because
people react to different messaging so
an effective strategy would be to create
multiple ads with different Hooks and
see what performs best so this is an
option for a b testing okay you have an
option to add messaging go ahead and
talk talk one way and one option and
then you know tweak that messaging tweak
that hook a bit in option b and see what
resonates with people so that's a good
option for a b testing is always you
know look at the way you're going to try
and you know get somebody to convert tip
number 18 okay respond to lead add
responses as soon as possible so
remember one of your ad formats is a
lead ad okay so if you have a lead ad
basically what you're asking somebody to
do is add their name their phone number
and their email if you get that
information don't sit on it react to it
just like the messaging the Facebook
Messenger how it's almost instantaneous
think of the lead ads the same way okay
you have somebody who's engaging with
your ad by providing information you
don't want to sit on it you want to
respond as soon as possible in fact you
know when you do engage with that person
let them know you're available on
Facebook Messenger so they can actually
then reach out to you via Facebook
messenger just to expedite the
communication but when you get that
valuable information from the customer
you know respond as soon as possible
it's good customer service because the
longer you take to respond the less
likely the customer will want to
continue interacting with you so there's
no real good rule of thumb here except
for do it as soon as possible okay tip
number 19 add scarcity to your
advertisements so what do we mean by
that well in this example we could see
the top 100 registrations get free
access so by putting this into your ad
copy we're hoping your prospects are
more inclined to buy your product due to
that there that they're not going to be
one of the first 100 registrations okay
so it allows you to really put some
sense of urgency in the ad to get
somebody to react so that's what we mean
by you know scarcity okay so by doing so
it could affect the long-term
credibility you know we don't want to
come across as fear-mongering by any
means but hey if your promotion is the
first 100 registrations get free access
then why not you know go ahead and put
it in there some other examples could be
you know only three days left to
register or first 50 get 50 off for you
know hurry now there's only two days
left so there's other language you can
put to play around with the language but
if you only have certain slots available
or a certain amount of days left there's
nothing wrong with putting that in the
ad copy to get people to react and so
that's the whole idea behind you know
the scarcity is you want to be able to
let people know hey there's a limited
edition going on here if you're
interested go ahead and take advantage
tip number 20 keep track of your ad
relevant scores so your ads do get
scored so the score ranges from one to
ten okay so what that score does is it's
an indicator to signify the quality and
engagement level so you know if your
score is between one and six then the ad
isn't reaching the relevant audience and
your audience isn't reacting to it
however if your relevant score is
between seven and ten then your ads are
reaching the appropriate audience and
you're getting a lot of interaction so
keep an eye on that you know the lower
the number that means hey we're not gay
our ads not getting to the Right
audience and if it's not getting into
the Right audience our audience isn't
going to react to it so it all starts
with making sure you're reaching your
audience with your ad when your ad is
reaching your audience and you're doing
a b testing your audience is going to
react to one of those two ads so that's
always going to help your relevant score
so keep an eye on that relevant score
okay so let's take another break here
and let's take a look at an ad here by
Blue Bottle Coffee okay so I'm a big
coffee drinker myself my frequent blue
bottle in San Francisco a lot and so
here this is a nice image a nice
close-up image of coffee and I really
like this notice there's really no call
to action here okay so they're putting
their website URL the domain
bluebottlecoffee.com they're saying hey
we Source great coffees we roast them to
Perfection and get them to you fresh so
I can vouch for that really putting
their brand out there okay so this is
more of a brand awareness type app
that's their objective their objective
is if you're going to drink coffee at
some other location or with some other
brand hey take a look at ours you know
we got good coffee too we roast them
pretty good and and we make sure that
you get them fresh that's what they're
trying to do they're trying to introduce
their brand to you so this is a good
example of a brand awareness ad single
image ad they're definitely making use
of the added the image itself you know
with a nice close-up shot of that
roasted coffee so that's what makes this
ad so special brand awareness you know
the image is telling us hey this coffee
looks pretty pretty good looks nice and
roasted it looks pretty fresh and maybe
I'll get Blue Bottle Coffee a try so
that's why they're putting their domain
in there okay so it's a good brand
awareness ad and the hope is to convert
some people over to their brand okay so
tip number 21 include emojis in your ad
copy okay so emojis we know are popular
you use them in text use them on social
media I mean there's hundreds of emojis
nowadays that you could pick and choose
from they are really specific and so
here you can see in the case of Simply
learn hey if you're taking a digital
marketing course with simply learn it
doesn't hurt to have some emojis support
that that message so you always get the
thumbs up it's a good Emoji you know the
image of the graduation you know that's
a good Emoji so you know you always want
to align you know really fun relevant
Emojis with your messaging it kind of
just helps it stick out a bit and people
resonate with Emojis and so it doesn't
hurt to add those emojis in your ad copy
and especially if your competition is
not using emojis you want every
Advantage you can to have your ad stick
out so emojis is a good way to get your
ad to stick out tip number 22 use UTM
parameters to your ad which can feed
into your Google analytics account and
provide tracking information so I can't
stress this enough if you're using
Google analytics to track your campaigns
then you want to use UTM parameters so
what do we mean by UT and parameters
well let me show you an example so all
you need to do is type in UTM tracking
or URL builder in Google and then you're
going to actually get to this page here
so what this does this is a tool to help
you create UTM tracking so if we're
simply learn and we want to advertise
and drive the audience to a specific
page in this case artificial
intelligence master's program page so
this is going to be the URL but we want
to append that URL with some UTM
tracking parameters our campaign Source
parameter we're going to put Facebook
because that's the source of what we're
advertising the medium in which we're
driving that traffic to the page from
Facebook is CPC which stands for cost
per click and then we're just going to
put campaign name AI engineer to
identify what it is that campaign is
related to so notice that the only
required parameters campaign Source in
this case we're going to put Facebook
but we can also use campaign content if
we want to different shape the different
ads that we have so you can use campaign
content parameter as well you don't have
to the only required parameters campaign
Source my recommendation go all
lowercase okay and then when you're done
you have a URL that you can use in in
your advertising so when somebody
actually goes to that URL notice the URL
includes the UTM tracking and then
analytics is going to be able to pick up
that campaign from where Facebook the
medium is going to be CPC and the
campaign in this case is going to be AI
engineer and that's what you're going to
look for in Google analytics so it helps
you track your ads more closely because
if you don't use UTM tracking for
example on Facebook then analytics might
you know interpret that traffic coming
from that ad as you know organic social
so we want to be able to identify
specifically the campaign you're running
by putting in different variables for
those parameters so that's what UTM
tracking is you want to use it for all
your Facebook advertising okay so it
really helps you you know in analytics
identify how your campaign is performing
not only is it driving traffic but is
the campaign converting for you so if
you're trying to get somebody to sign up
for a class then Analytics is going to
help us measure those conversions but
with UTM tracking we can bridge the gap
between how many people Facebook
delivered or drove to our site from the
ad and how many of those people actually
converted so UTM parameters help bridge
that Gap tip 23 use exclusion marketing
to improve your Facebook return on
investment by not including people who
have already taken the action desired by
you okay so this is a very key feature
here so if we've already advertised and
people have reacted to our ad and has
subscribed they have subscribed then we
don't want to Target that person again
so that's what exclusion marketing is we
want to be able to you know Target
people that we're really after so if you
know somebody's looked at our ad and did
not convert or did not go to our website
or to not download something or whatever
it is we wanted them to do then those
are the people we wanted to focus in on
okay so in this case space exclusion
marketing we're gonna exclude people who
have subscribed in this case we're going
to retarget people meaning advertise
again to people who have not subscribed
so that's what the exclusion marketing
feature does it helps you really hone in
on where you're targeting and
retargeting so that way you're not
hitting the same people over again and
that's only going to lead to poor
performance tip 24 track the right
metrics for your business so keep your
eye on important metrics what are those
metrics you know those are going to be
kpis kpis or key performance indicators
and kpis differentiate from metrics
because kpis are related to business
goals so track the right metrics for
your business what are the right metrics
for your business more than likely it's
going to be conversions or conversion
rate but you could be running a brand
awareness campaign just like a Blue
Bottle Coffee did and so if you're
running a brand awareness campaign then
maybe your kpi or metric is going to be
a click okay or click-through rate how
many people are actually reacting to our
ad okay so you always want to align the
right metric with your business okay
it's just very important that you're
measuring against the right metric if
you're not then it's going to be
misaligned in terms of how you judge the
campaign performance another set of
metrics could be reach and frequency so
reach and frequency allow us to measure
how many people saw the ad and post
engagement can determine how many users
are reacting to your ads CPC helps us
determine the cost Effectiveness or how
much we're paying for every click you
could see that information in your
Facebook ad manager for example if I go
to Facebook's ads manager here I'm
looking at some some ads that we're
running here what can I see I could see
my reach how many people I'm actually
reaching the frequency in which they're
seeing my ad notice I can see my
relevancy score I can also see my cost
per result I could see the total clicks
so I have a whole set of metrics
available to me really what I want to do
is pick and choose the metrics that are
most important to the ad I'm running
okay so if it's reach am I reaching the
full amount of people possible if I'm
running a brand awareness campaign or it
could be some other metric like
conversion so we want to be able to
align the right metric with the right ad
tip 25 take advantage of Facebook's
location tracking tool for your
advertisements so Facebook allows us to
advertise at up to 25 countries with
different states provinces cities
districts and zip codes so we can really
hone in location wise on where we want
to Target so Facebook allows us to do
that so basically it could be somebody
in a particular area or people who have
been recently been there or traveling to
that location or actually lived there so
so really you can hone in on a specific
location based on certain set of
criteria so with this you could take
your marketing to the next level by
approaching your competitors customers
by offering them better discounts so
that's the whole idea targeting your
advertising on a specific location and
then knowing that your competitors are
there you can really put out some really
good ads with some really good offers to
really convert some of those people in
that audience okay let's take a a look
at another ad okay so grammarly this is
an ad that they've put out there and
again you notice there's no real true
call to action associated with a single
image ad here it's all about messaging
here they're saying hey download it free
today okay and so it's a browser
extension that they're promoting and
really they're trying to get you to
identify or identify with this
particular brand that offers a specific
product so they do have a promotion in
there it's brand awareness hey your life
is about to change I mean the messaging
is pretty you know matter of fact
they're trying to get you to hey I need
this in my browser as an extension so
for me this ad is all about the
messaging here okay so with grammarly
you know if you're in Gmail or in word
you're an Outlook they got you covered
by using their browser expansion it's
free and by using it it's going to make
your life a lot easier so for me the ad
works from a messaging standpoint not
really big on the imagery but it's
really about this is who we are and we
can really rock your world if you use
this browser extension so they're really
putting a lot of emphasis on the
messaging so for me anytime somebody
says my life's about to change they've
got my attention how to rank YouTube
videos today so it's simply learn we
take our videos on YouTube very
seriously meaning that when we create
videos we won't be able to see them
because we know we make good videos and
we know we have good content and we know
that our audience is going to enjoy it
and so we want our audience to see the
videos that we're creating and so we're
going to give you some tips and tricks
and methodology and ideas on how to get
your videos to rank on YouTube so at
simply learn if I go to YouTube and I
just type in machine learning you could
see we're right here is the first
organic video on YouTube for machine
learning if I jump over to Google and I
type in machine learning Basics you can
see where number or number one for
machine learning Basics under videos if
I click on all we're also ranked here as
well under the video section on organic
search results another example data
science for beginners we ranked number
one for that if I look at another
keyword data science interview questions
okay we'll rank number two for that so
we're ranking for a lot of videos and
why are we ranking for a lot of
different content and videos on Google
Search and on YouTube well we put a lot
of work in behind the scenes of creating
the video and that's what we want to
show you so part of that has a lot to do
with you know how our audience engages
and sees our video so for example we're
looking at a machine learning Basics
video here and we can see that it has
over 221 000 subscribers for this video
000 views we've had over 2 000 people
like the video and we have had over 270
plus comment on the video so when we get
our videos to rank then we can see
there's a lot of Engagement and so
that's the whole idea is when you do a
video and you want to show up on YouTube
you want people to enjoy you want people
to share it you want people to like it
you want people to comment on that and
that's part of the whole ecosystem of
YouTube It's you know we're going to
show you behind the scenes of what it
takes to get your videos to rank and
then we're going to show you some some
of the metrics involved with some of
these videos to help you stay ranking so
without further Ado let's go into how to
get your videos to rank on YouTube so
we're going to talk about keyword
research for YouTube we're going to talk
about some ways to create high quality
videos so the importance of user
engagement just as I showed you with the
machine learning Basics video all the
shares all the commenting all the views
and subscriptions then we're going to
get into how to promote your content and
then we're going to just review a little
checklist for you and sum it all up so
let's get started with keyword research
so basically what we want to do is
Center our keywords just like our
website we want to Center our keywords
around or our content around good
keywords so the videos on YouTube are no
different than the web pages on our
website so if we have somebody who
states YouTube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind Google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
Google so YouTube is pretty popular
majority people use YouTube search every
day to watch videos on a number of
different topics so they can find these
videos in Google but because YouTube's
so powerful and so popular people go
directly right into YouTube for their
searches and so the whole idea behind
YouTube being the second most well-known
search engine is centered around
keywords so if you have the right
keywords for your video then the chances
of you ranking higher increases on
YouTube so we're gonna share with you a
few easy ways to do keyword research
this is the most important step in
getting your videos to rank on YouTube
just like for those of you who watched
any of the SEO videos we produced it
simply learn you know that keyword
research is so essential to getting your
web pages to rank on Google well it's no
different keyword research and choosing
the right keywords is just as important
for your videos as is for your web pages
so we're going to go into a few things
to do here to find the right keywords so
we have the search suggestion you can
look at your competitors we have
different tools we can use some other
factors involved in Google itself so
let's start talking about some of these
ways to really hone in and do some good
research on your keywords to align them
with your videos first thing is search
suggest so YouTube has a feature called
autocomplete so if you've done any
searches on Google it's very similar if
you're typing something in to YouTube
search then YouTube is going to suggest
other related popular keywords so let's
take a look at that if we go back to
YouTube for a second and I just type in
machine learning YouTube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in this
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if I Choose You Know machine
learning tutorial I'm going to see a
video about machine learning tutorial so
here you can see Simply Orange rank
number one for machine learning tutorial
but there are other videos that show up
in my search result so we want to be
able to use the search suggestion box in
the search box field so when we're
typing in something you know YouTube
just like on Google is going to give us
those suggestions so if we're focusing a
video on machine learning then you know
we have some ideas of some other
keywords that we could center around
because these are are popular keywords
these are key words that people are
using to search on YouTube so that's one
suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video and title and description so
let me talk a little bit about that what
you want to do is you want to go to that
particular Channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitors YouTube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title description and then once you do
that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type in simply
learn here's our Channel page just by
clicking on simply learn I click on
videos ever wonder if there's so now I
can see all the videos ever wonder if
there's an easier way go back so here I
can see all the videos sort by most
popular once they do that then I can
choose a video this is the most popular
video right now for simply learn if I
click on that video it's automatically
going to start playing but what I could
do is some and play just look at you
know the content description so just by
clicking show more I can see all the
content that align with this video
that's one way to do it is simply by
looking at your competitors now what you
could also do is look at the tags
associated with the particular video and
so what you want to do is you want to
look at the HTML and so that means
looking at the page source so just like
web pages what YouTube does is they look
at meta tags so if you call from SEO in
order to get your pages to rank you need
to have a title tag and a meta tag
description so videos are no different
what we're doing uh for YouTube is
aligning certain keywords with the video
so if you take a look and do a search
for keywords by viewing the page Source
you're going to see all the keywords
associated with a particular video so
for example if I go back to YouTube and
I look at the page source of a video
let's just say this video here
Facebook's ad tutorial I'm going to pull
up the page source and all I need to do
is control F and type in keywords and
now for that Facebook video I can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're aligning with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that YouTube
autocomplete it's going to give you
those ideas this most popular keywords
so if they're related align those
keywords with the video so here you can
see Facebook marketing Facebook ad
strategy Facebook ads for beginners so
forth and so on so there's a lot of
keywords we've aligned here with that
particular video and again all you need
to do is look at the page source so
right click in view page Source do a
control F for keywords and you'll be
able to see the keywords aligned so you
could do that for your competitors
videos as well so you can see what
keywords your competitors using for a
video that's most popular for their
Channel and is also ranking on YouTube
and on Google so using the autocomplete
gives you those keyword ideas looking at
your competitors videos also gives you
some other ideas for keywords that you
can align with a video that's relevant
that you want to rank for so let's look
at uh some other ideas here so you can
install plugins and there are plenty of
plugins available on the Chrome browser
that will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples are vid IQ and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in Chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if I go
back here and I look at a video on
YouTube let's just say the machine
learning Basics video I have vid IQ
installed on my Chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid IQ is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video you're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with Facebook
some engagement metrics really what I'm
interested in is those keywords so if I
scroll down a bit here I can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning Basics video so vid IQ is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where they
rank so for machine learning Basics this
particular video ranks number one if I
go down I could see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's rank number two here I could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so I can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
I can also see some Channel tags but
really this is the video tags are the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you to really get
an understanding of what keywords to use
at the particular video so autocomplete
you can look at the page source of a
competitors video or you can use a
Chrome extension in this case I'm using
vid IQ to give me some information about
the video tags for a particular video so
according to an industry study using
keywords and video tags will help you
rank well on YouTube so you have to use
keywords and video tags if you want your
video to rank there's been a lot of
studies YouTube is so popular and videos
are so prominent in today's world where
if you have videos and you're going to
upload them to YouTube then associate
the right keywords with those videos so
some important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third-party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with keywords that have low difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose some something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so for talking
about machine learning Basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what Google's
going to do and YouTube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimize for and so we have a number
of different keywords that are disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume and low
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
that are high volume low competition or
relevant and you want to choose that one
keyword that is really what the
content's about and then those secondary
keywords that support the primary so if
you have a machine learning video you
could choose your primary keyword as in
this case the machine learning Basics
video so well chosen keywords help you
rank well on YouTube just like the
machine learning Basics so if I go back
to our video our machine learning Basics
video if I just type in machine learning
Basics I'll be able to pull it up and so
here it is if I click on it I'm going to
go to YouTube and so here I can see this
keyword we know humans learn from is
well aligned because it's in the title
it's in the copy and it's a line is a
keyword tagged with the video so we know
that that keyword has good volume low
competition is relevant because that's
what the video is about the basics of
machine learning it's an introduction to
machine learning so instead of honing in
on just introduction and machine
learning primary keyword is machine
learning Basics and then we supported
that video with those secondary keywords
what is machine learning because
somebody who doesn't own machine
learning is probably going to type in
that keyword and then introduction to
machine learning is a good secondary
keyword because it's explaining the
basics of what machine learning is all
about so primary keyword machine
learning basic secondary keywords what
is machine learning and introduction to
machine learning so that's the whole
idea behind choosing keywords you want
that keyword that really is going to
define the content and then support that
with those secondary keywords so
remember when you're performing your
keyword research choose keywords for
your videos that Google shows on the
video results page so what I mean by
that is your video can get more views if
you rank on Google as well so the whole
idea is not necessarily to be found on
YouTube it's also to be found on Google
so if I go back to Google and I just
type in data science for beginners and I
type in videos then you could see we're
ranked number one so even if you're not
looking at the videos clicking on the
videos link on Google search you can all
always just when you do a search what
Google's going to do is also put in the
videos here on par as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall for data science
for beginners but we're ranked number
one in the videos category and so
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for
beginners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
backlinko google Ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube tube are going to be
instructional based and so what Google's
doing is they're saying hey if somebody
types in how to or tutorial or an
introduction to anything that's going to
signal to Google that it's instructional
it's going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video and
it's educational in nature you know use
those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video title so we want to
use our Target keyword in the title of
the video and again we want to make sure
if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how to so for every
video video title YouTube has a limit of
a hundred characters so we really have
to pick and choose really wisely so if
we look at the video that we were
focusing on a couple of minutes ago so
machine learning Basics here we could
see under 100 characters we have machine
learning Basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really that key term
that really Google and YouTube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us Rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
those catchy words and numbers to gain
High click-through rates just like you
would on on the title tag of your web
page we want to do the same with our
video title because the video titles
what's going to show up in search so if
I go back to you know search here we
could see you know data science tutorial
data science for beginners so we want to
make sure in this case you can see data
science in five minutes so that was
purposely done so that hey I don't have
time to watch a video I only have a
couple minutes data science in five
minutes okay great I'm going to click on
the video and now I have an opportunity
to watch something and learn something
under five minutes so choosing the right
words in your video title is going to
help you get that click-through rate up
remember clicked array please clicks
divided by Impressions and an impression
is how many times your video shows up
and the search results on YouTube or
Google so we want to keep our
click-through rate high and in order to
do that we want to be able to write some
really good title tags for our video so
use catchy words like a number or how to
or what is because that's going to
resonate with people when they're
searching now for the description what
we want to do is we want to use the
target word at the beginning of the
description the title and the tags
itself so if I go back to my video here
machine learning Basics we know it's in
the video title and right off the bat if
I look at the description of the video
here I can see this machine learning
Basics video will help you understand
what is machine learning so our primary
keyword is in the first sentence right
in the introductory of the description
and so that's going to bode well for
optimizing our video the description
length is 5 000 characters so we have a
lot of characters to work with so if I
go back to my video I click show more we
have a lot of characters to really
describe what the video is about okay
there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 character first go ahead
and see if you can work in naturally
your keywords but one of the key tips
here is just make sure that first
sentence starts out with that keyword
that's a good tip of course you always
want to make it sound natural as
possible you don't want to stuff it with
keywords at the same time work them in
naturally work in your keywords
naturally and then include hashtags in
your description to help the audience
find your video is easily so if I go
back here you know we want to be able to
include hashtags so hashtags it's like
anything else you would use on social
media it just signals to the end user
hey this is what the video is all about
and if I go ahead and type in that
keyword then it's our video has a better
chance because it's a line with that
hashtag and then there's Target keywords
and LSI keywords latent semantic
indexing keywords we want to be able to
use those keywords as Target keywords
with our video so if you recall the
example I gave a few minutes ago we used
the Facebook ads tutorial as our example
here I could see all the target keywords
associated with that particular video so
don't be afraid to use those LSI related
keywords meaning keywords that are
related to the content use them as
Target keywords with the video so
between your LSI keywords Target
keywords and then using our primary and
secondary keyword in the title tag using
our primary and secondary keyword in the
description and then using hashtags in
the description the combination of all
of that if we chose the right keyword
then we should find that our video will
eventually rank on YouTube so just doing
these small tidbits with our keywords
really help get our video to rank so at
the end of the day we want to be able to
use the tools available to Us YouTube
Itself by looking at our competitors
those extension like vid IQ the
autocomplete to really find our good
keywords and then incorporating those
keywords into you know the title tag the
description as Target keywords hashtags
we should really be off and running with
our video on YouTube that's our turn our
attention to creating high quality
videos and some of the best practices
around that so along with everything we
mentioned about choosing the right
keywords we always need to keep in mind
that the videos we create need to be of
high quality so the content itself in
addition to the keywords is a primary
factor in ranking so in order to have
keywords we need to have content and in
order to rank we need to have you know
good content so let's talk a little bit
about creating content and what's
involved with that and what we really
mean by high quality videos so if you
have a video content that is not
informative or irrelevant to the topic
it won't rank so so that's just common
sense so you need to create content
that's aligned with the topic obviously
and then that way you have keywords that
are aligned with the content so but if
you have content it really isn't aligned
with the topic then you're not gonna
rank no matter how much you've optimized
that video so just keep that in mind so
there's a couple of things we want to
look at here so high quality content is
determined by really two metrics so
we're not sure about how good our
content is and how good of high quality
video we created we want to look at
audience retention and user engagement
so audience retention and simply the
percentage length of your video that the
audience has watched It's the percentage
your audience has watched so focusing on
audience retention is important for
people who want their videos to rank
high so if you want to rank you need to
optimize for the keywords but got to
keep in mind content so content is
related to audience retention and user
engagement so audience retention
percentage length your video of your
video that the audience has watched and
for example it can be both absolute in
minutes or percentages so audience
retention can be the average view
duration or percentage of the audience
that watched then we have user
engagement so yours engagement of
viewers who are engaged with your
content and so that means they're either
sharing it subscribing commenting or
liking so those are all forms of
Engagement so the percentage of users
who watched or how long they watched
versus engagement or in combination with
engagement are two factors for ranking
so let's talk about some tips for
creating high quality videos so we want
to publish longer videos and so what do
we mean behind longer videos so what's
the reason for longer videos let's just
suppose we have two videos one shorter
in length and one longer first video is
15 minutes long the second video is
seven minutes long so on average if
viewers watch about 40 of both videos
then video x which is 15 minutes long
will have more than twice the watch time
of the video that's seven minutes long
so remember duration we want you know
people to watch our videos longer so if
the video is longer in length if it's 40
then it's gonna have a longer audience
engagement audience retention so that's
one of the reasons you know from a
metric standpoint so even when viewers
watch you know both videos the time is
going to differ so we want to take into
account longer videos for primarily that
region is because you know it gives an
end user an opportunity to watch the
video longer and then it's going to help
us rank our videos longer so when we
talk about watch time so if one video
has higher watch time than the other
watch time is is just the number of
views times the average view duration so
another tip is we want to plan our video
script so we want to keep the content
organized my recognition is you know
create an outline first and once you
create an outline of how the video is
going to flow then start populating with
content and so to me that's how you can
keep the flow organized okay is really
with an outline starting out with an
online there's no videos are no
different than say a presentation if
you've done a PowerPoint presentation
you always want to start out doing an
outline and then we want to upload a
high resolution videos high resolution
we don't want to create videos that you
know are small resolution like say you
know 400 by 400 resolution or something
you know something really small we want
to create something a very high res so
according to back or link Oaks more than
50 of videos on the first page of
YouTube are high definition so high
definition videos of higher quality are
going to be shown on the first page of
YouTube more often than not so high
resolution videos organizing the content
publishing longer videos are examples of
creating high quality video we also want
to make sure that content is relevant to
the title so if we're talking about
machine learning Basics you know
obviously the content is going to be
about you know intro to machine learning
or what is machine learning and then the
title should reflect that content so
aligning the title sets the expectation
for the end user so when they see a
title what is machine learning then when
they watch the video they're expecting
to learn about machine learning and what
it is so if it meets expectations then
the chances are that person who's
watching the video is going to watch it
longer and that means it's going to
fulfill the viewers requirements and
when you align everything accordingly
keywords titles content then at the end
end of the day the user is going to
watch it and the more they watch it the
higher the engagement the higher the
engagement the better chance you have to
rank some other tips that you could use
to create high quality videos so we want
to be able to you know use examples to
clarify our content so you don't be
afraid to go into another screen like I
am if I want to I'm talking about videos
jump into the machine learning Basics
video which I've done throughout this
session I can simply do that by keeping
the user engaged here this video is
about machine learning Basics well the
titles align with the video we made sure
that we have a nice description about
what the video is about and we're
aligning the expectations so not only
that I'm showing you example within the
video itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it visually
appealing so visually appeal feeling
means imagery or examples in the video
and then when we talk about imagery you
know you want to use good images in your
video so I use public domain sites that
are available to you like Shutterstock
or flat icon I mean there are plenty of
those sites out there so feel free to
use any one of those sites to use high
quality images in your video give more
information to your audience okay giving
maximum relevant information can help
gain more views and so when we talk
about more information again it goes
back to you know the examples you use
there's no should be no shortage of
examples here description use all 5 000
characters at your disposal imagery we
want to build up as much information as
you can in the video itself to keep the
end user the viewer engaged we also want
to create original content so always
create original content you could
certainly get ideas from YouTube if you
want to create a video about machine
learning see what else is already and
done do searches on YouTube itself but
you know when you're going to create a
video yeah you can create another video
about what is machine learning but just
make sure it has your own take on it
you're the subject matter expert when
creating the video create it with your
own original content have high audio
quality and video effects so just like
you see here on this video we have
effects in it and the audio is of high
quality meaning no background noise no
Distortion and we want to be able to
speak clearly in the video so you want
to speak clearly loudly concise just as
I'm trying to do now so that you can
understand what I'm trying to say or
what the viewer is trying to to
understand when they're watching the
video so watching and listening are two
of the components and you want to make
sure both of our high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
Point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other and intermix it
with examples those are ways to keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles for your video
so transcripts is just more content
that's aligned with the video and the
search engines will be able to pick up
that content and help your video rank so
to me that's a key component to creating
a good video is having the necessary
content that go along with the video
that outline I referenced earlier in
terms of organization you always want to
have a Content outline so what topics
are you going to cover in the video
that's why you need the outline to point
that out confirm that before you
actually start creating the video okay
focus on the initial 15 seconds so
that's key you know somebody's going to
click the play button of your video and
if you don't catch them in the first 15
seconds then they're likely going to
pause the video or just go ahead and
close it out altogether so you want to
be able to capture somebody's attention
right off the bat and even before they
click on that play button you want to
make sure again you're exceeding
expectations that title is aligned with
the content so in your first 15 seconds
it basically needs to be catchy but also
setting the expectation of what the user
is expecting so in this example here we
want to pay close attention to the first
15 seconds that's when viewers are most
likely to drop off so we can look at
audience retention in YouTube so use the
options above the graph to view absolute
audience retention or relative audience
retention so audience retention is
basically how many views a video
received and the percentage of the total
number of video views and that includes
every moment of the video as a
percentage so we'll show you an example
of what that looks like so here if we go
to the machine learning Basics video we
can look at the audience retention
report and this is since it's been
uploaded the lifetime audience retention
so here we can see a nice graph the
percentage of people who viewed it and
how long they viewed it so in percentage
so here for example I can see you know
43 44 watch the video for at least two
minutes here I can see
28.6 percent wash it for six minutes
plus so that's the audience retention it
gives us an idea in terms of percentage
how many people or percentage of people
watch the video at what length so that's
audience retention so we want to keep
that number high at the very initial
stage of the video and we want to keep
it high throughout and that's why you
always want to create high quality
content using those examples using
imagery making it organized content not
pausing you know going from one point to
the other those are all best practices
to keep the viewer engaged and then we
want to add resources from well-known
sites so throughout this video we've
used backlinko there are other sources
we've used so if you have a source go
ahead and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning Basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or you two can recommend to the audience
to set up end screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant videos to your audience towards
the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlists so this is a feature that
keeps your audience engaged with
relevant content by Auto playing the
next video so if you enable this feature
it's going to go from one video to
another pattern interrupts keep the
audience engaged so basically it allows
for your audience to stay within one
video without having any interruptions
involved and so going back to the did
you know audience retention report helps
you analyze how well your videos are
engaging to the audience so what do we
mean by that well if I go back again to
my audience retention report how
engaging was it well I could see 42
percent 43 percent watched it on average
of 3 minutes and 21 seconds so to me
that's pretty good of course we we
always want a hundred percent of the
video the video is seven minutes long if
almost half of our audience saw over
half of the video then I would say
that's pretty good people were engaged
so audience retention just is a good
report to start looking at to help you
understand how engaging is my video and
if your video is not engaging you know
you can always go back and edit it or
fix it or tweak it so remember the
average view duration for all videos and
top performing videos listed by all time
we can look at that information as well
in addition we can look at demographics
so we can get an overview of the age
gender and location and we can look at
playback locations report and what the
playback locations report does is it
helps us determine the platforms where
our videos are being streamed from
within YouTube look at the traffic
sources where did the viewers come from
devices did they look on mobile or
tablet and so if there's any doubts you
know if you have any questions please
drop a comment below but especially if
you have any doubts on the metrics so if
we go back into YouTube we can look at
analytics and if we're looking at
analytics we can see more and then this
is going to show us everything we need
to see from device type so if I click on
more I can see my playback location so
this will show me where the video is
watched it was on a watch page or a
channel page I could see the traffic
sources I could see the gender and age
so if I click on the viewer age report I
can see the percentage of views by age
so I can get a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it where they come from all the
information they needed now okay so it's
all within YouTube analytics so again if
you have any questions about that you
know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to YouTube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you publish to YouTube
high quality align with your keywords
you're going to be able to view the
metrics by looking at YouTube analytics
so let's talk about the importance of
user engagement so engagement is as we
mentioned important because basically we
can't rank without engagement our videos
won't rank unless we have engagement so
that's why it's important so engagement
is somebody liking the video commenting
sharing it or subscribing each one of
these is important to ranking so yes you
need to line keywords yes you need to
have high quality content so when you do
both of those and you upload your video
then it's up to the viewer and so the
hard work that you put out for the video
is hopefully going to pay dividends with
engagement so you want people to do one
of these four okay so let's talk about
what that means so how do I get
engagement so we already talked about
creating engaging content so there are a
lot of tips to creating engaging content
and so according to wordstream if your
content is entertaining then over three
quarters of the users are going to share
it so that's part of keeping uh users
engaged just keeping it entertaining is
part of getting a high quality video so
remember on that high quality video when
we say entertaining the audio portion
has a lot to do with it examples has a
lot to do with it quality of the video
itself has a lot to do with it so a lot
of components so all those components on
a high quality video are going to lead
to engagement so parts of what you could
do in your videos is conduct a quiz so
meaning the quiz itself is a way to keep
people engaged in your video so that
also help you get some more comments so
according to backlinku video comments
help and rank in your video higher so
just as I mentioned the last segment
about YouTube analytics and all the
different reports available on YouTube
hey have questions on those just go
ahead and add a comment so that's a way
to entice your users or your viewers to
add comments is if they have questions
because you know with videos you're not
going to be able to cover every detail
or every minute detail about a
particular topic you can only cover in
some cases the topic at a high level so
users are going to have comments or
questions naturally and so the comments
section is a good way to remind viewers
hey if you have a question or comment go
ahead and put in the comment section
because that will lend to engagement as
well so we want to add sources from high
quality websites that'll help with
engagement okay use humor in your video
we want to be able to basically you know
make it human based we don't want to be
robots so we want to be able to sound
like you know we know what we're talking
about but at the same time talk to the
viewer not necessarily at the viewer or
or looking the other way and just going
through the motions so adding humor
adding personality never hurts at the
end of the day we are all human adding
that clear call to action at the end of
the video will also lead to engagement
so if we win the video with hey leave
your comments on this video or hey feel
free to share this video with colleagues
who are interested then that's a call to
action that's likely going to lead to
more engagement reply to your comments
as well so if you have comments we
always want to reply to them likely
those comments are going to be questions
because again as I mentioned even in
this video about how to rank your videos
on YouTube okay there's a lot of
information and a lot of information
sometimes doesn't get covered in its
entirety and so we want to make sure
that if we miss something because we're
only human that we're able to respond in
the form of an answer to a question that
somebody leaves in the comments section
so more comments also lead to higher
rankings because it's engaged so when
you're getting high engagement and your
video starts to rank well you know
you're going to start feeling really
good and what is that going to do look
at that feel good is going to lead to
confidence which in turn is going to
probably lead to more videos and that's
exactly what we do at simply learn when
we're in the education business but
we're in it to not only educate but
making sure that our videos are shown to
as many people as possible so that we
can educate as many people as possible
so it's all it's contagious so getting
ranked feels good and then once you get
ranked then you know you probably have
good engagement okay let's talk about
how to promote your content so once
you've done all the hard work getting
your video done high quality content
optimized with keywords and then publish
to YouTube we want to let everybody in
the world know about it right so we want
to promote it we've done all the work we
want to promote it now so is it
necessary to promote it I would say yes
because once your video is published you
want to reach out you want to reach out
out to your audience not necessarily on
YouTube but on different platforms so if
you're active on Facebook or Twitter
that's an opportunity for you to post or
tweet something about the new video so
when we say different platforms I am
talking about you know social media
platforms so it depends on what you're
active on so if you're active on
Facebook yeah go ahead and post some of
you're active on Twitter go ahead and
tweet something it could be you know on
LinkedIn group if you're part of a
LinkedIn group about you know machine
learning then go ahead and post
something to that group to promote the
video so that's going to help Drive
traffic to the video and then help with
engagement so we want to engage with our
audience on those social media sites so
it really depends on what you're active
on so if you have a large following on
Twitter then go ahead and you know share
that YouTube video link on Twitter with
the Tweet that's going to drive traffic
from Twitter to YouTube Remember You
know you're going to be able to see
audio audience engagement or retention
by getting people to watch the video so
you're going to be able to see right
away by promoting the video and driving
traffic to the video how engaging it is
remember the more people you have
watched the video the more engaging it
becomes the better it's going to rank so
it's an ecosystem and promoting your
content is part of that ecosystem so it
all starts with social media if you're
active on whatever platform that is go
ahead and promote it so you can also
look at you know content based social
media sites or social media content
based platforms like Reddit or Flickr
for example so you can participate in a
forum discussion on Reddit so in this
example here it's about machine learning
so we want to be able to post something
about machine learning with the link to
our video so we can also go to
content-based sites that are q a uh
related like quora for example core is a
really good site where you know if you
go there post information about machine
learning or the basics of machine
learning with the link back to the video
it's going to help because not only is
it going to drive traffic but it's going
to signal to Google hey you get a lot of
traffic coming from Cora this is going
to bode well for this video in terms of
ranking so here's an example you know if
you find a question that you can post on
core then you're going to get people to
click on your video and respond
accordingly on quora or you can act as
the person responding to a question
that's already there so somebody already
asked a question about what is machine
learning you can respond with your video
as the answer so you can just simply
embed your video URL as part of your
answer that'll help Drive traffic so you
can also create your own blog and embed
your video so in the case of machine
learning here we have an example machine
learning what is it and why it matters
so this goes nicely with the video so
here you can see the person the author
of this blog went ahead and embedded the
the relevant video in the blog post so
they play off one another nicely you can
also opt in for influencer marketing
meaning hey you can reach out to
somebody in this example here you know
Katie nuggets posted information about
machine learning so in this case why
choose machine learning as a career well
they get information and then what do
they do they went ahead and embedded the
video about machine learning Basics and
so working with you know influencers in
a particular category or topic will help
Drive traffic to the video you can also
create a YouTube playlist so playlists
tend to rank high in YouTube searches so
if you find yourself doing a lot of
videos we'll go ahead and you know go to
your channel and simply on your channel
you can go ahead and create playlists so
when you create playlists basically what
you're doing is you're organizing the
content into different playlists no
different than say the music you have
set up on your you know your iPhone or
iPad or or iPod whatever it is you're
using so you're just creating different
videos in a particular category and it
YouTube likes it it's organized it's
going to help you get your videos found
quicker and easier on YouTube Itself by
putting your videos in a playlist so
here you could see we have entire
playlist on machine learning trending
Technologies cloud computing Big Data
digital marketing project management so
a lot of different playlists very
organized if somebody goes to the
channel they're going to be able to go
to the playlist that's interesting to
them and see all the videos there so it
allows not only the end user to find
what they're looking for but it's good
for YouTube because YouTube likes those
playlists so we want to engage our
Audience by posting your video link on a
community page so you could do that
within YouTube and you can prefer to
link your YouTube channel in your email
so you can also do that so for example
if I go back to YouTube and I'm looking
at a a YouTube video you know I can
always Click Share so here I'm gonna get
a particular URL that's associated with
the video and I can just embed that so I
can embed the whole thing in my email I
can embed it on a web page or a blog
post so just by clicking share I can
also immediately share it onto the
social media platforms that we mentioned
Facebook LinkedIn Reddit okay Tumblr so
there's a lot of ways to embed the video
not just on a blog post or influencer
blog posts but in our email and on
social media as well so here's an
example of what we can do with the
YouTube discussion so we can also
bookmark the video on a popular
bookmarking site you know like stumbled
upon or Reddit or you know there's lots
of other ones out there so there's
plenty of sites that you'll be able to
go to and bookmark that content so that
people can find it and you can all
always opt for backlinks so that means
that hey if there's a blogger out there
that blogs about machine learning you
can always you know ask that blogger to
create a link back to the video and you
could reciprocate do the same thing so
that helps increase the authority of the
video so a lot of things you could do to
promote your video so let's do a quick
review on everything we talked about in
terms of ranking your video on YouTube
it all starts with the keywords so we
want to identify a list of keywords that
are relevant to the video so we can use
tools to choose our keywords but
remember we want to choose keywords that
have high volume and low competition and
so where can we go to choose those
keywords well we can use the
autocomplete on YouTube we can check out
our own competitors videos or you know
we could use vid IQ or tubebuddy or any
of these extensions in Chrome to help us
look at the keywords that are tagged
with a particular video so remember we
want to have a primary keyword that's
aligned with the content then we want to
choose LSI keywords as our secondary
keyword or keywords that are related to
the primary keyword so we want to create
high retention videos meaning that first
15 seconds of the most important but
throughout the video we want to use
examples we want to keep it interacting
by adding quizzes imagery good audio
good video quality so we want to focus
on the user experience and we also want
to optimize our video content what does
that mean well those keywords that we
chose we want to use them in the title
we want to use them in the description
we want to use them as hashtags we want
to use them and tag them with the video
themselves so we can add keywords to our
meta tag okay we don't want to overdo it
but we want to add a handful of keywords
that is are associated with the video so
we want to be able to write I catchy
video titled and description so remember
use some of those key phrases like a num
number or a question like what is
machine learning so we want to use
relevant meta tags for the videos and we
want to use popular YouTube tags so we
want to be able to tag our videos
appropriately to watch the length of
your meta tags so there are links
involved remember keywords at the
beginning of the title Target keywords
in the title description and tags we
want to use interesting thumbnails to
increase our click-through rate ensure
the thumbnails are relevant meaning when
I say thumbnails I mean the actual title
tag itself or The Meta description we
want to use hi-res videos we want to
create you know videos with good high
audio quality don't be afraid to put in
video effects like some animation don't
be afraid to use examples and then you
know obviously look at the draft of the
video before you publish it so does your
video follow an outline is it organized
so these are all the things to take into
account and there's there's plenty more
you can do you know you remember once
you create not optimize that video you
want to promote it you want to make sure
that you're sharing it on social media
you create a complimentary blog you know
generate backlinks from say other blog
posts so there are lots of things you
can do to promote your video so before
you promote it you want to organize the
content create good quality content
align it with keywords once you publish
it you know keep organizing it by
creating this playlist and then reach
out on social reach out on different
communities related to the topic and all
those things combined will help you to
get your YouTube video ranked today
we're going to talk about how to
increase YouTube subscribers so with
YouTube It's All About subscribers the
number of subscribers you have on
YouTube it's just one of the key metrics
to measure success so gaining more
subscribers can help you achieve more
view counts on your YouTube video so
it's all about how to get subscribers
and today we're going to talk about how
to get more subscribers and before we We
Begin let's just show you what we did at
simply learn so if we look at the past
365 days on our YouTube channel you can
see we started here back in uh if we
look back at March 9 2018 we had 208 and
you can see just over the course of the
year it kept creeping up creeping up
creeping up and creeping up we've gained
you know a significant number of
subscribers over the last year and
what's our secret well it's posting
videos so you can see we've posted a
number of videos over the course of the
year and then our subscribers have gone
basically 165 percent over the last year
so you can see it's part of it is about
posting videos because when you post
videos you have people who can watch
those videos we have people watch those
videos you can have engagement and then
when you have engagement you have shares
and people who like it and then other
people will see it so it's kind of a
halo effect so to speak so getting
subscribers it takes a lot more than
just posting videos and today we're
going to talk about some tips to help
you increase the subscriptions so let's
start out with some of those tips we're
going to start with creating engagement
informative content so engaging in a
formative content that's where we're
going to start talking today about how
to increase subscriptions then we're
going to talk about publishing videos
frequently so simply learn you could see
the past 365 days we were consistent in
publishing videos consistently
throughout the month and the weeks so
another tip we're going to talk about is
how to optimize your YouTube videos so
there's a lot that goes into
optimization but this is a key key tip
to pay attention to because when it
comes to posting publishing videos on
YouTube you need to align certain things
like keywords and content and metadata
so optimize our videos we're going to
talk a lot about that then we're going
to talk about optimizing the YouTube
channel so there's some tips and tricks
here you want to do to optimize your
YouTube channel oil producing high
quality videos we're going to talk about
that adding a subscriber Watermark to
your videos okay that's another tip
we're going to mention today engage with
our audience okay that's what we want to
do we want to engage with our audience
that's a really key tip we're saving the
best for last promote your videos and
different platforms so all of these tips
we're going to talk about today so let's
get started and talk about create
engaging informative content so that's
the first place we want to start okay so
create engaging and informative content
so if we want to gain more subscribers
on our Channel we have to create highly
engaging and informative content why
because not our audience is not going to
pay attention and they're not going to
watch the video and then the
engagement's not going to be high and
they're not going to share the video and
they're not going to tell their friends
or like it and so this is where it all
starts you have to be able to plan your
content and not only planning your
content but you gotta create it so it's
engaging and formative so how do you do
that well let's talk about that so the
first thing is you have to know your
audience okay so when you create a video
who you're creating the video for I mean
that's where it all starts so when
you're creating your content you're
creating your content for your audience
you're not creating it for the entire
world now we know on YouTube there's a
lot of cute videos about kittens and
jokes and you know people playing games
and you know everybody likes positive
things on YouTube but you know when
we're talking about a specific topic you
know we really have to hone in on a
target audience and so if you know who
your audience is then you can really
hone in on your content okay so that's
the first thing ask yourself who is your
audience and then build your content
around that specific audience don't
build it just for the Mass general
population because it's not going to be
engaging and informative so that's the
first place to start then you want to
engage that audience with relevant
content so if you know your audience and
depending on the topic you want to make
sure that whatever the topic is the
content matches the topic don't there
off course if you Veer off course you're
not going to engage your viewers your
viewers are coming to watch the video
for specific reason the reason is the
topic okay so if they're your target
audience and they want to watch the
video that's a specific topic then the
content has to align so plan your video
script so if you know who your audience
is and you know you want to engage them
with relevant content go ahead and plan
the script out so what I normally do is
you know have an outline and then once I
have the outline then I go ahead and
create my slides if I will or my topics
points I want to talk about and then I
write out those points I want to make
sure I get all my points in and that's
what you should be doing you want to
plan it ahead of time so that you can
get all your relevant points across
that's what makes a video informative
okay you want to ensure to give maximum
information to your audience so the key
here is maximum information so you don't
want to over below the audience but then
again you want to cut out information so
you want to make sure that when you're
planning your script and you're writing
the outline that you're making sure you
include all your points that you want to
get across once you include those points
then go ahead and you know write your
script and make sure all the information
for all those points are in the script
that's how you're going to ensure you
give maximum information but you don't
want to overdo it so if you feel like
it's too much information it probably is
too much information back off a little
use the information to create another
video so it's all about knowing your
audience so all of these points play
against one another so be clear and use
more examples in your content just like
we're doing here okay just like at the
beginning of the session I showed you an
example of Simply learn subscribers over
the past 365 days and so that's what we
want to do we want to be clear but use
examples to punctuate the content or the
point we're trying to get across so we
want to include sources from high high
quality sites so if you're going to use
examples make sure they're from relevant
high quality sites when I make high
quality meaning does your audience know
who that source is or that site if it's
really specific and your audience may
not know then it's probably not high
quality so just keep that in mind always
play to your audience so you want to
start your video with an interesting
hook so again I get back to this example
if you're still watching this then the
hook worked we showed you our
subscriptions we showed you how we grew
over the course of a year you could see
our growth and part of it was posting a
lot of videos with relevant and
informative content and so you see how
we did it so you're paying attention you
want to know how to do it and so part of
what we did is exactly what I'm telling
you now we know who our audience is we
plan out our scripts we use good
examples and we start our videos with
interesting hooks now when we do our
videos we also create original content
so that goes back to planning your
script okay you always want to you know
come across as original and informative
when you do that you're going to be
engaging but if you're leveraging
somebody else's content then the
engaging part may not resonate because
it's not your content to begin with so
always always always use original
content okay so keep the content flow
organized so again that goes back to an
outline you know feel free to change up
the outline so the flow makes sense add
visuals to your content and make it
appealing always include images to me if
you can use images in your videos and
play off the video or the images then
it's just gonna flow and make it a
little bit more engaging and appealing
meaning the content so visuals help
guide and Aid in the points you're
trying to make so don't make it so text
Heavy you know accentuate it balance it
with some images use Simple language and
crisp sentences meaning don't choose
jargon don't come across and talk above
your audience you always want to talk to
your your audience and talk in a
language that they're going to
understand so it goes back to point one
if you know who your audience is you're
talking to them as if they're right in
front of you and not you're above them
or they're below you you want to talk at
them so add cards and screens and
pattern interrupts to engage your
audience and so YouTube cards or just
interactive panels that slide in and out
when a video is playing so it encourages
interaction by the viewer okay so you
can add up to five cards which include
images text or clickable links so feel
free to play around with some of these
features that YouTube has to offer to
make your content more engaging so tip
two publish videos frequently so
creating and uploading videos
consistently will help you increase your
YouTube subscribers so suppose you
haven't published videos for more than
say a month or two months it's likely
that that audience not gonna subscribe
to your channel so think about YouTube
videos as a popular TV program that
comes on once a week when a new episode
comes on based on the regular schedule
it's consistency and that consistency is
what helps your users stay engaged so
for example if I go back to our YouTube
channel you know what helped us gain
subscribers was our consistency in
publishing videos you could see we were
consistent in publishing a couple of
videos a week every couple of weeks and
so this helps users stay engaged they
know when the video is coming out they
know that simply learn is good for two
three four videos a month and the great
thing about publishing videos is that
when somebody does subscribe to your
channel they're gonna get a notification
or YouTube has an option where they can
get a notification via email so I
subscribe to Simply learns Channel I
subscribe to other channels like Google
analytics for example so anytime Google
analytics publishes a video I get an
email that says Hey Google Analytics
YouTube channel just published a video
and the great thing is I'm checking my
email and I'm getting this notification
in Gmail so guess what I can watch the
video right then and there just by
clicking on the link in the email I
don't even have to go to the channel but
knowing that if you publish consistently
and somebody does get the email once a
week then it's more likely they're going
to engage especially if the content is
original engaging and informative so
frequent video publishing equals more
subscriptions so according to Social
Media examiner YouTube channels that
publish videos more than once a week are
performing much better so if you can
afford to publish more videos more than
once a week the chances of you gaining
subscribers quicker are going to be
greater so keeping a fixed frequency can
help you quickly gain more subscribers
posting videos is like almost like
blogging I always say start small if you
could do one blog post a month and then
once you get in a routine then you can
ramp up the frequency so from one blog
post you could do two a month then four
times a month and once a week or twice a
week same with the YouTube videos you
want to get into a rhythm you know start
with once a month and ramp it up okay
you'll find that the more you ramp it up
the more subscribers you're gonna get so
tip three optimize your YouTube videos
so optimizing your videos will help your
content rank higher on YouTube so this
is a give must it's not a given it's a
must you must optimize your videos if
you want people to see them of course if
you don't optimize people aren't going
to see them then people aren't going to
engage and then not subscribe so it's
just kind of a snowball effect so this
is an important tip so I mentioned at
the beginning when we were going over
all the items we're going to discuss
this is the one item that is a must and
a given to some degree because if you
don't optimize your videos are just not
going to be found so you need that
audience to watch your video so audience
who tend to interact more with your
content have more chance to subscribe to
your channel but they're not going to
subscribe if they don't even watch your
video so there is a snowball effect in
play here if we don't optimize your
videos so okay Rob what are some of the
tips to optimize your YouTube video well
let's go through some of those tips so
to ensure your videos reaches the
relevant audience on YouTube you need to
optimize the title description in the
video tag okay Rob what do you mean by
title description and video tag so let's
take a look at that so when you actually
create your YouTube video you're going
to have an opportunity to put in a title
you're going to have an opportunity to
put in a description and you're going to
have an opportunity to add text so those
are the three key areas okay so once you
put in that what it looks like on the
front end is this so if I go back to
YouTube and here you can see another
video that we did about a month ago you
could see what is SEO so if that's our
topic that's our title uh or of the
content of the video then the title of
the video is going to be what is SEO and
you can see we also added in some other
content for the title so what is SEO and
how does it work SEO tutorial for
beginners and then our brand name so we
have some content to work with for the
title okay and then the description we
have a lot of characters to work with
descriptions so use as much as you can
here to describe what the video is about
here you can see we did that and so it's
always good to include this information
okay and then you can see we have tags
up here seo seo tutorial for beginners
digital marketing so we put in the
necessary information here on this video
to help us rank because if we don't
optimize it we're not going to rank and
so you can see we just put a lot of
relevant content around the description
around the title and around those tags
by doing so we're able to optimize this
video and get found so that's just an
example three of the things you can do
to help optimize is your YouTube video
so if you want to watch more on how to
optimize meta tags then I suggest maybe
watching the other video we did on the
subject how to rank YouTube videos so
this goes into more detail about how to
optimize the title The Meta description
and The Meta tags but there's a three
quick fields or areas that you can use
to optimize your video so just something
to keep in mind write a long description
with keywords timestamps and links so
what I mean by time stands for timestamp
an audience can choose the section of
the video that they want to look for and
then links prefer to include relevant
Links of your other videos so those are
just some additional tips to help keep
your content engaging so remember when
your content is engaging then people are
going to like it people are going to
share it and watch it later so upload a
captivating thumbnail okay so you want
to include a thumbnail that's going to
grab people's attention you want to
upload a transcript of the video so that
goes is back to when you're creating
your content when you write your
original content you want to keep a
transcript of the content of the video
so that you can upload that as well and
then add a start screen and end screen
to your YouTube videos so that way you
know it's somebody plays the video
they're gonna see it what it looks like
up front and then the way you finish it
they're going to see an end screen at
the end and so you just don't want to
keep it dark and black and
non-descriptive so according to
backlinko using an exact keyword in your
video title can help you with rankings
so high ranking more views more views
more subscribers so that's why I've been
saying all along you need to get these
videos optimized so again use an exact
keyword in your video title so let's go
back again to that video I just showed
you a couple minutes ago what is SEO so
here we started out with a question what
is SEO that's the name of the title
that's one our exact title of the video
that's our exact keyword okay so what is
SEO and how does it work and then SC a
tutorial for beginners so what is SEO is
our exact keyword and that's part of the
video that's the content of the video
that's in the title and we use it
throughout the description as well so
using that exact keyword in your video
title can help with the ranking so
whatever your topic is your title of the
video or the topic of the video included
in the title so backlinko also mentions
that there is a moderate correlation
between a Channel's total subscribers
and rankings and so for some of you this
may be common sense it's just like
organic search if you're not ranking
you're not going to get traffic on
YouTube if you're not ranking you're not
going to get eyeballs on your videos and
you're not going to get subscribers so
higher rankings can help you to get more
subscribers but you can't get those
rankings unless you optimize and so
again just for the sake of Simplicity
going back focus in on your title make
sure your title matches the title of the
video itself when you're publishing your
description use all the amount of
content available to you so you can see
it this entire description has a lot of
content maximize the content and then
use tags using those three Fields those
three areas can help you optimize your
video and gain the necessary ranking you
need to get viewers which will turn into
subscribers so tip four optimize your
YouTube channel so we just talked about
optimizing our videos now we're going to
turn our attention to our YouTube
channel so one of the easiest ways to
ask your viewers to subscribe to your
channel is really by creating a good not
even a good a great YouTube channel
trailer you also want to add Channel
keywords a description and some good
artwork and then having sections and
playlists to keep your videos organized
these are all good tips to creating a
good YouTube channel so let's talk about
some of these these tips here so we want
to give your audience a preview what
your channel is offering so this is by
hooking your audience with the trailer
so you can create a trailer to you know
just give your audience an idea of who
you are as a brand what kind of videos
you're going to be posting and give them
kind of a taste of what the future
videos are going to be like okay you can
even tell them your release schedule in
the trailer so you can start off by
saying hey hey guys we're new to this
we're going to be posting one video a
month but as we get rolling maybe two
per month and you know one per week you
know just being honest and open and
talking to your audience and get them
excited about future videos that's what
the trailer is all about so you also
want to keep it that the channel
description short interesting so in your
channel you want to have a description
of what the channel is all about what
kind of videos you're going to be
posting so in addition to the trailer
you want to write something short and
interesting then we want to use keywords
in our Channel descriptions just like in
the videos with what is SEO we included
what is SEO in the title we included you
know what is SEO in the the description
and so we want to be true to what our
channel is so pick keywords not only
include those keywords in the videos but
include them in the channel description
pay attention to the first 100 to 150
characters I have your channel
description because that's what's shown
next your channel on the search results
so for example here you can see we have
a description here simply learn is one
of the world's leading certification
training providers we partner with
companies and individuals to address and
so you can see those characters 100 to
150 are what shows up in the channel
description when somebody's trying to
understand hey simply learn just
uploaded this video who is simply learn
so you want to write short interesting
Channel description so that when
somebody's first introduced to your
video they could see what your Brand's
all about so and your description with
an appropriate call to action so short
interesting good call to action at the
end of the video a good call action
would be hey check out our next video or
check out our latest video something
that's going to gauge somebody and get
them to watch one of your videos so you
want to pick interesting channel art so
let's turn our attention to the simply
learn Channel page and here you can see
we recently had reached a milestone so
recently reached the 200 000 K
subscribers so 200 000 subscribers is a
big achievement for simply learn we went
ahead and updated our channel art and
I'm sure we will reach 500k we'll update
the artwork then too but the point is
you want to keep your channel art kind
of interesting hip and cool and feel
free to change it out every once in a
while so you have that option in YouTube
to do I mean so very simple so here you
can see simply learns Channel if we go
home we got all our videos listed here
we got the about us you know something
very short and interesting about us
here's our call to action for more
information visit simply learn so you
want to make sure when you you create
your channel get some good artwork in
there put your description and play and
create your first videos and get them
posted up there and optimize them
accordingly okay so this is the other
tips to go with that channel art and
description is a profile picture
relevant to your brand so you always
want to maybe put out the the company
logo up there okay so here you can see
we have the company logo at Accurate
relevant Channel keywords so if we go
back to who we are who are we we're the
world's leading certification training
provider okay that's who we are okay we
partner with companies and individuals
so we're all about training and training
is one of our keywords so you can see
that simply learn we provide online
training and machine learning AWS Amazon
web services devops Big Data digital
marketing project management a lot of
different topics so make sure that's
included in the channel description
feature the playlist on your home page
so if we go back to the home page we can
see here we have our channels so you can
see we have ai machine learning trending
Technologies cloud computing tutorials
devops tutorials popular videos big data
we have a lot of different channels so
you want to organize your videos into
different playlists so those playlists
are going to feature on the home page of
your channel so how you organize the
playlist is totally up to you but I
would certainly create a playlist for
different sections so depending on your
product your services think about how
you want to organize don't just stick
all your videos in one playlist then
optimize the playlist titles and
descriptions for search rankings so just
like the videos themselves just like the
channel description you have an
opportunity to optimize the playlist
titles and descriptions so be very keen
on aligning the right keyword with the
playlist title so here you can see
programming language tutorials project
management tutorials digital marketing
tutorials so we're very clear on how we
go about choosing our titles because we
want to optimize those playlist titles
okay we can rearrange our videos in a
playlist so we want to rearrange the
videos in a way that we're maybe putting
the freshest the most newest the video
that's been published last first so
almost in descending order if you will
so we want our users to see what video
has the latest in that particular
playlist so they're seeing the most
recent first but you can rearrange your
videos any way you want feel free to
play around with it of course you can
also take the video that's the most
popular and put that up front so people
could see that first vice versa you can
take a video that maybe hasn't gotten a
lot of views or is it ranked
particularly High maybe put that video
up so it can get some views and some
shares and likes so how you rearrange
your videos is totally up to you just
have some rationale behind that so
choose a playlist thumbnail from a top
performing video so for example if I go
back to our YouTube page you can see the
top performing videos here you know for
example this one we got a nice thumbnail
here what is machine learning so if I
click on that
most popular videos so 3 000 likes on
this video a lot of views 250 000 plus
views so have a thumbnail to go along
with that particular video so according
to backlinko YouTube SEO ranking Factor
study discovered that channel keywords
have a small yet significant correlation
with Higher YouTube search rankings so
Channel keywords so when you're
optimizing your channel and you want to
include keywords start with your
description so if I go back to our
Channel okay if I go back about us make
sure your description has those relevant
keywords in it that's where it all
starts so in case you have any doubts if
you're not sure about everything we
talked about on optimizing the channel
go ahead and drop a comment below
because we do respond to every comment
that gets posted on our videos so if
you're not sure how to go about
optimizing your channel when you say
align keywords with the channel what
does that really mean so if you want
some clarity on that go ahead and drop
it's a channel if you're not sure about
the trailer video drop us a comment
we're more than happy to expand upon the
explanation of how to best optimize your
channel okay tip number five produce
high quality videos so we need to get in
the habit of producing high quality
videos because viewers don't prefer to
watch videos that have poor audio and
video quality it's just that simple you
need to know what it takes to produce
high quality videos if you don't you're
just going to discredit you're not going
to come across as relevant you know I'm
going to come across as qualified
professional there's a lot of things
attached to poor quality videos so we
need to to create high quality videos
for the end user so let's talk about
some ways in which you can create high
quality videos and so the first is to
avoid any noise in the background so you
want to have a nice quiet atmosphere no
distractions so people can hear you
clearly and only you clearly you want to
use good audio recording equipment
there's plenty of options available on
the internet usually I would recommend
going with something paid not overly
expensive because you get what you pay
for so if you use something free it
might not be of good quality and you
might not have all the features and
bells and whistles with a free option so
you know use good audio recording
equipment again it can be online or it
could be some software just make sure
that you're able to produce good high
quality video and audio so when you do
purchase that audio recording equipment
you want to have something similar to an
input volume meter that way you can see
whether your audio is coming across or
not so if you're not seeing green lights
then your audio is not coming across if
it's red it might be distorted and so
you want something that's going to
signify that you're really pushing out
good quality audio you want to create
your videos in 1080 pixel size okay
that's HD and so you want to have at
least minimum 1080. so anything less
than that it's probably going to come
across as not so good maybe staticky
blurry not professional not high def so
you want to create a high def video and
1080 is about the minimum you want to go
and then you want to plan your video
script before filming so it goes back to
some of the other points I made earlier
you always want to have a video script
available so you know what you're saying
when you're recording your audio that
way you're not doing something on the
Fly then you want to use good lighting
for video recording so you don't want to
be in a dark place you want some nice
lighting so your video comes across well
lit people could see you they're not
struggling to strain their eyes on what
it is you're trying to show and appear
because of poor lighting again it just
comes across as professionals so if you
can you know shoot a high def video with
good audio speaking clearly having a
professional script with some good
lighting then people are going to take
you serious and they're going to start
to listen and engage and see the video
as good quality and very relevant and
informative and share it so use slow
motion and jump Cuts wisely so there's
some features you could do with your
video you know using slow motion and
jump cuts are some of the features you
can use to accentuate your points and
then set up a green background for
recording again this is for you know
making sure that the video part of it
comes across in good quality then
stabilize your video recordings with a
tripod that way you're not moving your
video camera all around and and again
it's coming across the shaky and poor
quality shoot horizontal video videos
you don't want to go vertical it tends
to cut the screen so you want to stay
horizontal so that people can see
everything that should be included in
the video okay you want to capture a
wider shot using a clip-on lens again a
good feature good tip to use use that
wider shot okay so you could do that
using a clip-on lens and then choose
good video editing software I can't
State this enough because you're putting
all this time and effort into a video
you need to be able to edit it to cut
out you know some of the things you
didn't want to say or maybe some poor
quality or or you know you just want to
have a smooth professional output for
your video and so you gotta have good
video editing software there's plenty of
options available on the internet again
I would go with something low cost but
paid usually free isn't exactly the way
you want to go if you're trying to
create a high def good quality video and
at the very least review your work
before publishing I just said it a
minute ago I'll say it again you want to
be able to have a really professional
video and high def when you have a good
professional video in high def with good
audio horizontal shots you know nice
green background image nice well lit
it's going to come across as
professional and if you have a
professional video then people are going
to take you seriously they're going to
see you as a professional and then share
or subscribe and like and then they're
going to watch more videos and and
that's how you start to build up a
reputation as being a very professional
organization so just following these
simple tips on producing high quality
videos so you want to review your work
because if you don't you put all that
effort into it and then you're going to
realize hey your video is low quality
and then you're gonna have to do it all
over again so follow these tips get a
high quality video and you should be on
your way to ranking in fact according to
backlinko YouTube preferably ranks HD
videos so you gotta have that 1080 uh
pixel size that way a you know your
video is going to come across crisp and
clear and YouTube prefers that tip six
add a subscriber Watermark to your
videos so this is a great feature in
YouTube so it's a feature that allows
you to add a watermark that can be shown
on all your videos the reason why you
want that Watermark because you want to
keep reminding your audience to
subscribe to your Channel The Watermark
can be whatever you want but normally
it's going to be some type of logo or
brand and a call to action and so how do
you add a watermark to your video well
you log into your YouTube account it's
it's pretty simple at the top right
corner you're going to select your
creator Studio icon and then you're
gonna go to channel select branding and
then add a watermark to your video so if
we look at that in YouTube so here
Creator Studio on the left side
navigation I'm just going to click
Channel then I'm going to click branding
and then once you click brand name you
have the ability to add your watermark
and then you can add it to the entire
video at the end of the video a specific
start time and then just click update
and that's pretty much it so you want to
be able to add this so that you can
brand your videos with an image and then
add that CTA so this is a good good
feature for YouTube it allows you to be
consistent with all your videos by
branding and adding that call to action
tip 7 engage with your audience so you
want to be able to interact with your
audience as much as possible just
because the video and you can't see
people doesn't mean you can't engage
with them so when you interact with your
viewers especially when you interact
with them immediately there's
gratification you know everybody likes
to be responded to nobody likes to be
ignored and so when somebody is
responded to there's a higher chance
that your viewers are likely to gonna
become customers it's just customer
service it's how you really want to look
at this okay so when you engage you're
creating a service for your customers so
here are some tips on how to engage with
your audience so first is at the end of
every video convey a thank you message
to your viewers you know thank you for
spending the time out of every busy day
to watch this video you know some of our
videos go an hour plus long and so when
somebody's taking an hour to watch a
video it's only the least you can do is
thank them now you can thank them and
give them some information about where
to go for more information because if
they watch the whole video they're
already engaged and they're probably
going to want to learn more so you
always want to follow up to thank you
with where to go for more information
just like our videos always convey at
the end okay you always want to ask your
audience for their feedback or ideas on
the video so with YouTube there's a
comment section and you always want to
encourage comments so comments can be in
the form of feedback so as you're
watching this video feel free to leave
feedback on other ways to engage with
your audience or some other tips to
increase your subscribers is on YouTube
so we're always looking for those ideas
we want to keep it engaging so somebody
may have some other ideas that we didn't
think about and so we always appreciate
that from our audience so we very much
appreciate the feedback that our
audience gives us so not all the
feedback there's always going to be
positive some of the feedback could be
less than positive or even negative
there could be mistakes so the idea
behind getting feedback is you want to
look at it you want to read it and you
want to react to it you want to react to
it positively in the form of you know a
thank you for the feedback and looking
at the feedback weighing it and
incorporating the feedback so you don't
always want to make the same mistake
twice in a video so if there's something
definitely wrong with the video that
we're doing for example and somebody
looked at it and gave us feedback on it
we'd certainly definitely take a deep
look into that and try not to do the
same mistake twice because likely that
user is going to watch the video again
so you always want to learn from your
mistakes and you want to try turn those
mistakes or turn those comments into
future videos okay so create videos
based on your commenter's request the
audience has given us feedback we should
take that as positive and sometimes
that's creative sometimes those ideas
for more videos okay you always want to
ask questions to your audience and
reward excellent commenters so we try to
ask questions in our videos and when
users respond with their answer if
there's an excellent comment or
excellent answer you know we can reward
them you know reward them in the form of
say some type of gift card or gift
certificate or promotion or something
there's always some way to incentivize
somebody who provides excellent feedback
you can always give Emoji Hearts there's
so many emojis out there that you can
use emojis just to engage with your
audience based on the feedback that
they're giving the point is if your
audience is taking the time to give
feedback you always want to respond to
it and you want to respond to a pause so
emojis tend to have a positive
connotation to them and so responding
with an emoji especially to a favorite
comment goes a long way so you can
reward your community both on and off
YouTube for their engagement and support
and that's just being creative you can
reward in many ways many ways not
necessarily monetarily but by
recognition you could do promotions you
could do something fun there's always
ways to reward and prefer to host live
streams and interact with your audience
so you don't always have to do a
pre-recorded video there's certainly
YouTube has them other platforms like
Facebook have them Instagram so you can
certainly reach out to your audience
with a live stream and that's talking
directly to your audience right there in
the flash so when you can have an
opportunity to talk to your audience and
engage with them that's always going to
work because they can see personality
they can see what you're all about and
there's two-way conversation and so that
will lend to more of a you know
relationship so to speak with your
audience so you want to create videos
for subscribers and subscribers can get
impressed when a channel dedicates a
video for them so you know take the time
out to create a video just for your
subscribers subscribers are the ones who
are most likely going to engage with you
okay they're your loyal fan base so if
you create something for them that's a
form of a reward so you can Captivate
your viewers by uploading interesting
YouTube stories as well you can also
hear from your audience and and get
their videos and use their videos and
upload them to your channel so according
to backlinko video comments of a very
strong correlation with rankings so as
you create a video feel free to talk to
your audience and ask them hey if you
have any comments feel free to put them
in the comment section right below this
video I see that a lot now with a lot of
videos and I'm gonna ask my audience
right now to do the same thing if
there's anything you see about rewarding
the audience or engaging with the
audience feel free to comment we'd love
to get your suggestions because if you
can engage with the audience even more
the then that's only going to net
positive results not only in rankings
but with your subscriber base so
comments are the way to go solicit
comments respond to the comments reward
the comments tip number eight promote
your videos on different platforms so
promoting your videos on different
platforms has been around for many years
it's a good strategy once you create
your video on YouTube you want people to
see it you want to get it out there so
if you want to increase your YouTube
subscribers this is a strategy you have
to perform so let's take a look at all
the ways you can use and leverage
different platforms to increase your
subscribers so before you do that you
want to research discover how you can
use different platforms so the first
thing you want to do is look at the
platforms you're already using if you're
using Facebook and Instagram that's
probably a good place to start but
there's other platforms you can also
leverage and we're going to talk about
those so social media most companies
most individuals are are on in some form
or fashion amongst the most popular like
Facebook and Instagram so you could
start there so with Facebook you can
post something include the link of your
YouTube video with Facebook if you're a
business you have a business page you're
communicating with your community and
that's a great way to get started by
promoting your YouTube video you can
also do the same on Twitter or Instagram
or whatever platform you're on go ahead
and post something or tweet something
and include that link to YouTube you can
participate in forums and blog
discussions so there's plenty of forums
and blogs out there where you can
participate in discussion and include a
link to the YouTube video if it's
relevant and natural so for example here
there's a Blog about machine learning
you can include if you have a video
about machine learning and the response
to that conversation in this example
we've done that on Reddit you can list
your video in relevant and reputable
directories there's plenty of
directories out there plenty of video
directories okay that you can just go
ahead and publish your video on you can
use testimonial link building okay so
somebody can provide a testimony and
include the link of your video you can
opt for influencer marketing so if
there's somebody that is associated that
likes your brand or product and has a
large following you can ask them to post
a video on your behalf it's a great way
to reach an audience fairly quickly okay
you can earn backlinks from relative
relevant and authoritative websites so
for example if you look at this website
here touchgenics okay there's a article
here about you know certificate of
achievements okay for AWS so if you
scroll down we could see our video is
included here in this particular web
page so this is a high quality web page
okay that's generating it backlink for
us not only is it generating a backlink
it's also generating traffic and
awareness for the video go ahead and
find out if there's any websites that
are relevant to your video topic and see
if you can collaborate with them on
producing a web page to include that
video you can also take advantage of
email marketing by adding your YouTube
link in the email signature for example
it's a simple email any email client
like Gmail or Yahoo or even Hotmail or
Outlook is going to have an ability to
or give you the ability to add a
signature in the signature you could
simply just include a link to the video
or to your YouTube channel it doesn't
have to be to a specific video but it's
a way to get people to your YouTube page
or to that video so the whole idea is
more eyeballs more potential subscribers
engage your Audience by posting your
video links on community pages so for
example you know we're promoting
something here on a community pitch and
that's going to get some additional
traffic over to us you can always
bookmark your videos on bookmarking
sites like stumbledupon.com again this
is free very little time to do this but
it's a chance for you to get the video
out there and even generate a backlink
you can collaborate with other YouTube
channels this is always a good strategy
if you're creating a video on a
particular topic on YouTube chances are
there's probably somebody else out there
doing the same thing it doesn't have to
be necessarily a competitor it can be a
complimentary product or service and if
you offer that then go ahead and
collaborate with them and see if you can
exchange your videos on their Channel
and you could take their video and put
it on your channel in a particular
playlist okay so that's a way to
collaborate with other YouTube channels
is swap videos you could join High PR QA
sites and post answers to the questions
related to your video like core is
always a good example or ehab okay so
core there's always a question of being
posted and if you have the answer to
that question in the form of your video
then go ahead and post a response with a
link to the video on YouTube it's a
great great way to get the video noticed
and it's relevant and natural okay you
can embed videos in your blog posts or
if you're using a platform like
WordPress for example very easy to go
ahead and just take that video you can
even just put the link in the blog post
I like this option I think blog posts
are always good because you don't have
to be text Heavy with a blog post you
want to create a blog post that's nice
and balanced with an image and text but
if you put a video to support your blog
post that goes even further and blog
posts themselves can be engaging and
interactive with your audience so having
a video in your blog post always goes
well in my opinion okay so you can
promote other videos in your end screen
for example at the end of your video you
can always promote something related
like we've done here in this example so
lots of ideas get your video out there
use them in email use them in your blog
post go to free bookmarking sites like
stumble upon you know collaborate with
them the people on YouTube you know go
to core respond to a question use social
media to your advantage there's lots of
opportunities to get your video out
there the more you can get your video
out there the more traffic you're going
to get the more traffic you get to the
video the more subscribers you're going
to get so that's how the game is played
in order to get your video out there but
these are relatively you know low time
consuming ideas to get your video If
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so with Twitter it's all about tweets
it's actually a verb now uh when you do
something on Twitter you actually tweet
and there are a lot of people out there
tweeting in fact Twitter has over 1.3
billion accounts so a lot of tweets
going on in the world of Twitter so as
of the third quarter in 2018 last year
Twitter had 326 million Global monthly
active users okay so active meaning
every day using the platform on a daily
basis so a lot of people using Twitter
it's very easy to use as you'll find out
and what you're going to find out today
is how to increase followers on your
Twitter account so they can see more of
your tweets okay a little bit more about
Twitter there are 500 million tweets
posted every single day that's a lot of
tweets so you can imagine with every
tweet is a hashtag that accompanies that
tweet so a lot of information be
disseminated across the plan platform so
tweets with videos so Twitter does a lot
of videos as well as images attracts 10
times more engagement than other forms
of content so if you watched our YouTube
videos and some of the other videos we
had out there regarding Facebook or
Instagram you'll know that videos do
perform better Twitter is no exception
so if you have a video even if it's done
on YouTube or if it's not unpublished on
YouTube use it with Twitter you're going
to get more engagement so Twitter has 75
percent of its users use the platform
for news Okay so people go to Twitter to
get their news that's where they go they
don't go to a regular website
content-based website they get their
news via Twitter it's just very easy to
digest because it's so few characters 75
of B2B businesses Market on Twitter so
not only is it a b2c or business to
Consumer platform it's a B2B business to
business platform so a lot of businesses
are on Twitter basically promoting
either a product service or trying to
establish themselves in the industry
using the platform so let's take a look
at Twitter and let's take a look at some
of the ways in which you can increase
your followers it all starts with your
profile you always want to make sure you
have a complete profile your name
obviously the Twitter platform that you
have is going to have a handle okay in
this example here it's a totally real
person at totally real person is the
Twitter handle and that's what you're
going to want to use to disseminate your
Twitter profile to others so you want to
make sure that you have a good image you
have a real name and a good handle that
people can associate with and remember
so you want to be able to set up this
profile with a key word friendly bio
okay a link to your website and a
picture that represents your brand
always helps so make sure it's is
complete you can even take a step
further by customizing the color scheme
of your profile you can add a header
image that sticks to your theme that
will help your profile stand out and so
let's take a look at an example here so
if I go to Twitter here if we go to
Simply learn it's Twitter account okay
their handle is simply at simply learn
okay they've customized the header they
use their logo now if you're an
individual you probably want to use a
nice profile pick here where they're
based a little bit about them so just a
you know customize complete profile goes
a long way you don't have to go
overboard with an elaborate design so to
speak but just make it stand out make it
associate with who you are as a person
and a brand those are best practices in
getting that profile up and running you
don't want to use something Bland and
generic you know take the extra step
create something unique make sure your
profile is unique you have a good image
okay make sure it's complete with of you
know telling people who you are and what
you're all about that's really the first
step on really any social media platform
so you want to promote your Twitter
profile to drive users from other social
media platforms so when you actually get
that Twitter account set up and you
actually do have your handle go ahead
and share it that's the first step in
getting followers if you're already on
Facebook if you're already on Instagram
then use those platforms to announce
that you're on Twitter you can also take
that a step further and you know send
out an email to friends or family or
like I said if you're on Facebook go
ahead and set up a post say hey guys I'm
on Twitter you know come follow me so
you could also use business cards
advertisements marketing materials and
events to put that Twitter profile on
okay so it doesn't have to be within the
social media sphere it could be even on
your website it can be even in email so
you can basically promote that profile
again you want to make that profile that
handle easy to remember so so totally
real person is the profile in this
example we're going to use that profile
everywhere we can whether that be
offline or online you don't don't be
afraid to use it on a business card
especially if it's easy I can just
simply go to Twitter and type in that
handle so you want to stay active on
Twitter with regular retweets replies
and favorites and that's just it's just
so easy to retreat and reply and add
favorites so let's take a look at that
on Twitter so you can just simply I'm
logged in as me and if I want to retweet
something that simply learned did I can
just simply click on the retweet button
and I can add a comment if I want to and
then I'm going to retweet it's that
simple so now that tweet is going to
show up on my profile my handle and I
could simply like it if I scroll down
here okay top 10 it Trends shaping 2019
notice a simple tweet supported with an
image so I'm just gonna like that so I
can even comment on on it I can click on
the comment and click a reply here okay
and that's going to show up in this
tweet here just like if I click on this
I'll be able to see what other people
have written and so it's that simple if
I want I can just click on the email
button and even send a message to
somebody right from that tweet the point
is I can do everything I need to do
right in the platform but to get started
if you don't have any tweets you know go
and find other companies similar to you
look at their tweeting and you can
always retweet that that's a good way to
get going with tweets that's what I
started doing when I started on Twitter
in 2008 I didn't know what to write
particularly and I didn't know how to
write it particularly well so I looked
at what other people wrote and and
tweeted and just retweeted those that's
a good way to get your Twitter account
started okay so engaging with users is a
great way to get more followers so on
simply learn I retweeted one of their
tweets I liked another one of their
tweets and it's probably gonna get their
attention somebody at simply learn is
going to say okay Rob Sanders went ahead
and liked us and you know what we're
gonna go follow this guy he seems to be
somebody who's an audience member who
likes what we have to do likes what we
have to say like what we're tweeting
let's go ahead and follow him and so
that's a good way to get going with your
Twitter account is to really start
retweeting and liking other tweets from
other users so you can find an
appropriate time to post your tweets to
increase exposure retweets and followers
and you want to do this you could do it
within Twitter or as I'll mention later
you can do it in a social media platform
like Sprout social or HootSuite or later
or buffer and there's plenty of social
media platforms out there for you to
schedule tweets point is you want to be
able to schedule those tweets when it's
the appropriate time so you don't want
to do it in the middle of the evening
because what's going to happen is likely
by the morning other tweets are going to
bury your Tweet so you want to be able
to find the appropriate time to post
your tweets so according to a survey
conducted by HubSpot the best time to
post is between 12 and 3 P.M and why is
that well most people are usually in
lunch checking their phones yes Twitter
has an app and in fact most people use
the app just like on Instagram just like
on YouTube the app is very popular on
Twitter so it's very easy for somebody
to check tweets especially during the
lunch hour and then from 5 to 6 p.m that
that in between time when when people
are wrapping up work or heading home
okay so weekdays have shown to have the
maximum amount of Engagement so during
the week when people are working highly
engaged with whatever they're doing
depending on what industry you're in
they're likely going to check the
Twitter and react during those times
okay so that was a survey conducted by
hotspot but really what you want to do
is you want to be able to use one of
these social media platforms like a
HootSuite or later and find out exactly
when are people engaging with your
tweets when I what time of the day what
day of the week are you getting the most
retweets or the most likes okay that's
what you want to do so you can use this
as a starting point as a best practice
but eventually you're gonna have to
cater to your audience based on when
you're getting your tweets engaged so
you want to increase followers by
following more people it's that simple
and so it really is that simple let me
rephrase that so it really is that
simple so if I go back to Twitter you
know Twitter's always going to recommend
somebody for me to follow and normally
those are people that are similar as
myself okay so they're not just going to
choose random people they're going to
choose people who are following people
you're following so there's going to be
a connection to some degree or they
could be people who use similar hashtags
tweeting the same content so you want to
go ahead and follow people the rule of
thumb on Twitter is if you follow
somebody on Twitter chances are they're
going to follow you back you know I was
once told when I was using Twitter that
hey you want to give somebody about
three days to follow you back so that's
always what the rule I stuck to you know
wait about three days start following
people you can see here 833 people that
or accounts Twitter accounts that simply
learns following and over ten thousand
nine hundred followers to Simply learn's
Twitter account so for me I don't mind
having a nice balance myself I have just
as many followers as I do following and
that's a good thing so because you want
to be able to keep up with what people
are tweeting and so you can retweet at
the same time you want to be following
people as well because they're going to
follow you back okay and that's how you
can build up your Twitter followers by
following people and it's as simple as
clicking on a follow link so the key
here is to follow people who follow your
content people who are following dollars
of your followers and you can use
Twitter's poo to follow list and upload
your email contacts to Twitter okay
since they know you they're more likely
to follow you back okay so you can use
Twitter's who to follow list and so if
we go back to Twitter here's the who to
follow list and so this is what Twitter
is going to recommend but you can click
on this link here find people you know
okay so if I click on find people I know
then I can upload my contacts from
Outlook or Gmail and they're gonna find
people who are already on Twitter based
on who I'm connected with so generally
that's how it works that's a quick way
to get more followers is to connect with
people you know by the way I'm going to
follow simply learn because I wasn't
following them prior so now I just
clicked on the follow button now I am
following so now I'm going to see simply
learns Tweets in my feed so let's take a
second to look at a brand okay so it's
time for a brand watch let's have a look
at some of the best Tweets of 2018. now
remember there are a lot of active users
millions of active users that's a lot of
tweaks so what we did was we scoured
Twitter from 2018 and we went ahead and
picked out some tweets that we thought
were pretty good and so the first one is
Wendy's now I don't know if any of you
have actually eaten at Wendy's I used to
eat at Wendy's a while ago I know their
frosties are pretty good so what they've
done is they Incorporated that Frosty as
part of a giveaway okay so basically
they're saying hey grab yourself a free
Frosty with any purchase in our app so
they're encouraging people to use our
app and then they're following that up
by saying hey and then join us on Twitch
from two to five eastern as we unlock
all that Frosty goodness so they're
promoting something that's going to
happen on a specific point in time this
is last January they're encouraging
people to use their app and they're
using that Frosty as kind of a carrot if
you will okay is a catch it's a giveaway
so they were able to you know basically
wrap a bunch of things into one so get
encourage people to take part and I'm
sure a lot of people went ahead and took
part of this but we could definitely see
that 206 retweeted this tweet 302
basically commented on it and over 3 000
liked the Tweet so the Tweet was good
and it basically engaged with users who
doesn't like a free giveaway especially
free Frosty so that's why this
particular tweet really does some
justice for the target audience Their
audience they're they're giving
something away to Their audience just by
allowing them to you know use their app
okay so this tweet combines a lot into
one and I like it apparently a lot more
people than I did 3000 plus also like
this tweet and so moving on to how to
increase your followers on Twitter you
want to mention other people in your
tweets to increase engagement so what do
we mean by that so let's look at Twitter
here so go back if we look at simply
learn just take a look at some of their
tweets what they're doing if we scroll
down here they have hashtags so they are
mentioning specific hatch tags but you
can also mention handles as well so the
hashtag is always going to start with
either pound sign but if we scroll down
here if you use the at symbol you're
actually mentioning somebody so in this
case we're mentioning Matt Bailey so
Matt Bailey says is Matt Bailey's handle
and so if you get a shout out to
somebody they're gonna pick up on that
and then they're going to probably
follow you okay who doesn't appreciate
getting recognized for something
especially something as small as a tweet
okay notice I can go ahead and click
follow if I want to follow my bailey but
it's not a bad idea to add people into
your Tweet and you simply do that by
just using the at symbol and using their
Twitter handle it's a good way to get
recognized by that Twitter follower it
also increases engagement because it's
adding validity to the tweet and it
definitely catches the attention of the
person mentioned remember if you use
that person's handle they're going to
see that that you mention them okay and
what it's likely going to do is start
some type of Twitter relationship okay
they're gonna then follow you you're
gonna follow them and chances of them
retweeting you in the future or
mentioning you in the future is probably
going to increase and overall that
increases engagement so another
important thing you want to do is find
and use hashtags that are relevant to
your brand and audience so this is a
must this is mandatory on Twitter you
need to use hashtags Twitter's all about
hashtags every tweet that goes out
should have a hashtag tame so what you
can do is figure out what hashtags are
trending so here what Twitter does is it
trends for you so these are all specific
hashtags that are trending it's Mother's
Day Happy Mother hey Sunday morning
whatever works for you these are trends
that happen to be moving meaning a lot
of people are using them clicking on
them okay so you can use a popular
hashtag what I would also recommend is
you use a unique hashtag the rule of
thumb is usually about two hashtags in a
tweet but that's a rule of thumb but
rules are made to be broken do what's
best for you if you want to include more
than two hashtags go for it the only
thing I'm recommending is include a
hashtag so find out what's trending you
could just look right in Twitter or you
could just create your own unique
hashtag it works both ways but when you
have a hashtag in your Tweet and
somebody clicks on it then they're going
to go to that particular handle that
hashtag and so when they look at the
hashtag and see all the tweets with that
hashtag in it so that's the idea behind
hashtags you want to have hashtags okay
so if somebody clicks on a hashtag that
you've used then they're likely going to
see your Tweet in that hashtags feed
okay so that's how how hashtags work you
want to use hashtags okay but you want
to use hashtags that are relevant to
your branded audience that's really the
key so hashtags help your tweets to be
found through Twitter search thus
improving your reach and increase the
visibility of your post so that's
another benefit Twitter has search
functionality so somebody can simply go
in and start searching on Twitter so if
I go back to Twitter I can just do a
hashtag and start typing in something
like Spanish and I'm gonna get some of
the most popular Spanish hashtags or
Hashtags with the word Spanish in it and
so this is an idea for me that if I
wanted to use a hashtag with Spanish in
it these are some ideas but they're
certainly searchable on Twitter okay so
if I just click on Spanish okay I'm
going to be able to see all the Hashtags
with the word Spanish in the hashtag so
definitely use hashtags it's the most
beneficial feature of Twitter Bar None
So some reasons why you in hashtags also
a good idea well you're gonna get more
engagement and you're likely to get
retweeted as well so when you get
retweeted then that means more eyeballs
because if somebody sees your Tweet and
retweets it they're retweeting it for
Their audience and so it could go viral
so to speak on Twitter and that's where
the engagement comes in so if you're
using a hashtag that's trendy well
somebody might like that okay if you're
behind a specific movement or you're
following a specific baseball or
football team or cricket team or
whatever team you're following then if
you use that team and the hashtag that
could also get you some some likes so
don't be afraid to use hashtags mix it
up play around a little use something
unique use something that's trending
just use something but make sure it's
relevant to the Tweet find out what
works for your competition what works
for them might work for you too so you
know I work with simply learn but you
know simply learn has a good Twitter
account you know they have lots of
followers they're doing a lot of
tweeting so if I wanted to be just like
simply learn well I could simply just go
to their Twitter account and see what
they're doing okay see what they're
using as hashtag so what kind of tweets
they're implementing and see who's
following them so I can simply just
click on the 10 900 followers that they
have and what I could do is I can go
through and start following the people
that are following them so just mimic
your competition to some degree or mimic
others in the industry you know look at
what they're tweeting again start out by
retweeting some of the stuff they're
retweeting if it's good stuff if it's
like a tweet don't be afraid to retweet
even your competitors tweets okay use
you need cash tags use the hashtags
they're using look at who's following
their brand so you can really learn a
lot from others in your industry
including your competition because what
works for them again might work for you
especially when it comes to hashtags or
people whose phone following them again
people who are following them would
likely follow you if you're in the same
industry so it's as simple as looking at
who's following them and following those
same people remember the rule of thumb
is if you're following somebody they're
likely to follow you back so again you
can analyze things like the number of
followers they have the frequency of
their tweets what their profile looks
like how they respond to the competition
of customers okay what are they tweeting
about what types of content brings them
more engagement meaning of all the
tweets which one is getting the most
likes or retweets get some sense of what
they're doing and again when I say mimic
I mean what I'm saying is quote Best
Practices from that Twitter account this
will give you an idea what you need to
do to get more followers so it's always
a good form of flattery when you can
mimic what somebody else is doing just
like every other social media platform
following Twitter influencers who belong
in your industries always a good idea so
if you're in the food industry and
there's these star chefs out there
probably not a bad idea to follow those
star chefs you know if you're in the
technology industry well probably not a
bad idea to you know follow Bill Gates
or Elon Musk or Richard Branson or
somebody else and that's a big
influencer who has an influence on a lot
of people okay but make sure they're in
your industry that's the key if you can
make sure they're in your industry and
you follow them chances are if they look
at your Twitter account and see you're
posting or maybe retweeting some of
their tweets they're likely to follow
you and if they're following you your
tweets are going to show up on their
handle on their feed and so don't be
afraid to go out and connect and follow
those influencers it's a good way to
boost up your followers so again this
will help you gain followers since you
can replicate what they've done with
their profile so again just like the
competition mimic what your influencers
are doing okay so people tend to follow
people who follow influencers so you're
all of one like mine so to speak okay
influencers might retweet or share your
post if they find you retweeting
favorites and replying to their posts so
remember if you're following a retweeter
or excuse me an influencer and you
retweet their post chances are they
might retweet one of your posts and
again put you in front of a large number
of people since they're influencers so
all of these are good valid reasons to
follow influencers because if you're out
to increase your reach and exposure it's
hard to ignore influencers in your
industry okay you want to use images and
videos while tweeting remember videos
get multiple multiple times more
engagement than not using them at the
very least use images but you use images
don't use stock Photography use images
that are relevant so one of these tweets
caught my eye here from Simply learn so
if I click on you know here it was
further down here it looked like you
know these are people who are engaging
in a conference and it might have been
one that Matt Bailey was at so it was a
retweet from Matt Bailey as a matter of
fact but you could see what simply
learns doing is they're including either
a video or they're including an image in
every tweet and so that's likely to
boost up engagement so according to
buffer which is a another social media
platform adding a relevant high quality
image in your tweets can help you gain
more than a hundred and fifty percent
engagement okay videos are six times
more likely to be retweeted so if you
have an Arsenal video or even one video
don't be afraid to use it my
recommendation is try and use images as
much as you can in almost every tweet
images go a long way and again it's
going to help improve engagement meaning
more retweets more followers okay more
followers more eyeballs so it's a
Snowball Effect just by using images
Okay so let's take a look at another
brand from 2018 okay Pizza always my
good example to use on these webinars I
like pizza here this just says it all
you know they're talking about art and
they're using Pizza in the form of art
so they didn't really have to say much
else here this pretty much says it all
and they did get some retweets they get
some just some likes so sometimes you
don't have to say a lot to make your
point sometimes just the image itself
will do the job this was actually not
from 2018 this goes all the way back to
2016. so still holds true if you use an
image that image is going to get
engagement okay so on Twitter just like
most other social media platforms you
can promote your Tweet so you can use
Twitter ads to do that so you can
promote your Tweet and what you do by
promoting it is putting it up above so
that most people will be able to see it
okay so see if we can find an example if
I go here I could see this person is
promoting their handle but if I go down
here I can see a promoted tweet by
Constant Contact so they're promoting
their tweet here so it's not a bad bad
idea if you have some Media budget to go
ahead and either promote your Tweet or
advertise on Twitter so what that's
going to do is put you in a more
prominent position and get your tweets
out there and the whole idea for that is
to get people to engage here you can see
a call to action from Constant Contact
so if I click on that I'm going to go to
probably a landing page on their website
and so the whole idea when you advertise
on Twitter is really just like any other
social media platform you want to put
yourself in front of the Right audience
and so Twitter's no exception so with
Twitter you could put yourself in front
of the Right audience so what you could
do is you could promote a tweet you know
do promoted Trends or you could do
promoted accounts so you have a number
of different advertising options on
Twitter what we just looked at was you
know looking at promoted accounts and a
promoted tweet so when you do advertise
there are advantages you have to to pay
only after achieving your marketing
objective so that's a benefit of Twitter
the cost per click it's a cost per click
model so it tends to be fairly low you
could tail your audience so again you're
picking and choosing who you want your
promoted tweet or Trend or account to be
in front of and it's targeting is based
on either engagement or it's based on
keywords I.E hashtags so really you
could tailor who you want your Tweet or
your handle to be in front of and so
that's the really the benefit of Twitter
if you have a lot of active users on
Twitter you can really put yourself in
front of those active users if they're
your relevant audience at a low cost per
click so it's definitely worth the test
so you want to offer Twitter support to
your users okay so I can't stress this
enough okay so what you want to do is
when users have questions about your
product they're more likely to tweet you
for support hence they're likely to
follow your account so don't be a afraid
to use the messaging option as well so
we go back to Twitter okay chances are
somebody might have a question for you
here you can look at big ads it's great
connecting with PPC experts can't
believe tax season is here we've got
some great insights so what they're
doing is they're using the messaging app
but they're offering that messaging app
in the form of customer service so don't
be afraid to use you know direct
messages to reach out to people in the
form of support what you don't want to
do is buy Twitter followers chances are
you're going to get the wrong followers
so even though it may boost your Twitter
follow account these Bots cannot use or
buy your products or services so stay
away from all sorts of buying a Twitter
followers you want to build your Twitter
following naturally Twitter is also
cracking down on bot followers so a lot
of Bot accounts that were paid to follow
users were shuts down shut down by
Twitter so just my point is everything
we've mentioned today is what you want
to take advantage of okay if you want to
pay for something pay for a promoted
tweet reach out to influencers look at
what your competition is doing use
hashtags okay these are all best
practices in organic ways to build
followers so don't get involved with
anything that's going to involve Bots
and adding thousands of followers to
your Twitter account because chances are
it's just going to lead to no engagement
so create useful and relevant content so
what we started out by saying is hey if
you're not sure what to do retweet
retweet which somebody else is doing you
know look at your competition's Twitter
account see what they're tweeting get
some ideas as to what you want to tweak
so you want it to be useful and relevant
to your industry okay you want somebody
to engage that's the whole idea behind
Twitter the whole idea is if you're
going to Tweet something you want to get
somebody to engage with it so use
Twitter polls your old recent blog post
brand news industry news and events and
highlight customer stories I'm mean all
of those are ideas that you can do to
put content out there okay so for me one
of the things I do is I'm definitely one
for industry news so if I'm in the
industry of digital marketing if Google
did a recent algorithm update I'm going
to likely tweet about it or retweet it I
also am a blogger so on my particular
website if I blog I'm gonna make sure
that blog gets over to Twitter so those
are some ideas in which you can create
useful and relevant content on your
Twitter account you definitely want to
get that content out there but you want
to make it useful and relevant quality
over quantity because you want people to
engage so bring variety to the type of
content you share so I'm in digital
marketing I deal with pay-per-click SEO
but am I going to just do pay-per-click
and SEO no I know that analytics I know
that you know Google tag manager I know
that they'd be testing all of those are
elements of digital marketing so I'm
going to Branch out out and talk about
some of those things that support
digital marketing so that's an example
of bringing variety to the type of
content you share so don't just stick to
one thing you know feel free to reach
out a little bit shake things up by
sharing other forms of updates like
engaging quotes and questions these work
best when complemented by an image and
an act as a great discussion starter so
good point here even if you want to
Branch out of your industry and just
throw in a nice useful quote it's always
a good way to gain some attention and
get some engagement okay let's look at
another brand and see what they've
tweeted about so we're looking at
Forester here so think about emotional
qualities and their implications so here
you can see customers that feel
surprised or grateful or appreciated
they're sharing that Insight with you
and so this was interesting when I saw
this so what I did was I simply you see
the hashtag here the four digit digital
basically if you want to look at this
particular study I just went to Twitter
and I typed in that hashtag and now I'm
going to be able to see you know some of
the other studies that they've done here
you can see top 10 it Trends shaping
2019 so I'm just following the Twitter
handle that they used so Forester does a
lot of good research a lot of good
insights and so what they've done here
that makes this tweet look so good is
they've actually put an image of the
results in the Tweet so they used an
image to help gain engagement or
increase engagement notice they also
gave a shout out to somebody as well as
use some good hashtagging so good tweet
this was back in 2016 but again a good
use of the image with the Tweet so you
want to organize tweet chats to interact
with your users and bring in new
followers so you know you basically want
to be organized when you're dealing with
with chats so tweet chats enable you
send out tweets on a particular topic
use using a designated hashtag so during
a certain time to interact with your
your followers and other users so you
could do it at a specific time to really
get out a specific topic but you want to
be able to stay organized so that you
know you what you're chatting about is
reaching the Right audience and you're
getting the right following and right
engagement okay you can also pin your
best updates and tweets to your profile
so you can just use that pin and what
that's going to do is pin it to the top
and keep it there so that you know
people who go to your Twitter handle are
going to be able to see that best tweet
that you've done so what you want to do
here is use the one that's most engaging
so pinning your best update or tweet
meaning the one that's really had a lot
of Engagement meaning retweets and
followers and likes you want to do that
you want to pin that to your profile and
that will enable first-time visitors to
see it and if they could see something
that other people engaged with and
that's going to encourage them to share
and probably follow you so and and
that's always what you want to do you
always want to put your best foot
forward so pin your best tweet to your
profile so I mentioned this earlier use
tools to schedule when to publish your
tweets so here's some of the most
popular platforms you know I.E Sprout
social so if we take a look at Sprout
social here I'm Inspire social I'm
connected to my Twitter account I can
simply just start tweeting about
something here so you can see it's going
to let me know how many characters I
have remaining so to 180 to start out
with when I'm done tweeting notice I can
add an emoji I can upload media I can
tag a specific location okay I can even
you know call out a specific Twitter
profile now I could schedule this myself
or I can use the schedule below I could
pick and choose a time to schedule the
Tweet now again you want to be able to
use the Sprout social whatever social
media tool you're using to figure out
when the best time of day and the day of
the week to actually tweet when are you
getting the best engagement so ideally
that's what you want to do you want to
tweet when you're likely to get the best
engagement when those eyeballs are
actually going to look at that tweet
okay but you also want to separate out
your tweets so they're not on one on top
of another because if you actually Tweet
back to back then those tweets are just
going to get buried so if you spread
them out a little bit then you're likely
to maximize your number of Impressions
or eyeballs on that tweet so if you
schedule a tweet multiple Tweets in the
same day then post them a few hours
apart or an hour apart so that way
you're always going to get that maximum
visibility so these social media
platforms really help you and not only
scheduling but figuring out what tweets
got the best engagement and when and
then that way you can replicate that
success so again it's not just Sprout
social HootSuite buffer they'll help you
determine the exact time your audience
is most active and schedule posts to
increase traction so you know most of
these social media platforms do the same
thing so really what you want to do is
you really want to nail down that exact
time your audience is going to be most
active Okay that's the whole idea behind
using it and when you actually do tweet
you are going to get results and these
social media platforms are going to
share those results with you and then
when you understand based on your
audience behavior when they're engaging
when they're not engaging that's when
you're going to fine tune your
scheduling so what you also want to do
as you're doing these tweets as we
looked at earlier with Wendy's is run
contests or giveaways remember Randy's
gave away that free Frosty you know be
afraid to give away something if it
means more engagement more eyeballs
which could lead to basically future
customers so contests can help increase
your reach and exposure and each new
participant can be considered as a
potential follower so it also gives your
followers an opportunity to tag their
friends who would be interested in
participating so really come up this is
a great way to be creative come up with
a good idea to get your your audience
involved because what's likely going to
happen is your audience is going to
share this contest with others that
aren't following you and so what's going
to happen is when they share it you're
going to get more followers you're going
to get more eyeballs and again
potentially more customers so embed your
Twitter updates on your website you
could simply do that uh it's very simple
but when you do then people to your
website will be able to see your tweets
so if I just go to my website here if I
scroll down we actually have you know
Twitter embedded on our website as well
because we want you know people to see
what we're tweeting about and you can
see I just retweeted the simply learned
tweet at the beginning of this
particular webinar and it's showing up
in my feed here so that's when people
actually go to my website they'll be
able to see what I retweeted and that's
going to help learn out because simply
learn is likely to get some clicks on
this particular tweet from my website so
it's also a good way to keep your
website fresh and updated because if
you're an active Twitter user and you're
tweeting a lot then hey that's going to
show up on your website and it's going
to show that hey you're fresh you're
engaging you keep up to date it's just
gonna make it look good and make your
website feel fresh and not stale so
embedding your Twitter updates will help
you add new followers as well because
it's people who are coming to your
website that may not even know you have
a Twitter account so you can also do
this in a blog post and a newsletter and
other forms of communication media so it
doesn't necessarily have to be just your
website but I would definitely recommend
it because it will give a boost to your
Twitter account so now let's take a look
at the final brand watch let's take a
look at another tweet that caught our
attention when this is from PlayStation
so PlayStation is mentioning hey we got
a multi-view on Apple TV today with
support for up to four live channels on
one screen okay so you know they're
promoting a new feature that they have
with PlayStation and you can see they
supported that with an image and they
got some really good engagement here so
they're basically saying hey look what
happened to us today you know check out
this new feature that got supported on
Apple TV so you never know what's gonna
happen with a tweet when you tweet good
things are likely going to happen
whether that be somebody liking it
retweeting it or somebody adding you as
a follower something good is going to
come out of tweeting Twitter is an easy
platform to use and if you take into
account all these best practices you are
going to increase your Twitter followers
today we're going to talk about how to
increase Instagram followers today's
webinar we're gonna have some tips and
and best practices for you to take
advantage of to increase Instagram
followers so let's get started and talk
a little bit about Instagram so
Instagram is not really an up and coming
platform it is already up and coming a
lot of users fact 500 million daily
active Instagram users 500 million daily
May the user-based growth of more than
300 percent year over year so it's
growing and growing and growing it's
become more and more popular ever since
it's launched back in 2010 and then
there's more than 100 million photos
uploaded daily so it's a platform where
you can upload photos tag those photos
even use and Implement videos and photos
have become very popular with the Advent
of mobile technology that the Instagram
app makes it easy for you to post your
photos so there's no surprise there's a
growth there's no surprise there's a lot
of users there's no surprise that
there's a hundred million photos plus
uploaded daily and then there are 400
million stories posted daily so when you
post something you can create a story
out of it and there's 400 million of
those per day and then there's more than
50 billion photos shared to date so
since 2010 platform Nat which is now
owned by Facebook has become really
really popular a good place for you if
you have your own company if you have
your own brand if you have your own
product it's a good place for you to
really showcase that service that
product that brand because of the user
base how easy it is to use and the wide
reach it has for you in which to tell
your story so imagine there are lots of
photos shared today close to seven
billion dollars revenue generated
through Instagram mobile so on top of
everything I just said there's a lot of
e-commerce going on here too so
Instagram is a platform in which there's
e-commerce integrated within the
platform so as a business who offers a
products you can actually generate
revenue for yourself on the flip side
Instagram which is owned by Facebook has
an opportunity to sell advertising space
and Instagram so Instagram is an
e-commerce platform to say the least in
fact Instagram is because it's so
popular because it's part of Facebook's
advertising platform they're more than
two million advertisers on Instagram so
amongst all those stories videos and
photos and hashtags you'll see some ads
and then because you'll see ads because
you'll see users you're going to see
businesses it's just good place to
really set up shop and really tell your
story through the world of photos and
videos so 25 million plus businesses
have already migrated over to Instagram
and that's growing and growing and
growing so it's an opportunity for you
to work with other businesses so the
arrow is definitely pointing up on
Instagram there's a lot going on here
easy to use application especially when
it comes to photos and videos so we're
gonna go through some tips and tricks
today and we're going to talk about
everything there is to know about
Instagram and how to increase your
followers so let's take a look at tip
one here so because Instagram is an
application everything you do on it is
through the application now you could
certainly view a web page version on it
but you really can't do much out of that
so if I go to my Instagram accounts for
example using my desktop I could see my
profile and I can edit my profile to a
degree but everything you're doing is
through the application so when it comes
to that tip one here is take advantage
of your bio so regardless of what
industry you are you're in who you are
you really want to have a clear and
concise and compelling bio why because
this is your introduction to the world
you want people to know who you are and
because if you don't really become very
clear to people they're not going to
follow you so this is where it all
starts you need to take advantage of
your bio have a clear and concise bio
and have a link to your website or some
contact information so to me this is
where it all starts you gotta have a bio
because that's what people are going to
look at and they're going to decide
whether to follow you or not based on
primarily that bio that's where it all
starts so make sure you have a good bio
that's tip number one so you'll have to
make sure that your landing page is also
mobile optimized since most Instagram
users are on mobile so if you're going
to put a link to your website and
somebody's on the Instagram app and they
see your bio and they like it and you
have a link to your website make sure
that Lanny page they go to is mobile
optimized so tip number two everything
you do on Instagram when it comes to
posting evolves around hashtags so
that's the backbone of the platform just
like most platforms out there social
media platforms like Twitter or Facebook
Pinterest you're gonna have hashtags
accompany those posts so Instagram's no
different but in this case you really
really want to take advantage of the
hashtag so hashtags are there to help
users find your content so you want to
start out by you using hashtags that are
relevant to your business so if you're
in the food industry you're going to
post something related to food do the
appropriate amount of research to find
hashtags to describe your brand and also
are being searched on Instagram so what
does that mean that means do a little
bit of homework on Instagram you know
see what searches or see what other
brands in your industry are using for
hashtags don't be afraid to use the same
hashtag but mix it up hashtags are
important so don't be afraid to put a
hashtag in there that really defines
what your business is about but if it's
relevant use other hashtags that are
popular or people are using to find
information so mix it up but the key
here is relevancy you want to make sure
you align your Hashtags with your
content and making sure the connection
between the hashtag and the content is
relevancy so using the popular tags on
your photos or videos might get you some
immediate engagement but it may not help
with future goals like long-term
engagement new interested fires and
sales so here really what I'm trying to
say is look pick and choose your
hashtags carefully because if you use
something broad or something
non-relevant yeah you may get that click
to your Instagram page but that doesn't
necessarily mean somebody's going to
follow you or that doesn't really mean
somebody's going to be interested in
what you have to offer so if you use
something really popular and Broad yes
you're going to get short-term
gratification but not long-term interest
tip number three post your content at
the right time so according to sprout
social which is a social media
scheduling platform among other things
so they deal with a lot of people using
their platform and posting content via
their platform they have data and
they're telling us based on the data
they've collected that the best time to
post this between 2 and 3 P.M and the
best day to post is Thursday now that
may be all fine and true according to a
sprout social study and and so you may
want to go with this 2 to 3 P.M and this
is probably local in case you're
wondering what time zone you're
referring to so this is all local to you
so go ahead and try that out try two to
three p.m on Thursday the thing is what
you're going to have to do eventually is
figure out what the best time to post is
okay so if you're pointing out a lot of
content and you're putting out content
throughout the week at certain times of
the day or throughout the day you're
gonna have to determine which time of
day and what day is generating the best
engagement for you who's looking at your
post at what point of the day what day
of the week and so you're going to
really have to lean on a social media
platform to help you determine that
because they're going to have the data
that you need to determine what the best
time of day to post is okay so we'll
talk about social media platforms here
shortly we just know that when you post
post with some rationale in mind ask
yourself before you even push that
publish button or before you even
schedule that post this time of day in
this day of the week makes sense so you
always want to post at the right time
because you could be missing your
audience so remember when you do this
you're going to be working with some
platform and Instagram also has some
analytics for business accounts so
Instagram will also give you some
feedback as to how you're supposed to
perform it and we're going to talk about
that here shortly as well so let's move
over to tip four here so steal followers
from your competitors okay so if you're
dealing in a very competitive industry
and your competitors have a lot of
followers it's very very easy to see
who's following them so the easiest way
to do this is just interact with your
competitors followers you could follow a
user like or comment on their photos and
so the more you engage with people the
more you stand to gain from them so you
could see who your competitors followers
are and you can add them as a follower
just by following them so start engaging
with them if they're liking your
competitor's brand then what the chance
of them like in your brand could be
great so check out who your competitors
followers are if they seem like somebody
who you would want to be following your
brand then go ahead and interact with
them and how you interact is again you
can like something that they post or you
can comment on something that they
posted and engage with them okay it
doesn't take that much time it's a good
way to gain followers so if we're on
Instagram we can simply just click on
the Brand's followers so here I can see
the Sprint has 127 followers and here I
can see all the followers and what I
could do is simply just click on one of
the followers and I can go to their
profile and from there I could see what
they've posted in terms of videos and
images and I can like or comment so just
doing something as simple as this gets
you an opportunity to engage with
somebody who can then turn around and
follow you so tip five okay for
sponsored posts and product reviews so a
number of ways you could do this here so
pay for a sponsored post so you can find
an influer who satisfies a couple of
requirements they have large following
and an email address in the profile so
you can connect with them and ask them
for sponsored post pricing so it's as
simple as that as reaching out to
somebody who has a large following okay
so if you do this then it's going to put
shoe in front of a large number of
people and so by doing this it'll help
expose your brand to that larger
audience and help build your credibility
because you're connecting with somebody
who has a large audience as well so do a
little bit of homework find people out
there in your industry who has a large
following and make sure they have that
email address in their profile so you
can contact them and when you contact
them you know ask them for sponsored
post pricing so if the influencer has an
email address then they're open to
sponsored post or shout out so that's
the key so they gotta have that email
address us and when they do then it's
all about asking them and connecting
with them on being a sponsor to one of
your posts okay you want to get yourself
out there in front of people this is the
quickest way to do that okay so tip six
we want to use geotags for easier
discoverability okay so tag your images
videos or stories by tagging the
location City or venue where it was
posted from so very easy to do as you're
posting just go ahead and and there's an
option in there to say hey where are you
located or what city are you located in
so locations have their own feed and
stories which you can contribute to so
go ahead and add that extra element to
your tags so if somebody's in that
location the chance of them engaging are
going to be great and it's good for
local businesses because if you're local
and you're posting your location then
again somebody in that location is
likely to engage with you so tip seven
use Instagram stories to track followers
and grow your user base So Stories are
really big feature on Instagram so what
stories could be used for is just show
footage of an environment so it could be
your office it could be your home it
could be you know the playground it
could be the golf course it could be
anywhere that you want to show vintage
of so you want to post new relevant to
your industry so if you're in the food
industry hey why not go in the back into
the kitchen and post a story about how a
particular bread or cake is made okay
show off your product so if you are in
that food industry and say you're in the
pizza making business perfect
opportunity to show people via an
Instagram Story how to make that pizza
and how you make that pizza what
ingredients you use how unique is your
particular product and that's really
what you want to get across when you do
a story you want to show something
unique and relevant that's going to
grasp people's attention you can promote
a company event so if you're celebrating
say 200 000 subscribers create a YouTube
video or you can create an Instagram
story it works just as well so you can
endorse your company's blog post you can
post positive user reviews so these are
all features of a story increased
interactivity with polls sliders Etc and
then you can also mention other
companies that work with or follow you
so great use of Instagram stories is do
a shout out to somebody else so
Instagram stories is a really big
feature with Instagram check it out you
know you just do a search for Instagram
stories in fact let's get some of you
users involved what best practices do
you have when creating Instagram stories
why don't you go ahead and share your
Instagram story with us by putting that
Instagram story in the comment section
below so we want to get everybody
involved here because there's a
thousands upon thousands of great
Instagram stories out there to be shown
and viewed and engaged with so go ahead
and share your Instagram story if you
have any other tips or tricks then go
ahead and put those in the comments
section so that everybody can can
benefit from them so the only thing to
keep in mind when you're creating these
stories is what are your followers
interested in seeing so your stories
could teach you promote something to
your user base so always keep that in
the back of your mind you know for me I
always go back to what industry are you
in if you're in the food industry hey
you know people who are following you
are interested in food if you're a pizza
company you know show off that pizza if
you're a bakery show off how you make
your Breads and goods baked goods
whatever it is you have show it off
because if somebody's following you
that's what they're interested in so tip
number eight highlight important stories
so you want to highlight highlights
serve as the easiest way to create a
first impression for a potential
follower so with highlights can be used
to tease what your content's about
create a trailer for what your brand
offers promote and promote your product
so highlights are there it's a good
feature it's a first impression for
potential follower so it teases what the
content's about it creates a trailer so
speak for your brand and promote your
product so use highlights and again any
users out there who have good examples
of highlights go ahead and put those in
the content section or comment section
right below this video so remember
stories have only a 24 hour lifespan so
highlights can be used to give them a
second wind okay so highlights serve a
purpose it teases what the content's
about it promotes the product and it
really kind of accentuates that story
tip number nine ask for followers so
sometimes people need a little push
before they can follow you on Instagram
even if they enjoy your content so you
can ask users to become your followers
in the caption the comment section or
even work it into your content so in
other words when you're posting
something don't be afraid to say hey
follow me you know I got some good stuff
here be confident you don't want to do
it for every post of course but you know
pick and choose if you feel you have a
really good post you know really good
image that you think is going to gain a
lot of followers and engagers then and
you don't necessarily need to put a
caption in there but if if it is popular
then go ahead and say hey this is a
popular post you know think about
following me or put something in the
comments section you want to do it kind
of succinctly you don't want to be
begging but just working into some
degree okay but don't be afraid have
some confidence in asking for followers
so when you do this it's very similar to
how we do it on YouTube so you can ask
viewers to subscribe to their channels
at the end of the video so it's if on
YouTube basically you're saying hey if
you like what we have go ahead and
subscribe it's no different on Instagram
if you have something you've posted just
go and said hey you like this you know
go ahead and follow us so that's simple
so tip number 10 take on the latest
trends to get more followers so align
your content to cater to trendy topics
or hashtags to improve engagement and
discoverability so really what we're
trying to say here is your competitors
follow influencers what are the latest
trends and you can get an idea the
latest trends by you looking in it
hashtags so what hashtags are trending
which ones are people using the most so
really what you want to do is whatever's
trending in your industry you know ride
that wave so to speak now it doesn't
have to take on your entire profile but
there's nothing wrong with one or two
posts if something's really taking on
popularity then go ahead and post about
it as well you know for example in the
wine industry if there's a new wine that
really came out that's really gaining
some popularity go ahead and post about
it with the same hashtag and with the
unique hashtag so don't be afraid to you
know ride the wave of popularity so to
speak because it shows that you know you
know what you're talking about it adds
some credibility and it's going to get
some you know viewers over to your
Instagram profile so keep in mind you
need to keep your content relevant
because if your audience is interested
in what you have to offer then they're
going to be engaged however you know if
you're joining the discussion in a
relevant manner keep it in mind whether
your audience will interact or not is
important but just always keep in mind
you always want to stay within your
industry and relevancy for your target
audience so tip number 11 run contests
and giveaways and so just like on
YouTube just like on Facebook I mean
Instagram is no different you can
increase reach and exposure by running
contests since most followers would tag
their friends to let them know about it
it's a good idea to run contests and so
it's an idea of a contest well again if
you're running a pizza parlor you know
you could say hey what's your favorite
pizza or give me your favorite pizza
ideas and you can run a contest and you
know you can have people even create
their own pizza and post an image of it
you can have people create stories on
the best ways in which they create pizza
or their experience in another pizza
parlor there's lots of things you can do
to create a contest and you don't always
have to give something away you could
just do something for fun especially if
you have a lot of followers if you have
a lot of followers and somebody's going
to take part in it so don't be afraid to
run contests just to make it fun and
light it up a little bit so each tag can
bring you a new audience member who
could be a potential follower so anytime
you run a contest people are gonna tag
their friends to let them know about
that contest so those friends are gonna
come over and likely engage so that's
the beauty of running a contest or
giveaway is chances are words gonna
spread and it's going to get you some
new followers so that's the the end
benefits so to speak but the real
benefit is keeping your audience engaged
so tip number 12 we want to stay
consistent with posts so having a
consistent pace and theme for your post
can have a huge impact to convert
visitors so when we say consistent you
know if you're again that pizza parlor
stay within Pizza you could Branch out a
little maybe and talk about salads or
talk about beverages to you know as a
complementary factor to the pizza okay
but don't talk about hamburgers if
you're focused in on pizza so we want to
stay consistent with your theme this
method involves less effort with a
faster production of Instagram content
so than me what we're really trying to
say here is focus stay focused on who
you are if you do that if you're
consistent and you're gaining some
followers and that's what people are
coming to you for the content that
you're good at for the industry you're
in okay so if you start varying it and
branching out then it's going to muddy
the water supposed so to speak and
you're probably going to get less
engagement so set a theme on Instagram
by maintaining consistency and your
personality filters colors and layouts
and really what I'm referring to is post
and when you have post something you're
you're really creating a personality for
yourself okay so if you're in fashion
for example and you're in the jeans
industry well jeans jeans jeans right
that's your personality accentuate it
with different outfits related to jeans
but you know when you start talking
about dresses and shoes and that kind of
blurs your your personality a bit so if
you stay consistent within jeans and
outfits that go with jeans then I think
people are going to start to pick up on
that personality so tip 13 keep track of
your Instagram following so you can
analyze the growth of your Channel with
tools like socialblade I could tell you
how many followers you lost over time
and how engaged they are okay so you can
use data gather from here and from
Instagram business account to diagnose
where you're faltering so let's take a
look at socialblade as an example here
so if I go over here I'm going to go to
socialblade here I can enter in
basically any account after I register
and I could see how that account has
performed you know where they rank you
know how many uploads they have what
country they focused on one industry and
the beauty here is I could see and I'm
looking at YouTube as example I could
see you know how my post to perform well
you could do this for Instagram you
could do it for Facebook so you can
really get an idea of how your account's
performing so socialblade is a great
platform for measuring and again you do
also have Instagram business insights so
with Instagram business insights
basically what you're going to do is
you're going to go to your app right and
then from the app you could basically
look at your insights from there so in
the app itself you're going to click on
the upper right three lines and from
there you're going to see insights and
when you go to insights you're also
going to see you know what your reach is
how many Impressions and some engagement
metrics terms of your audience where
they're located the age range okay
you're gonna also see some content
related information so there's a lot you
could see from the the Instagram
insights analytics insights but you can
also see additional information from
socialblade so so the key here is when
you're looking at your data you want to
look for patterns in post what posts
receive the most amount of Engagement so
if you see something working obviously
replicate it you know you don't want to
replicate it immediately but make note
of it and use it for future content so
tip 14 use Instagram ads so Instagram
ads give you complete control over
advertisements so how they appear and
who sees them so with Instagram ads you
can run photos you can run videos
carousels slideshows stories so we
mentioned this on other webinars for
Facebook advertising it's worth
repeating so if I go back into say
Facebook ads manager I can pick and
choose my placements and really what I
want to do is pick and choose for
example Instagram and so I have
Instagram feed I have Instagram stories
so and I could see with the video
requirement or the media requirement is
for running on Instagram so with
Instagram you can run stories you can
run videos single image ads you can run
Carousel Sue really you could put your
best forward meaning take the post
that's performing well and maybe you
want to advertise that promote it so
you're going to run this through
Facebook ads manager and it's going to
tell you you know what your audience
size is your potential reach okay what
your daily results would be so you're
going to get all that information when
you run your ads on Facebook ads manager
but it's a great opportunity for you to
really push forward if you're running a
promotion it's really an opportunity for
you to push forward that promotion other
advantages scalable pricing self-serve
and instant robust reporting and highly
refined audience retargeting so all of
that is in the Facebook ads manager you
can get all the reporting you know you
need meaning you know who saw the ad did
they click on it okay you can refine
that target audience you can go back
into Facebook ads manager and refine who
your audience is so lots of flexibility
here on advertising on Instagram but the
key here is if you want to run
advertising on Instagram you know think
about what it is you're trying to
promote if you feel something needs to
get promoted then go ahead and you know
you can either again reach out to
somebody and have them sponsor it or you
can run it as an advertisement so let's
move on to tip 15. so we want to create
visually attractive and eye-catching ads
so if you are gonna run ads you know
here's some things to keep in mind okay
you want to use images that are natural
and seem native okay you don't want to
use any stock photography first off you
want to use something that you've done
okay you want to minimize the amount of
text so let the image do the talking you
want to ensure your caption relates to
the image and resonates with your
audience okay so you have an opportunity
to add some text below the image okay so
make sure it resonates and then of
course use hashtags to show your ads to
Target your audience but a wider
relevant audience so hashtags do play a
role here as well so these are some tips
if you're going to create ads you want
to take these into account the whole
point of the ad is to get people over to
either web page or to your profile page
okay so that they can engage and take
action so Instagram ads will help
showcase your product service or brand
in a way that's memorable and unique so
if you really want to get your vision
your brand your product out there in
front of a lot of people then
advertising on Instagram is a good way
to do that so since we've been talking
about pizza throughout this webinar
there's a good Instagram a profile here
about pizza you know I'm getting hungry
just looking at this hopefully this is
an example for all veg and non-vege
pizza consumers I mean you can see this
profile here they got the website you
know they got the handle okay so they
have a lot of followers so you know if
I'm in the pizza industry I can go ahead
and you know click on their followers
and see who who's following them who
they're following so some really good
shots of pizza here it looks like you
know a lot of people are wearing were
involved in this you could see lots of
different examples here some cute ones
you know some funny ones some humorous
ones so you know just taking a look at
something like pizza which you know most
people enjoy you know most and you can
kind of appreciate you know how much of
an advantage Instagram can be because it
really you can accentuate photos you can
have fun with it you can really run some
contests here you know give us your best
pizza photo so here you know you could
say use daily Pizza as a hashtag for
feature okay so they're even encouraging
you to use a specific hashtag so you can
really do a lot here on Instagram this
is just a good example of what you can
do and have fun with you know with an
example like pizza just to give you some
ideas so let's move on to tip 16 take
advantage of Instagram tools so you can
use scheduling tools like later
HootSuite and buffer so I can't stress
this enough you know when it comes to
measuring the engagement of your
Instagram posts you're definitely going
to need a social media tool so you're
also going to need it if you do a lot of
you know posting on Instagram so let's
take a look at an example we'll use
later.com so if I go to later here I
could see you know I can use this to
upload my images to my profile so here
you can see it's scheduled throughout
the day of the week so that way we're
not overlapping you know we're
scheduling based on the times of the day
that people are going to look at this so
you know here I could see you know
particular stories if any stories are
posted okay I can look at it from a
weekly or monthly preview I could see
what's been posted okay and more
importantly as a schedule tool I can
also see the analytics I could see you
know how many were posted how many
followers so this this is really
important because you know if my profile
is growing I want to be able to see what
post perform best what the audience was
like you know by gender by age by
location so again I can look at it by
post-performance story or hashtag
analytics as well so later really goes
into details about you know what's
driving engagement so here you can see
some hashtags that this become
particular company is using on Instagram
so here you can see how many posts with
this hashtag you know and what and kind
of Engagement did they receive do they
receive likes comments Impressions how
much reach do they get how many saves
and it really just does go into detail
so later does a good job I like this
platform especially for Instagram it's
great for scheduling but more important
you know in addition to the Instagram
analytics you can really lean on you
know this particular platform to get a
really good idea as to you know how a
particular poster performing remember if
a post is performing you want to reuse
it at a certain point in time okay learn
from Best Practices learn from what's
working learn from what's not working if
something's not working then don't do it
again so you can really get a good
breakdown in here and later.com so
remember these tools place an emphasis
on automation okay enabling you to
automatically post at a scheduled time
so you want to lock it in at a certain
period of time and not have to worry
about it so it allows you to really hone
in on that particular time of the day
and day of the week so that you're
really maximizing your chances of
getting good engagement okay so develop
your own signature style so set up a
style and content theme so that you're
able to stand out amongst the various
competitors so you know again just going
back to our pizza example lots of good
photos of pizza you know this is their
style this is who they are you know
they're not a particular brand they're
just you know people who like pizza okay
and they're having fun with it okay so
that's their style you know they're
posting really good shots of all this
different types of pizza different
styles different toppings and just to
give you an idea of how popular pizza is
and what you can do with it okay so yeah
and this is a good basic example
um of what you can do with something as
simple as pizza so don't be afraid to
experiment you know try something
different with your profile you know do
something different you don't always
have to follow what everybody else is
doing that's the great thing about
Instagram it allows you to be free and
creative in fact if anybody has any
styles that have worked for them you
know feel free to put something in the
comment section we'd love to hear your
thoughts so tip 18 use user engagement
to your advantage so I just mentioned
that using the later example so we want
to be able to learn from what's working
and not working so user generated
content shows off your brand be
authentic and improves your relationship
with your followers so you know you want
to be unique when with the content that
you're posting so if you do that you're
likely to build that relationship and
you know increase your followers and you
want to be able to see of that user
generated content that ugc which is
performing which is not performing okay
so basically your followers and your
audience are telling you what's working
and not working so take advantage of
that remember going back to hashtags you
can set up your own unique hashtag and
ask your users to post images or videos
relating to that which you can post in
your Brand's account so just like the
whole pizza thing they're saying hey
look you know use daily pizza for a
feature okay that's a good example of
something you can do as well so you
could set up a unique hashtag and say
hey use this hashtag and that'll help
you gain some followers that'll help you
gain some notoriety and some visibility
on your platform tip 19 use high quality
images and videos just like on YouTube
just like on Facebook Instagram's no
different in images must be of high
quality authentic and original I mean
again one more time going back to the
pizza these images look to be pretty
high quality I mean if you have a decent
mobile phone that's all it takes a
mobile phone with a camera that is
that's all it usually takes you know you
want to be able to get that that right
shot you don't want to use anything
that's of low quality because it really
is going to take away from you know the
story you're trying to tell so you don't
have to be professional per se just make
sure what you're posting whether it be
video or whether it be an image is of
high quality and remember videos needs
to be fun and informational about
causing the user to lose interest so you
know if you're going to create a video
you know go ahead and you know make you
can make it short make it fun okay you
can see here these guys are just showing
you how pizza's made doesn't take a long
time they're just going through the
motions they're not boring you with
details they're not talking really quick
and easy just to give you an idea it
doesn't have to be as serious it can be
fun so video content needs to be fun and
informational without causing users to
lose interest that's the key short sweet
unique authentic and fun have fun with
it so worth repeating don't use stock
images on Instagram because you know
they don't really bode well for your
particular brand you know it's Instagram
it allows you to post original content
that's the whole purpose of it okay and
on the video side be concise high
quality and informational enough okay so
you have to hold the user's attention
here so when we say concise you know
don't make it a five minute video
obviously make it high quality relevant
to what you're trying to offer and if
you do that you're likely going to hold
the user's attention so tip 20 promote
your Instagram page and other social
media channels so Facebook and Instagram
are part of the same family so this
seems like a natural but you know don't
be afraid to promote it on other
channels like Pinterest or or YouTube
The whole idea is to get users to your
Instagram page and encourage them to
follow it so you know you can always put
that URL in you know other platforms
like YouTube nothing wrong with that at
all okay you can also promote your page
offline with print ads and during other
relevant events and then I would even
take that as to further as you probably
see you know an Instagram logo on a web
page along with other social media icons
so you always want to help promote
Instagram on your web page as well but
you can do it for offline with print ads
so you can simply just put you know
whatever your your slug is for Instagram
whatever your ID is whatever you're
using on Instagram that's what you can
use don't be afraid to promote it
offline or online social media marketing
tools social media always a great topic
to talk about so we're gonna finish up
all our digital marketing tools with
social media we talked about SEO paid
competition affiliate email you know web
analytics it's just appropriate to
finish up with social media because
social media has so many tools available
so many okay the first one I can think
about here is HootSuite HootSuite is a
great social media marketing tool to use
okay it's a freemium okay you can set up
a free trial here you you basically a
base account and then uh you can use
HootSuite to do a lot of things anything
from setting up landing pages to
actually publishing content to listening
HootSuite to me is one of the most
powerful social media marketing tools
available you got buffer buffer is a
paid version but you can actually set up
a low cost or free account actually on
Buffer and then move to a paid account
okay you got tweet deck it's been around
a long time that is actually free and I
would recommend tweetdeck and we're
going to take a look at that here in a
couple minutes okay and then you got
Sprouts all social Sprout social is
another social marketing platform
similar to HootSuite do a lot of
reporting a lot of publishing you can a
lot of listening and so we're going to
take a look at Sprout shows for today as
well before we do that let's go over why
these tools are important to us from a
social media perspective you're pumping
out a lot of content so you need to be
able to smartly efficiently you know
schedule and manage your post okay so
you're not just working likely with just
one platform like Facebook you're
probably on a number of different
platforms depending on your business
depending on your bandwidth depending on
what you're selling your products Etc
your audience obviously has a lot to do
with it you know it could be Instagram
Pinterest you want to be able to
consolidate all that and manage it in
one place and that's what social media
marketing tools do they allow you to
manage everything in one place so if you
can manage everything in one place then
these social social media marketing
platforms need to be able to make it
easy for you to add and manage different
accounts okay so a lot of them have the
ability for you to add you know not just
one Twitter account but multiple Twitter
accounts and not just one social media
platform but multiple social media
platforms and a good social media
marketing so worth its weight will help
you monitor the results so monitor
social media posts that help Drive leads
and sales in other words you're going to
have a lot of different metrics
associated with each social media
marketing platform okay which one is
actually doing its job okay so you want
to be able to easily manage these
platforms applications and websites very
efficiently okay so instead of having to
log into each platform is log into one
place get a sense of what's been posted
what the engagement is did they purchase
Etc and what you want to do is be able
to individually customize every social
media media post across different
platforms so it just makes it a lot
easier to do that in these social media
marketing tools okay you don't want to
send out a blanket message across
different platforms you want to be able
to go ahead and customize a post
depending on what that post is depending
on what the product is what time of day
what target market what target audience
so customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
Advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand Advocate
who's not a brand Advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual posts on real-time data so if
for example you post something using one
of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like Sprouts social and HootSuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further Ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are running ads on Facebook or
you're posting on Facebook as an example
or any platform in general that
platform's going to have its own metrics
if you will so for example Facebook has
something called Facebook Insight so
you'll be able to actually see you know
what's been posted based on you know
last seven days in this example how many
page views you're getting engagements
recent posts so just to let you know yes
you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
Facebook ads okay you can go right into
Facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can measure all that in one place so if
we log into Sprout social I can set up
these accounts right into Sprout social
so I don't have to log into Twitter
individually or Facebook individually I
can link them up all within Sprout
social and then I can go to reports just
like I can with Facebook insights and
then once I'm in Facebook excuse me once
I'm in Sprouts social reporting then I
can go ahead just like I can in Facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me I can jump into you know Facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so I don't have
to log into Facebook directly I can see
you know the Impressions the engagement
the clicks over a period of time I can
see my audience growth I can see my
publishing Behavior how often my
publishing I can see the top post
individually I could see Impressions by
day you know a lot of this same material
same information is already in Facebook
insights so if it's available on
Facebook insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like Sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know I can go to Instagram you
know and look at Instagram data or I can
look at Twitter information so you want
to be able to efficiently jump from one
platform to the other using in this
example Sprout social now as I mentioned
as part of one of the benefits of a
social media tools that you can publish
content you want to be able to publish
content because you want to be able to
organize and schedule accordingly you
don't want to be submitting and
Publishing content right after one
another okay you want to be able to
spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is Click compose select a profile write
whatever we need to do you can schedule
it for tomorrow at a specific time and
there you go voila schedule so this is
on Twitter okay so you know we could
choose another platform here it's just
that easy to schedule so you want to be
able to schedule accordingly because
again when you schedule something then
you want to look at the behavior of it
so it's just as simple as going from
publishing to reporting and then based
on when something got published you
could see the reaction of it and react
to it so another thing here that I like
about it's about social food sweet a lot
of these other platforms do it really
well you got listening tools so you can
listen in on conversations that are
being had for example uh mail delivery
you know if we do mail delivery and
Twitter search we'll be able to see
what's been tweeted about mail
deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can refine our
search and choose a specific location a
radius to hone in if we're local okay so
this is Sprout socials example of
listening here let's take a look at
another example I'm in later.com so
later very similar to sprout social in
that it does a lot of the same things
you can actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing I like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see a calendar and
what's been scheduled so I could see
today I have scheduled something
scheduled at 1 15 local time and again I
have five profiles set up for this
account account so I can pick and choose
the profile that I want to publish to so
it just makes it that much easier and I
can visually see it and that's important
so here I can click on media library so
the one thing about later.com is that
you know you have a library of images
that potentially you can reuse so if I
click on this image here okay I can get
a sense of when it was used and I can
view it on a calendar I can out label
for it so that's another benefit to
later is that they have this media
library here they have conversations so
I can actually connect to a platform and
listen in on conversations that are
being hacked similar to The Listening
tool in Sprout social and they have
analytics so you can actually see right
in later.com how your particular social
media platform is performing so I could
see it here over seven days I can see
the number of followers have increased I
could see the growth rate I can see the
number of Impressions that I received
okay so I want to be able to see how my
particular platforms performing over a
period of time so I can look at reach
the law profile views website clicks
okay so I can get a lot of good insights
here right in the analytics platform of
later you can look at specific post
performance so if we posted something I
could see basically how many likes it
received how many comments Impressions
the reach and then if I wanted to I can
click on details and get more specific
information on it engagement rate okay
Discovery actions comments saves Etc so
later.com goes into some nice detail
about post performance they even have
data on hashtags so if you use an
hashtag you can actually see how many
times the hashtag's been used or saved
how many Impressions it's received okay
so they really go into some nice detail
here about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool I really like I've been using for a
long time and that's tweet Tech so what
tweetdec does is connect with your
Twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
Twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here I can see this is my feed here
okay I can see some notifications I can
see specific messages then on this
column I can see activity okay so I can
add different columns here if I wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
could see I can look for what's trending
as an example so I'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now I
can go in and see okay these are all the
different things that are trending on
Twitter so you can actually add a column
and pay attention to something really
specific okay so for example search okay
so right now I have men's health but I
could type in let's just say a World Cup
okay so I can see the you got the
Cricket World Cup you got you know the
soccer football World Cup going on so
you know we could pick a particular
topic to follow if we wanted to so again
here I'm following Men's Health so I can
now see you know everything that's been
posted on men's health now if I click on
for example one of these hashtags here
that's trending I can actually see who's
tagging or using that hashtag Friday
feeling in their tweets and so the whole
idea behind you know tweetdeck it serves
up a interesting overview so to speak of
not only your account but you know a
specific topic or what's trending or you
know other things that are being said so
if you really want to pay attention to
your brand or something really specific
like you know your competitors or a
specific product then you can just do a
search on that and so that's the great
thing about tweetdeck it allows you to
kind of just look and listen in on
everything going on in Twitter thanks
Rob with that we've come to the end of
this complete social media marketing
tutorial I hope you guys enjoyed this do
like and share it thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more from Simply
learn